thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
good morning everyone
how are you all doing it's been almost
24 hours since the start we're about a
third in which is pretty dope
Tim is getting some breakfast and some
coffee I got up like three hours ago I
had some other stuff to do
so I've been awake for a while since 7am
a little bit rough but it's all right I
got this uh nootropic drink that Tim got
me so hopefully I'll be all right how's
everyone doing
I'm about to have a chat with Peter
and see where we're at
uh
and yeah basically
all right I think Tim's back
all right excellent Tim is back so we're
gonna hop on off call with Peter soon
and we'll end by soon I mean like now
and um I'm gonna see what what it's what
Peter's been up to because I don't think
either of us really know
so that's kind of cool
yep
I'm about to
I'm just setting something up real quick
yeah
I just want to see if I can get shot
only on my
okay let's just
actually render anything oh it's done
if it was dark
oh man that's not bad all right cool
oh yeah I was just setting this up
stream
so now I have I can't see it because
it's Overexposed but you'll have to
trust me it's like
a little web page that just shows me
Chat full screen so I can uh
in case any of you are interested for
whatever reason it's like Studio
channel.com
chat.html but
that's just gonna let me have chat like
here
on my iPad so I can actually use my both
my two monitors
Tim why are your eyes always red
because I never sleep enough because he
never sleeps enough
in case you didn't hear that all right
so uh Peter
Peter's getting cold let's see if Peter
picks up when I call him
because
you reckon
let me try it yeah this is what he's
doing
picked up
Tim thought you wouldn't pick up all
right let me quickly stop the music she
tend to not disturb off on Discord
hey
Peter yeah no I just I had Discord open
oh that's lucky
all right so
um
we basically
oh is that blueberry that looks like I
don't know it just look like some
blueberry hero get something yeah it is
kind of cool all right um I guess I'll
get the Whiteboard so that streaming
roughly knows what's going on but
basically Peter like tell us a story
like what have you done and uh what do
you think of do you have any idea like
idea Evolution iterations and what
what's new
I'm gonna show
him so if I Sharon
Sherman yeah yeah
do you want my stream to see it as well
ah you can show it if you want well
we'll see we'll go with the Whiteboard
for now
yeah so I've been working on quite a few
things uh actually I'll have to re-add
the enemy manager's clip real quick
because I accidentally removed it from
here
enemy
um but yeah so I've been mainly working
on
uh pickup systems uh like making sure we
can pick up guns and the coffee and we
can drop everything off and that kind of
stuff
uh
yeah I think this should work now so if
I just hit play
uh oh hang on I have to re-enable a
setting in the camera controller because
I was working on
the
root motion movement in which case we
cannot have this
this so okay here we go
so I made it so
you can first of all like if I kill this
dude he will drop a gun uh-huh
and I can oh and I can pick it up using
the x button on a controller
yeah uh and you get you get the ammo
from the gun if you know I will probably
want to check gun type eventually
um
and the enemy can actually shoot back
and you do lose Health which
uh I don't know if we want like
to make it so that the player just dies
or if we want to make it so that you get
shot and you lose coffee yeah maybe it
would be more fun if the player was
wearing like armor like you know what is
the best car Mandalorian armor and so
basically yeah the best car yeah and so
basically you don't like take damage but
of course it knocks you back and thus
you spill coffee and that's really the I
think that'll just be a little bit more
interesting than just a health bar or
just Health that's like every game does
that you know
yeah well I want to really reinforce
that the asset you're protecting here is
the coffee
which
um you can see I have a coffee and I can
pick it up oh excellent are you holding
it oh awesome yeah that's great
um
no currently you do not lose coffee if
you get shot yeah because I wanted to
run that past you but you can drop it
off does our guy have hands or we just
wanted to float no hey I don't think
yeah so he'll just float kind of like
Rayman style in front of you like the
right Rayman glove or whatever
yeah yeah
um
so and funnily enough you can actually
end up if you if you get it just right
you can shoot the coffee off the board
which I don't want to keep that
let me quickly share Australia just
wants to see
all right I'm gonna show them yep all
right
stream can say now um I was gonna just
show them on my screen later when I play
this but I guess since you're you've
added so much stuff and it's detailed
you might as well it's funny how they
float sometimes I kind of like that
almost I mean the qualities yeah it
actually adds some difficulty because
you can't shoot them when they go up
into the air that's right yeah
because you can't aim up or down yeah
did you like what I did by the way with
the camera how you can kind of tilt it a
little bit
yeah I actually quite like it because I
wasn't sure if I wanted to keep that
fully
I think we should keep it
um because then we have to actually make
do you know put in some effort for the
Horizon basically
but I might just do fog for that yeah
could be fun
um
but yeah so you can actually end up
shooting weapons that the enemy dropped
off the board like I did there which I
actually I don't know if we want to keep
it
um I think it's could be kind of
interesting like you're shooting and you
you kind of can't just go blasting
wildly because you might end up losing
all the loot are we gonna have a flat
ground we might not no yeah I don't
think we will have a flat ground I think
I think that there definitely needs to
be so what I was picturing was obviously
like in the beginning I think what what
like where you start is in the you know
the cafe tent so there's like a tent
somewhere on the Battleground where the
coffee is made and you have to get to
the General's tent so it's kind of like
you have to get it's like capture the
flag in a way right it's from one point
to another but there may be just like
some kind of tense that Tim could make
um and so that's kind of your spawn
point so obviously my point is there
will probably be structures in this
environment
um and then I guess I like what I think
because you didn't do any
like terrain generation or anything
right Peter
yeah that's fine um what because what I
think I'll do this stream is I'll
basically grab some Pearl and noise
generate like a landscape uh maybe even
like some Cliffs and some Ravines with
water or just something I just want to
kind of have fun with this a bit maybe
even spend today the whole day like 12
hours just generating like a really nice
landscape because I think that'll be
cool
um and then Tim can probably make some
assets like uh apart from the ones he's
already making where there's like some
tents and some structures and maybe like
some trenches you know
I don't know what else
um and then yeah that's kind of going to
be my plan I think for today just
dressing this all up and uh because
basically you could say already the
gameplay Loop in a way exists it's just
very not polished and not kind of fun
because the enemies don't really have
much strategy to them but you know in
terms of like you have the coffee you
can pick it up you can put can you can
you put it down yeah
yeah
um if I go
pick it up over here
uh you can yes the B button and it will
just yeah I can say that actually like a
physics object
yeah
well I could probably to make it more
obvious I might even add like a an arrow
that just goes like this down kind of
like an arrow that's like pointing down
to the coffee like a you know like a
cartoon Arrow or something that's just
like dude you left your coffee here and
maybe even some text on the screen
that's like you know protect the coffee
or whatever
um how like one question I did have is
how do you think we should show like the
coffee spilling like should that
actually be
physics based or should that just be
arbitrary like when you take a hit you
lose x amount of Health
I would love it if it was actually a
physics based how would we do that and
and well I'm thinking yeah it doesn't
have to be anything complicated
technically
we could literally just make it so that
instead of blood coming out you just see
like so a couple of coffee colored cubes
flying out from the kind of a coffee cup
um I was trying to open this and it was
already open that's hilarious about me
um
because I think I don't know it would be
cool if we actually had cubes in a cup
and you could actually see the level
decrease but I think Tim did some
testing with that no no I don't we made
it you didn't I don't know that was for
the deadline right it was the yeah it
was the player death
that you did because that was over 2 000
cubes
yeah I mean if we just have a couple
hundred cubes
maybe a hundred
yeah maybe I want to help
and you know
every time you get hit we just pick you
know the top
the like surface level ones and applying
upwards Force to them like an outboard
Sports
I think it could be interesting
we probably need like a coffee health
bar right
some indication yeah well I I don't know
I don't want to do it like boring and
just have a health bar you know
for the coffee because I mean I think
like I don't know that's why I think it
would be cool if somehow
this doesn't really make too much sense
though especially in this perspective
but you know if you did have
theoretically if this coffee cup was
huge and you just had like I don't know
a hundred cubes in there and then
obviously as you get knocked back like
just that motion or if you walk too fast
or whatever they will spill out like I
think ideally that's what we would go
for because
I think it would be really interesting
because since I'm gonna add like terrain
and stuff it won't just be flat you know
if you jump too much if you roll around
too much if you just like Sprint too
much like that physical if you like
suddenly stop and change directions now
I think that could be such a cool
mechanic and something unique because
the coffee would spill out a bit
and so you kind of have to be really
careful and you possibly have to put it
down if you're planning to be an acrobat
and fight enemies
yeah yeah because there definitely has
to be like a good reason for putting
down the cost yeah yeah that's what I'm
thinking at the moment like you just
shoot normally obviously but my idea was
that like shooting would be wildly
inaccurate you know it would be like hip
firing a sniper rifle you know because
you're carrying you can't you can't use
two hands to fight the sniper rifle
which is like a one-handed thing and you
have to like you know it's not going to
be comfortable so therefore as soon as
you put down the coffee your shooting is
so much more kind of accurate and so
much better
um
but obviously that leaves the coffee
vulnerable but also you have the freedom
to jump around take cover do like
whatever the Crouch I don't know do
whatever without having to worry about
like okay I need to move slowly and I
need to not jump too much and I need to
not like rapidly change direction and
causing them you know the liquid
chat are we back
are we just wait no okay good we just
yeah we just restarted um the routers
because I don't know it was it was the
weirdest thing the stream disconnected
and you couldn't hear us but we could
hear you perfectly like for a while and
so we just kept saying like what
happened did something like can you hear
us blah blah and then you just reply in
a crystal clear voice but the stream's
100 offline it was the weirdest thing
your internet was so strong that it got
through to us even though ours was down
yes
um okay
so there is one more thing I want to
show you and that is root motion
movement yeah that's what Tim was just
talking about yep
zero X helped me out massively with that
um so we have our little dude
and he's just walking using root motion
right now now he doesn't apparently
smoothly rotate if you like combine the
rotations yeah that's what I'm gonna do
next cool
um but like it's working
uh-huh so
and I'm really happy with it
yeah although there's there's something
interesting like and I think it might
just be due to the animation
it's like it's kind of stops every now
and then like very briefly there's like
a Slowdown and I think it might be when
the animation resets
right
um yeah I'll need to re-export it to fix
up
uh
I mean I don't know like actually I mean
it might be worth a go
um it is very obvious yeah
well
but I I can't really tell from like this
can you tell when there's a massive slow
down well I guess like you'll Pull It in
a minute and say on your computer yeah
IRL would be nice oh no no I can see it
there I can see it okay yeah I can see
it on side side view is very uh obvious
I think
I don't know I can't say I love the
player model
what happened to the gorgeous legs
they were never part of this one ah but
everyone voted for them
that's why everyone voted for B the only
people voting for B it wasn't because of
this fear that you had
yeah I don't know Peter what do you
think of the player model
could have been different
um like I don't hate it but also I know
just how painful it does look like that
actually
actually this
yeah but the animation and the skeleton
is different from the actual
geometry
yeah like if it's not too much like sure
I just honestly think it could massively
be improved by just changing the
proportions like you don't even have to
change much like maybe make it more like
a cube and make the legs fatter and
shorter and I think it would immediately
look better
and like the Hat should maybe be taller
because it does it looks flat from
certain angles it almost looks like a
normal map
from a lot of angles and it looks like I
don't know some
pressure plate slash Colonial like
Colonial profile for a kitchen cabinet
okay well at this point we have a
decision to make
do you want me to use the feedback or
all the feedback that you're just gave
me leave that for last we have a plan
that was my entire day you're looking
yeah yesterday but I mean you spend
another day well you don't have to redo
it from scratch like the animation you
can keep
redo that way
yeah yeah it's getting to the animation
real hard time actually getting it to
work with like the mesh I redid that why
was it so difficult to get it to work uh
weight painting oh well to work oh like
well that's just yes a blender authoring
is basically a blender authoring Hazel
Hazel is fine right oh no Hazel was well
I didn't do anything in Hazel it's Peter
exited I can tell you Hazel was not fine
okay there you go uh spent I think zero
X spent maybe an hour but why what was
wrong with it like because obviously we
have plenty of root motion examples in
Hazel why was this different
it was partially because
um the
I according okay so I don't know Sarah
can correct me if I explain this
incorrectly but part of it was the bones
were parented weirdly and the blender
file so when it exported like the legs
yeah I wasn't parented right think yeah
and so they went they just went gliding
forward well the body was here yeah
um
Tim didn't you set up and oh that was
different this is why I did it correctly
the first time and the skeleton just
would not get exported like I tried for
an hour and a half to export the
skeleton with the correct root bone that
just sits on the ground that's the one
that's going to be used for root motion
tracking and I just could not do it
so I just went to basically it was a
different way yeah yeah there was
another issue where like
um
the player basically just drunk
um with one of the animations
um but that wasn't I don't think that
that wasn't like due to Tim exporting it
incorrectly I don't think it was the um
the masks in the um the translation mask
in the actual anime yeah that's the
thing yeah correct
Xerox really should write some good
documentation for this because like he's
explained all of this to me but I have
forgotten it all I have a recording all
that I think
um but yeah and like Xerox had to
basically put together a hack in the
engine to make this animation can like
animation yeah I saw that I saw that I
pulled the engine code and read through
it a bit yep yeah
um
so it was not
smooth
yeah
well whatever like we'll leave that to
last
um
like I'll tell you right now
this model if you know like we have a
model
if we have time to touch up on it let's
go let's do it I think what you could
have what you could have done and I feel
like this would have been a better move
maybe from the get-go would be to just
use like someone else's model
because like first of all we don't have
to make all the assets it's just that if
we use other people's assets we
reference them but also what that means
is we can you know prototype faster get
something up and running be like this
kind of style works well
okay Tim now commit a day to making a
model in this style because the problem
is like again like this is it's kind of
like you know if you don't plan it
enough you commit to something and then
it's like actually
this needs to be changed and then you've
already lost that time
so I feel like that would be that would
have been a good Strat but I don't know
where would you find a model just go to
like go to miximo grab like
and they've got so many models there
already animated with root motion that's
how we got it into hey into the Hazel
sandbox examples and then you could even
play with the scaling to make it a bit
more squished or whatever but they've
actually got like dwarf style models and
that's kind of done you know and then
you know see how that fits into the
world what do we like about it what do
we don't you probably even play with the
textures quickly
to just you know do some previous
basically and then after that it's like
okay this is what it should look like
you could probably have even just taken
the animation from miximo instead of
hand animating it right but animating
was not that wasn't difficult the
difficult part was getting to the
animating which is uh but once you have
a skeleton once you have a skeleton from
mixer mode you can use blender's tools
to just immediately do the weight
painting for you and then just tweak it
is it yeah like tweaking it is what
takes long about it
and then I tweak it maybe because it's
such a like no blender's web printing
yeah they're just they're just so bad
like I don't get it because it what's
called vertex painting tools are much
better than weight painting right
yeah
all right cool Peter um so what are you
are you heading off to sleep or are you
going to do anything else
uh I'm gonna basically try and get this
player controller to do smooth rotation
okay
um shouldn't be hard should I work in
that scene or do you want me to try a
different scene
uh so I'm working in the root motion
movement scene oh so you have your own
scene okay so I can work in the main
scene
you can work in
working how but all of your obviously
all of your pickup systems and the enemy
stuff do they work in the main scene at
all
um yeah yeah
because that's all in scripts yeah oh
okay right yeah oh that's the main scene
okay I thought all everything you showed
me was that root motion scene
no of course because that main scene has
doesn't have the player model yep
cool
I thought I don't remember so if okay
that's fine yeah
I was getting nuked yeah it's a bug like
with the scripting engine somewhere
uh
yeah so my hair I think it's the gun
yeah sometimes you just have to re-add
it that sucks
yeah I I put it on a to-do list for are
you sure that's because you just you
just didn't forget to you forgot to hit
save so you're still getting not
references there no yeah
okay static data Ah that's right yeah
but I made it clear I think on uh
or like well no that was an engine crash
anyway
yeah and if if it hits a null reference
exception
um the script won't like terminate
properly
so it might not call the detached yeah
or destroy it like properly oh yeah well
that's why I did it on on the uh in the
uncreate
yeah because that will definitely be
cold
um all right cool well it sounds good
then um I'll get to work on the main
scene and then yeah let me know like if
you commit stuff and
I
do actually
uh and that's not important that is
I'm just going to discard that because I
was working with gun types but I didn't
read the ocean
um
that's whatever
uh
and I'll stage those two lines
but yeah I think that looks
like it might be good
okay
so I'm just gonna Commit This yeah
I do have an engine fix as well so
you're gonna have to pull the engine
I've already pulled the engine is it
this is a new one I knew thing yeah okay
just fixed some some offsets not being
accounted for in the
character control have you already
pushed that
no okay not yet
um
with that stuff you said about
prototyping that are essentially I just
don't think that's something you'd ever
do during a game show like deciding the
odd style like halfway through the SEC
of the first day I think is like but you
can't like how do you know though you
can't commit to a certain art style
without playing it first and being like
this fits this works well like just you
know in advance of the game Jam
basically I don't know because you can't
just spend half the first day no but it
takes less than an hour to grab
something from Maxima and Chuck it into
the effect of what yeah by the time you
settle out settle down on it by the time
you're exporting all this yeah but you
can kind of just tweak it a little bit
get the view that you want without like
you know but the thing is anyone can
also do that like it doesn't have to be
you like because otherwise I don't know
like
obviously doing something for a day and
then having to redo all that work during
a game Jam is even worse so that's kind
of my point
yeah but like redoing it is just not an
option we can ship the game with the one
model that we have I'm going to be
redoing it because I want to redo it
today and probably redo it tomorrow and
then maybe we'll be happy with it you
know but like I'm telling you so the
solution is just to make something that
we don't like
well this this game just in general is
going to be forest level art not going
to be dichotomy level up because the
economy had like five assets that I
spent making two days there's like 20
assets 25 assets I'm going to make
texture animate some of them there's
just not enough time in the day to do
all that
and like it's up to us because we had
cubes the other the other Advantage
though
um but we wanted to make something of
Oxley here yeah which is similar to
cubes
but the other advantage to prototyping
it is that like we can actually like you
know Peter could have for example set up
the root motion and got everything
working
like as in you know because if we need
like the coffee cup to actually be on a
bone that's on the player because it's
in the hand you know that could have all
been basically done
um and then it doesn't like as long as
basically the skeleton doesn't
dramatically change the actual like you
could just have an empty skeleton that's
why you know
mostly like if you look at like Unreal
Engine people will do all their
prototyping just using the default
mannequin model because like you can
just kind of get to work on that and
then like we know it's going to be a
human so the actual vertices around the
bones they don't matter they're just
visual yeah
so it's kind of nice to separate it we
really should have like a default
biped kind of model just in um hazel
that we can just Chuck on for this
because I feel like obviously having
uh
like yeah it's going to be common to be
like I want a humanoid character yeah
yeah
um
but the thing is
I'm writing up some actual like
character controllers that we could just
swap on and like tweak
yeah
but yeah the problem anyways I've pushed
my engine stuff by the way
okay cool I'll uh fetch
and we'll see
did you push the yeah you pushed the
game as well
all right
um
let's see now that is the main scene
okay well
ah I'll have to pick up a gun so I can
still shoot with no gun
you can you shouldn't be able to well I
can't anymore
yeah
oh yeah so I start with 10 ammo and the
muzzle flash is just in the middle of
the player as soon as I start the main
scene
really yep
I mean okay because it isn't for me ah
guys I might not have push it might not
have like it might be some scriptures
yeah yeah
mixed up well I have a gun maybe I
shouldn't have a gun
should the player I mean if you don't
want to have a gun then
should have delete the gun from the
player well yeah but should that like do
you have it without a gun you start with
that without like a gun and entity on
the player
uh
no like the the player entity starts
with a gun right now just like in the
entity itself
um well I've got one but like I guess
visual like what seems to happen is I
think maybe I do have a gun but it's
just inside the player
okay you might need to
um
come on oh am I no I mean I don't have
any gun there's the held player offset
um which
arguably we could just use the local
translation uh as the offset yeah
um so you can probably just change that
because this was left over from when a
previous design of the item system it's
being weighed like I can't it's like
selecting the whole thing as if it's one
like it's a vect three yeah it's a vect
three but it's highlighting all the
fields yeah that's because it's it's not
set to a drag
um flow three it's set to like an input
flow three meaning you can't drag it by
default Ah that's weird
why I don't know
okay so player controller yeah
um
do you so but you've got it set to
something or no
I do it's basically set to match the
values that are in the transform
components
um so do you and do you like because the
other thing is if the player doesn't
start with a gun
then obviously how do you get your first
gun
I guess maybe the coffee the coffee tent
has a gun that you can just grab yeah
or maybe even has a selection of guns
and you can grab any gun so it's kind of
like when you can pick Bulbasaur
Squirtle or Charmander in the beginning
Pokemon you can pick your little gun
yeah because you can just put down like
a gun
um instance that has the prefab for
whatever gun the player should actually
hold yeah
and what's it what is it what is it to
pick to pick up a x
yes
oh yeah that's right yeah
remember you saying X
cool
because they're forests in a way just
because
you have the enemies running towards you
and a gun
controller movement yeah
cool all right sounds good oh
flamethrower that would be a fun weapon
just spewing out flame particles that
hurt
yeah it would be nice to have a particle
system because at the moment
unfortunately every single particle is
an entity and that is not great for
performance
yeah
although actually what I'm doing that's
a bit bad at the moment is I'm pretty
sure
oh maybe not no no I'm not I don't think
I am I was going to say I thought every
particle had a script but it doesn't
all right cool
um well yeah let me know how you go
Peter
yeah
all right see ya all right see ya
now let's see here
um where's my music
[Music]
no anxiety
please
all right
okay so I guess we wanted to kind of do
some level generation I think
um where should we start with for that
though
uh actually let's quickly just
check out the root motion scene
why do I not have the asset oh I do
but then
I'm playing as the cube
it's so weird I've got some interesting
differences to what Peter was showing
I mean something is null here
well that seems to work
I guess the camera needs to follow the
oh because because it wait is it because
there's two players but they're
I mean yes there's two players but
it's not like it's looking up it's not
like it's looking it up by name
now this is Peter scene and Tyler I
don't think I should have any changes to
it at all
I don't know which player it is
oh actually I can just drag it in though
okay now I'm this but I can't move
something's still null though what is
this what's null anime.cs line 45.
so that probably means that enemies and
maybe enemy prefabs oh this is all yeah
gun pickup prefab like what ah that
needs prefabs why is that not set
gun pistol pickup I guess
enemy gun prefab
what are these supposed to be set to
let me just send Peta this and find out
what he
they're supposed to be
yeah I'm not sure why there's
values are being reset to null but they
are
foreign
okay
uh the stream volume should be pretty
fine I think I'm just not talking much
because I'm pretty much at like max
volume it'll distort if I go any higher
and the music I've made quiet because
so you can hear me talk
um all right
so uh yeah
um anyway it doesn't matter I'm not
gonna work in this scene anyway
uh I'm gonna make these a bit smaller
uh let's go to scenes and Mains in
so this is kind of where we're at
um
so my plan
yeah I think I want to start with
basically the level Generation
Um
the terrain generation so we have
hexagonal tiles uh one thing I was
playing with
last time
uh we were doing this was
well last night I mean was
My Level generator
it's still called dummy let me rename
that let's look at that
all right
yeah we were playing with Y positions so
basically we had it set to this
uh which looks really cool all right and
let's see if this still crashes the
engine all good it doesn't pay to fix
tip well done
um so yeah we had this kind of cool uh
uh you know aesthetic
um
I like this a lot obviously it's a
little bit nonsensical in the sense that
um
well like
well yeah the player doesn't collide
with them which is we need to fix that
but that might already be fixed so I'm
not gonna worry too much about that at
least I will have to probably worry
about it but anyway the problem with
this obviously is that it's every single
hexagon that we see here it's completely
random like between you know I think
zero and one meter
um so that's not great
uh and of course we can increase that
range especially if we want higher Hills
we can increase that range you know
let's just say from zero to three meters
and then it's gonna look even weirder
well I mean this is too tall for
the size of the model but
um the point is that this is just
completely random
and even though it looks kind of cool
it's not really practical instead we
want to have you know varying degrees so
instead of kind of having them at
different heights like this from a side
view we kind of want to you know make
valleys and do all of that stuff and we
can do that just by using noise and it's
pretty easy to do and I think to some
degree Hazel does have that already so
let's just see if we can use it I think
we can just do
noise purling or something for example
uh and then give it an X and a y
coordinate so if we just replace what we
have here
and I don't know like I don't know if
we'll be able to use this probably but
uh if I basically take
let's keep these around just for
debugging but if I basically take
this kind of noise uh and we we can get
a value from
um our X and Y position
well we could even do
translation X translation Z right
and that's translation Y and so if we
try this
if this works
we get nothing okay so I don't know if
that worked properly I haven't used we
haven't used this class in a while it
might just not work
um see it is just eight by default sure
um maybe you need to set this I thought
that by default it was pretty okay
though
maybe we should try to actually
instantiate the class
and then I can just do noise.get
maybe that will work I don't know if
no I'm just getting zero
which is weird am I actually getting
zero or is it just tiny
oh okay I'm not getting zero it is just
tiny it's also between okay so it's time
so if I do
so let's just get the noise value Maybe
and then I can do noise value times 0.5
plus 0.5 actually let me do that here so
that will just
make it actually be from zero to one
instead of from negative one to one
and then I can multiply it by I guess
how much I want but it it's weird
because I didn't really see it being
anything yeah that's not correct either
[Music]
let's not do that hang on let me just do
this
but that looks perfectly flat
it does have different y values though
I guess they're just not like yeah
they're just not big enough
well actually you know what let's not do
the times 0.5 plus 0.5 let's just
multiply it by like an amplitude so
let's just try three
uh like there'll be a little bit of or
do we crash
oh we did
wait that's
that's a that's a GPU crash and I think
I have Vulcan validation on
oh no I don't okay let's turn that back
on
so I can cash those because the new
renderer does still have some some small
issues
yeah it's like Warzone is kind of what
we're going for
I guess they are at different heights
but again it's weird because it just
seems like um
no but this is a big difference so I
don't know why we're not seeing that
look these are massive differences
what
uh it's just it's just very gradual yeah
yeah it's very gradual because see how
deep I am now
okay so this is too gradual it needs to
be way more sporadic
um so yeah we can either increase the
amplitude or we can just play with the
actual noise settings which I guess I'll
do so let's see what we have so we have
frequency octaves
um it'd be good to get it as a texture I
guess we that kind of is what we're
doing though
um
but yeah be good to kind of see just
what it does
um because we could try playing with
this I guess
I guess I could just regenerate it maybe
so
let me do this I want to play with this
obviously to get it looking how I want
it to look so I want to basically grab
like all of these parameters right
uh and then this will just let me play
with them
um
and I don't even know what the defaults
are so
let's maybe see what the defaults are
actually maybe I can just
see what the defaults are
in the actual like C plus code because
that would be a lot faster
than trying to pull them out from C
sharp
I guess it just sets it internally
though I thought that would be set by
Hazel maybe not
so in that case I guess we will pull it
out
um
that's all done now though
okay so let's just maybe
all right so we got zero point
let's quickly copy that
down
zero zero one three
two and point five so these are the
defaults
um
I'm missing that one but
let's set them to this
foreign
yeah so
um if we look at Hazel
put on this monitor
okay
um so yeah so now if we look at the
level generator we should see
I didn't actually pull our
our values maybe because we already set
them
so we had there
usually it does
okay so if we run that that should be
our world okay so here's what I want to
do I'm going to make a keyboard shortcut
in the level generator to regenerate the
level and then I'm going to make a
private void generate chunk or something
like that
uh that will just yeah generate it
um and basically we'll just do this
so we can start with one but uh we're
gonna do
if input dot is key pressed um and let's
do
G for Generate
uh generate and so basically this will
just let us uh now this has to actually
also clear the existing ones so if I
I'll have to keep track of them some way
so private list uh entity
uh tiles
when we instantiate them we'll add them
to that list
and then what we'll do is
we'll run through all of them
let's clear this
we'll run through all of them and um
to destroy
clear it okay so now we should be able
to regenerate this which shouldn't
really look like anything at the moment
or
wow
why did that take so long
that takes way too much time
damn
that takes so much time
I wonder why
very weird
um
yeah because it definitely shouldn't
like maybe this is also taking a lot of
time just to destroy them
well actually to be honest we probably
shouldn't like
yeah I don't think we should create
recreate them every time I destroy and
that's a bit dumb isn't it I don't know
why I did that um
let's do private void create
initial tile set
and we're basically just going to go
through
and create like from up height and map
with for now and we're just going to do
uh this and honestly like
well like we can I guess we can place
them if we really wanted to
so we'll kind of do this which is what
we did the first time around I think
right
and then that's nice because of course
we we are regenerating them so we don't
have to re-add them or anything we don't
have to reinstantiate them all we need
to do is go through tiles uh X Plus y
oh extra Z times map
uh with
that's our that's our tile
and then we just do
tile Dot
uh translation equals translation now
I'm not going to worry about generating
it like it's changing the color of it I
could I guess
that's a little bit difficult though
because they're literally different
prefab so we'll leave it as is for now
um I deleted X pause
but the idea is we'll do we'll do this
and then this
and this should be much faster
yeah I mean I'm not even noticing it
unless it's not working but we'll find
out in a minute
um so this will let's just do can we do
foreign
what's a quick way to seed
was a quick environment tick count yeah
that's what I was looking for something
like that
so that will just seed it differently
yeah so you can see you can see it
change now every time I hit G which is
cool all right so why did I do that
um uh because so let's go to the enemy
spawner
for one and we'll just be like do not
spawn uh maybe we should have a bully in
here as well uh spawn equals true
and then
return so that way we can stop it from
spawning enemies if we wanted to so if I
hit play
uh you know we can spawn some enemies
but if I go to the enemy manager and I
uncheck this then we shouldn't get any
more let me kill this guy we shouldn't
get any more enemies okay good
so now what I can do is if I go into the
level generator
uh I got my parameters down here right
so I've got my frequency octaves
whatever uh I can play with that and
then if I hit G you can see that just
like that uh I can yeah just update it
now
um actually I don't even have to click
which is nice I can just literally you
know play with
all of these things uh
and just hit
oh gee so
this is kind of nice I guess octaves
I actually don't remember what these
parameters are supposed to do what if we
like let's start by zeroing them all out
and then I want to play it so yeah so
you definitely need frequency
okay that looks kind of cool so see now
we're getting like some mountains which
is kind of what I was thinking of
um
[Music]
well I have to hit Escape but Escape
also deselects the entity which is a bit
annoying
um but yeah so let's play with the gain
a little bit so what does that do
because it's also going to be different
right
um
and maybe one thing I could do as well
is
uh the camera
like if I wanted to I could just make
the camera a bit further away from the
player or whatever
so that way I can look at the terrain a
bit more
um
okay so that's kind of what we're
dealing with very hilly like I the thing
is like obviously I'm just starting by
generating noise
um
but
you know you usually will like level
generation isn't just like let me just
tweak Some Noise parameters and I'm done
um we'll we'll probably have to generate
different kind of levels of noise and
layer them on top of each other and have
some logic
um I might even look up maybe what a
good guide
to doing this would be just so that way
I can because like for example if I
wanted to be an island I could basically
multiply it with a mask that Fades out
over time and goes to zero so that way
I could create a shoreline I could
enforce a shoreline you know around this
and there's so many things you can do so
I'm just kind of playing around with
this just to begin with but this kind of
looks nice
um let me try one octave instead of zero
I don't know what the difference really
is I think that's how many times it will
generate a multiply on top maybe 70
octaves
doesn't really seem to do much visually
then we've got this laconarity which I'm
not gonna pretend to understand what
that does
again looks kind of the same strangely
frequency and gain seem to be doing
during the most
um
like also I guess
there can be like well frequency yeah
frequency is going to control the
resolution basically so you can see if I
do frequency this creates a much broader
resolution and if I do something really
low it's going to be super smooth
um I'm also not really controlling the
amplitude
too much so this is just like you know
some basic kind of hills
nothing too fancy
um but then I could multiply certain
regions
you know with
um I guess
something a bit higher like that that's
probably too much though
maybe like this you know 0.1
2 or something to create something more
dramatic because I feel like part of me
would want to have some yeah like this
looks kind of cool like I want to have
Cliffs like this
but also you know it's not just the
because at the moment okay so let me let
me just I'll keep these settings I think
I just copy this but I'll actually don't
know if that'll work and I think this
can just be zero because I'm really
using it but also gain gain does
something right what does gain do
uh
0.2
versus zero not nothing really I mean
the only thing that seems to be doing
anything is frequency which is a bit sus
isn't it
hmm
maybe it's just maybe I'm just wrong in
something
anyway let me take a screenshot of this
parameters so I remember them even
though the only one I really need to
remember is 0.15 but I also want to see
if I paste this in to that
no that doesn't actually work funnily
enough so
what
wait
but look that doesn't generate anything
huh
have I done something stupid
I don't think so I'm pretty sure I said
all these unless these are broken
but it doesn't really look like it they
should be
because I can't say I've tested this
noise all of these noise parameters
before but they do exist so
kind of makes me think like they should
work
so let's let's see what this actually
does
I mean it looks like it does set
yeah I mean it definitely does do that
these all seem to work
hmm
and obviously that other thing works
right
yeah there's all these different noise
types we can use as well
but it's a bit annoying isn't it
like
I shouldn't have to redo it
but even so like I mean
every time we hit G what is it doing
it's
doing this and it is setting all of
these and then we generate from it right
so
why would that not work
isn't that so weird
hmm
that's so weird
I mean it's just flat out not generating
anymore
and G doesn't do anything
this is really really really strange
we're like really weird
huh
yeah like they're not appearing here so
that means that it's like legit it's
literally not running through
this card
did I have something to do with me
pasting and that ruined something
I don't know how that would have
happened
let me just reset it up maybe oh that's
annoying though but
too late I guess wait is player or
player two the one I care about
where's my player I think it's player
surely yeah player
I don't know what happened there that
was bizarre
um all right let's go to player blood
particle blood particle
um
we'll try the same parameters but now I
have to add my prefabs
my hexagon
uh
it doesn't really matter the order
yeah it's not generating anymore
man this is weird
let me just
I guess debug I don't know
yeah it's well it's not it
might not be
hitting that break point
that's so strange
literally not doing this
let me do a chuck and a log
oh here we go no reference exception
line 90. but that I didn't see that
before was that was it happening before
line 90
our player
well no oh look I reset everything what
this is very very weird
all right okay now it's working
all right so
yeah so I kind of liked that these
Cliffs or whatever but it's so weird how
it doesn't seem to actually like this
stuff doesn't seem to do anything
right
that doesn't seem right
or maybe I don't know maybe that doesn't
apply to purlin noise
all right let's change the noise type
just for fun if I go here because it's
purlin but if I make it like Simplex or
something or Simplex fractal
[Music]
be nice if I could set the noise type
from say sharp maybe I'll make that
happen
okay well that's that's a different
result for sure
um
so let's maybe play with this
okay that looks the same
I think this this one is just more
sensitive it seems
mean that
does that look different
I don't know
actually get it to stop spawning enemies
wonderful
can't delete
enemies like that apparently
make a flat floor and apply noise to
colors
uh well I mean
the grid is basically the floor I can
still see the difference
I could definitely do it by height
though the colors which I might do later
but
that might be better
um
let's go to the enemy manager and just
not spawn enemies
because they're a little Annoying wow
this is
yeah so that's like um
yeah I don't know it's really weird I
feel like it's not working
but I don't know why
like
the variables should be correct
yeah 2.5
6.5 octave 6. that's what I set it to
right
yeah okay well it's definitely being set
into the library maybe it just doesn't
apply to those things but it's weird
um
oh Peter wants a call
sure
yo what's up
um so I pretty much got the
root motion movements smooth now okay at
least when using controller
uh so let's try the Stream
oh that's beautiful yeah that looks
really nice
how's it with the mouse
which I quite like
um and you can do 45 degree angles ah
cool yep
um so I quite like that now I had to
decrease the dead zone for the movement
axis because it was like snapping at
weird angles on occasion yep
um it's a decrease in The Dead Zone made
it a lot smoother
um but do you want me to effectively
take what's in the player controller
and just put that in here as well uh or
do you want to take care of that
uh I think you can do that if you want
because I'm not going to touch I'm just
yeah just doing level Generation stuff
so I'm not going to touch any player
mechanics
um like and definitely not before you go
to bed because that'll be soon I imagine
well either way I'm I'm very deep into
like terrain generation right now so no
player stuff I'm doing yeah
um
to do so
all right
cool cool
um
sounds good keep me updated
um one one thing I had as well was uh so
with this level Generation stuff um yeah
I'm thinking of just like combining I
don't know like
ah we need so there's two two questions
I have from a game design point of view
I guess one of which is
boundaries right so do we just put up
like maybe some bubbed wire fences
around the area to stop the player going
Far Hills and Island perhaps maybe this
taking place on an island and you can't
go off the island
um Island might be nice because it's
just like
you know you can just make um
the you know the multiply the noise like
by a small small value depending on the
radius and then everything becomes flat
and it's water
um whereas like with barbed wire it's
like butterfly I guess you can see
through them so we might have to
do some like static meshes off in the
distance or like some matte paintings
kind of flat paint 2D images or
something
um but there'll be fog anyway I guess
uh but yeah that's one thing any
thoughts on that
uh
okay
um and the other question was
yeah like do you have any uh I know you
did some map Generation stuff last time
do you have any resources or like good
kind of suggestions like
because I'm probably going to end up
generating a bunch of different noise
types multiplying them together
you know trying to create things and I
don't know like there's an easier way
I didn't actually use Noise Okay so that
was just really basic yeah yeah
I might do some research then because
I've never really done like actual
complex terrain generation
um yeah besides like noise so
um
yeah that's right
maybe we'll watch some of those videos
yeah
yeah I think that could be
starting point yep I might check those
out on stream that'd be fun
yeah cool alrighty well see you later
okay
sorry I stream that was probably echoi
because I forgot to I forgot to mute
uh
sorry I always do that
I forgot to mute the uh desktop audio
all right now that I've woken you all up
um
does anyone in chat have any good
suggestions for some like terrain gen
resources
I guess like at the moment we're kind of
we're generating like
maybe we should start since it's an
island especially why don't we start
generating from
the middle like the origin is not like
because the Moment Like This is the
origin right like over here and then
we're generating out like that in the
positive kind of y direction and the
positive X Direction on the positive um
I guess Z and X or whatever but we could
make it centered around the origin and I
think that would be a bit nicer both
both for the mouth because then we could
easily use a radius without having to
offset it but then also
uh with thought in the middle you know
and not like somewhere weird although we
won't we won't want to start somewhere
weird but we'll see
yeah maybe actually maybe I'll maybe it
would make sense if we start
here and then our goal is to get
to the other
thing
like to the other side
um maybe that would be nicer
okay so let's let's just try and shift
it
so what we'll do is
[Music]
um
I guess
yeah let's just do
fart
and said P equals said
minus map height
divided by two
uh
doesn't really matter which ones can we
use I think here
but I guess once we have that maybe we
should just use that
um and then where do we do this so is
that P
let's use XP
and X Plus y times that needs to be yeah
that
um all right
that should be it I think
so now we should be in the middle yeah
yeah all right looks seems legit uh
let's see
now that I've done that yeah so we
obviously like I mean we have some kind
of radius here like we're not really
like yeah we could we could pretend to
have some kind of radius here
um now we could say the radius is just
the
half the width or height
so obviously like at the moment we're
generating a square right and we have
the width and we have the height but
what we can do is we can also just use
it kind of as a radius which would be
half of that and then just be like let's
apply that uniformly which would mean
which would mean that we get
you know a circular shape obviously
because it's also like this distance is
obviously greater than the half the
height but if we construct it to the
height we get this so what that means is
that if we do float
um in the generation I'm in float radius
equals map width for example divided by
a two
let's do times 0.5
um what we can do is we can say that
this translation y
right
um
the further this tile is
from The Middle
so basically the closer it is to radius
so radius is going to be
where it isn't quite gonna be them yeah
but we could just do we it's not quite
going to be the minimum the minimum but
we could do
so if I do translation oh should I just
do
okay let's do this Vector two
I don't know this probably would be
simple from uh
um
code point but might be a little bit
worse performance but basically if we
get the length of this vector and we
subtract radius from it
right
um because I want to do it in that order
and then we clamp it to zero
so math F dot uh Min zero right
then we could say that is basically like
we can multiply this with the
translation y I think
and then that will mean that
it will basically start off as real
height and then but this is going to
curve it down and we probably don't want
to start you know from there but let me
just make sure that's right so if the
radius
minus the length from The Middle
as long as it's centered around the
origin I guess that will work but that's
always obviously going to give us a
linear falloff from
the middle well let's just see what that
looks like
I kind of wanna I was gonna say I kind
of want a free camera okay that is not
what I wanted that's like the opposite
somehow
how did that happen
ah well okay I'm yeah I need to um
that's not what I want to say
uh where am I
um yeah because I wanted to divide this
I think what I wanted to do is probably
divide the length by
the radius or the radius by the length
radius by the length right
no but that's going to be one then
right
what am I doing man
morning maths is just the worst
um
I need some paper or something I can
just use the screen uh okay so let's
just say radius maximum radius is two uh
our length from the middle is obviously
going to be like 0.5 you know one I want
to basically draw do a graph initially
from one to zero
um based on that so if I just take the
radius which I kind of did okay I can I
think I can take the radius subtract it
from the vector divide the whole thing
by the radius that's probably what I
wanted to do
so take the radius subtract it from the
vector and divide it by
the radius
and that should give me a value between
zero and one let me just make sure
that's correct
especially because I clamp it
um
no that's all negative
wait is that the right thing
why is it but it can't be negative
because I'm
oh man I meant Max I think
right
yeah
so you can see kind of what that's doing
it's flattening it out the only problem
is that I don't really want it to
like what's happening at the moment is
it's flatting it's flattening it out
kind of linearly around the thing I
probably want it to just do a little
curve or something at the end and so I
wanted to start from uh I don't want it
the fall off to start from a given
area right so and this is also like this
is not chunk based yet it probably will
be just because we might want a larger
play area but not necessarily more tiles
or whatever so we'll see
but
um yeah what we should do initially
is I think
um
so yeah we're basically let's see
divided by radius
I should I really should just graph this
to be honest because otherwise
uh let's let's just graph at this
because it's just really difficult to
visualize especially in the morning
um so we can use like Desmond for that
so we kind of have this at the moment
um
so let's do
uh
radius minus length minus radius so
we'll do radius minus length divided by
radius
gives us what
about length
no no no no
okay here we go
yep so there's there's our graph right
it goes from one to one so
like if we just take this and we
multiply it by two
and then we clamp it to one what that
does is it creates a steeper falloff but
you can see it only starts halfway
through
um because if we clamp it to one
uh and obviously this is clamped to one
then that's the region of the graph
we're dealing with versus obviously if I
don't multiply it by two then I get this
graph instead which means that from the
beginning it starts so we can multiply
this by a higher number and then just
get a steeper linear fall off uh the
closer we are to the end of the island
so if I even do
like three or five or whatever
you can see that's like the very end so
maybe let's just try four
um
it is a little bit arbitrary this value
like it might make more sense to Define
it as a unit of measurement
but I think this will work
I've just got my uh do I actually maybe
maybe I don't
I didn't clamp it yep sorry
um we have to change this to a clamp
and make sure that that is between
zero and one
so it's basically not going to start the
fall off here but then towards the end
of the island
we should finish up which that doesn't
look like it worked because it's going
off
or is it actually
because it also means it'll reduce it to
zero no no so that's correct
that might just not be enough space oh
no it's not correct because look that's
below one
what
shouldn't that have worked
looks like it worked on this side
I got moved faster actually I've got my
free cam I can just use
yeah this little dip is
a little bit concerning because every
everywhere else seems to have worked oh
well no so this side didn't work
why
um
that's very strange
yeah I mean that oh hang on
ah I probably need to do that
I know that's not what I meant
that's also not what I meant what
do I have to add it here
what
do I have to do a multiplication no
that's weird
I mean a four plus would have worked but
it's still that just rotates around that
so it should maybe should be R Plus
and it's not quite right
yeah because I need to scale it along
that as well because this the problem is
yeah the radius
I think
so
yeah so if the rate so
if the radius increases it obviously
controls that
I need to do that here actually
what if I just do this no that's still
bad
yeah because there has to be
but it doesn't quite increase by that
factor though
because that controls a steepness now
and math
ah
now but the thing is I kind of need it
to be between like here's the thing I
need it to be between
um
zero and one so maybe
maybe
um
well that's why I had the divided by
though
oh oops
but this is weird because isn't this if
radius is one isn't this the same as
just y equals negative X
like this has some kind of
because R is I don't know it's 1 minus X
sorry right this isn't zero
and that would be dividing by zero
anyway
so
so this is just yeah 1 minus X
so surely if I'm just doing one minus X
can't I just I can just I can control
the steepness of this of the
but that's yeah that's not gonna be
normalized
so I don't get why radio oh well yeah
because that's not gonna increase
yeah I'm reading the chat but you guys
aren't really helpful sorry
um
I feel like I'm overthinking this
no the grades are definitely not going
beyond the radius
um the grid isn't um
that being said though uh can't I just
do
so if if I just do radius minus length
right so that means that
um
so if I go back to having R minus X
right so the bigger my radius is
you know I'm still getting a fall off
towards zero based on length so this is
actually
more or less perfect
so all I really want to do isn't all I
really but I need to start there
yeah all I want to do is kind of just
make y bigger
so
if I had like a
slope or whatever
then
I can do that but to compensate
I need to make this slope
bigger
but that's obviously not right
[Music]
uh how do I limit it again
I forgot how to limit it it's like
Community is like Kelly brackets or
something
and that doesn't oh yeah that does work
okay good
I don't really care about the side
and why am I doing this again
now I'm just confused
cosine like what does cosine have to do
with any of this
um
I should really avoid doing this stuff
in the mornings
I'm just not good at it
in the morning
the other thing I could do though is
like if we actually
because the the other big problem here
is that I want to be able to obviously
clamp this down
so let's go back to what we kind of had
actually
so we'll keep that
um
and we'll get rid of this
and that
and then I'm gonna clamp it
to this right
so this is kind of what we had
so s is not used anymore right
um so if I want this
I mean that's basically done I think
oh no actually sorry that's based on the
radius so slope if I did that
so that's kind of what I want right and
then the radius
am I trying to like does the radius
matter though
I don't think the radius matters
right I could just say I could just
normalize it
if I just normalize it and say that
radius is between 0 and 1.
well then that becomes X though because
there's two things here isn't there
no but no there's not though ah yeah
there's not that's the thing
I keep thinking there is but I don't
think there is
um okay so that's obviously just
translating that now so minus X is good
so
um
so that this is I think what I want
right because the reason is that this
situation
yeah like v-length is always going to be
this is like the how close am I to the
edge
um
so this is like my normalized distance
kind of
in a way yeah
um
because we get the length of the vector
and then we divided by the radius
because that's the maximum possible
value of it
according to us
[Music]
is that what I want
so if this is just like zero because
we're at the origin then that would be
zero obviously and then it goes all the
way up to one and if it's if it exceeds
one which is possible because we're
dealing with a Q with a square so like
anything in this range would be out
would be greater than one we can just
make sure it doesn't go above one
by um
setting a minimum
like that so this basically will go up
to one
so if this is now from zero to one right
um so now that I have that distance
I don't care about radius anymore that
was kind of my problem I was thinking
about the radius too much
and I think I should just be able to use
S as a way to basically
somewhat arbitrarily but I should be
able to use it if it's one then you get
a linear fall off from the beginning but
the thing is if we can we also clamp y
yeah we can I think
you can see what that does is as I drag
this forward it's letting me be like
when do I want my Island fall off to
begin
do I want do I want it to begin it like
immediately or the more I increase this
number it's going to wait and then it's
going to begin my fall off
um and then I could
like if I wanted to I guess I could um
I don't know if
um I could curve it
the problem is there's like not that
much room to curve it
so I could curve it a little bit
might be better to just do
uh that though
what's happened here
so I could have it start at like
let's just say 1.3 I guess we could try
this so then that would be
this distance this weirdo distance thing
which we will clamp as well between zero
and one but this becomes so s is our
slope so we have to Define some kind of
slope which will set to 1.3 and then
this is going to be S minus s and then X
which is distance normalized
squared right
ah
and then that should be it
am I logging anything else because I
really don't want to be that it doesn't
exist anymore no I'm not let me just
actually be like dissed
equals that as well
okay I
pretty sure that didn't work
for some reason because see this is
still
I did build that right I would have
right
insufficient disk space uh
this problem again I forgot about this
clear my clear some stuff
let me show you my face while I look at
sensitive files
hmm
whoa I have 80 gigabyte of jolt captures
Peter
what has Peter done 80 gigabytes of jolt
captures
let me just uh
show Peter this
couldn't save screenshot free up some
disk space then try again damn it
I tried to send a screenshot to Peter of
where my disk space is gone because 80
gigabytes of it is inside jolt captures
and it
it didn't work but I'm surprised the
stream is
well that's what I did obviously like oh
there's I don't know
well I don't know why it doesn't just
throw it in Ram but like I just I don't
know it's weird
probably to leave some garbage from here
foreign
before I delete that
all right now we can delete it
silly jolt
80 gigabytes of captures go away what do
you think this is 2050 or we have
infinite Hardware space I don't think so
all right now let's try and compile this
again catastrophic failure
that's Visual Studio exception though
come on
come on man I'm gonna have to restart
you
huh
piece of garbage
oh
well
I don't think that's the reason why it
didn't work unfortunately
would it be
terrible
for me to quickly
um this is kind of funny I want to debug
this but this log is annoying so here's
what I want to do
um I'm gonna basically
uh grab the orange hexagon I'm gonna add
a text component to it
I'm gonna update it
actually let me just first move that
text component up
ah no let me not do that maybe
because I'm not gonna be able to see
that
let's add a text entity to it
get rid of this thing I don't know
what's there
um
let's move this up
and basically the purpose of this
is so I can log on each hexagon
so if we I'm just going to do it on I'm
just going to make all the hexagons
orange so I don't have to do this for
every single thing but
um what I should now be able to do is
basically when it instantiates this and
it gets like it's obviously got the
entity tile here I can do tile get
component text component
dot um
text and that's going to be
the this distance basically
so I'll just convert the flow to a
string um
can I just there'll be too many decimal
places there
can I do like
that or something
I guess we'll find out
can someone double check the Syntax for
this for how to using C Sharp's strength
format what the how do I how I get
decimal places sorted
thanks all right
that's what I wanted right uh yes except
I'm gonna have to not instantiate all of
them now because at the moment it's
instantiating
uh I need just the orange one because
that's the only one that works so that's
number two
so let's make this two
let's see what happens
probably take longer because now there's
all this text to do or not I mean
they're definitely all orange
my error input string was not in correct
format
okay
I guess that's not it
oh no no hang on I need the zero first
don't I
it's probably that
no
I'll Google it
oh it's all weird yeah
it's like um
zero and then it's zero Dot
that or something weird
no no reference exception though why is
it not why that a null reference
exception
is this like is it not happy with that
oh no sorry I'm wrong okay we have to
get the CH the child the children into
this because it's not it's a child
entity it's not on the thing
no that that didn't work uh we probably
exceeded it there's probably not enough
room for all of them let's just quickly
uh make change the max
quads to like a hundred thousand
so that we have enough space
to render because I don't know I really
should change the way the render works
at the moment but because it should just
flush and re-batch it but
lots of stuff to do eh
lots of game engine stuff to do
but I'm looking forward to this like I
hope that be able to make a nice level
gen situation today it's only like 12
p.m so
got time
there's a hundred thousand enough
hopefully
yes it is
okay it's lagging
um quite a bit actually but you can see
that now I have my numbers
and you can see the fall off and you can
see it clearly does not reach zero
um but anyway how much better is this it
doesn't the edges
huh that's weird
what about the other side no the other
side's even
so the radius looks like the radius is
kind of too big and you can see that one
anyway how much better is this than
logging
why is it so slow though is it really
I guess rendering because what are we
doing we're just rendering a bunch of
text that's what's new
but why is that so slow like would that
be so slow because it's like we're doing
this every frame
like we're rendering it every frame but
we're not yeah
um
yeah so the radius seems to be too big
which is weird because
like you know
can't even stop it
it's all right it's not registering my
clicks
good work
oh yeah I do wonder why that's so slow
but actually I don't have to wonder for
long
because we have uh we can just oh okay
it stopped finally but I think I hit
play again let's just terminate it I can
just take a look with Tracy and see why
it's so slow but um
that's not the point the point is I
don't care that it's slow because it's
not it's just for debugging for now
um
so bro what what is wrong with my math
apart from everything
uh I thought this was gonna be
so the length of that vector
radius and the radius is what it's map
where the times 0.5 now we are we are
going like up until map with here on the
ax but then we're subtracting half of it
which kind of implies that the edges
should be at radius
does it not
okay new plan
um
clearly this is wrong but please tell me
instead
uh
uh what the let's do this
and that so I want to know
out of the radius what are we
could over into the hexagons of
different cards based on the distance
value instead of rendering test quads um
yeah I I could have but I actually
wanted to know the numbers obviously
because colors are a bit arbitrary
oh Falcon validation error
again maybe too many quads
yeah I think it's too many quads I
really should make the batch render be
able to
do that I mean we could why don't we
just reduce the map size that would
probably be best 32 by 32 didn't really
matter obviously
but yeah I definitely should make that
work it's just not and like I don't know
at the moment again the hexagons are
obviously individual entities I would
love to not do that because that would
just be better yeah this is so much
smoother
um all right so this is what is this
exactly um okay it's too big for one so
let's go into our orange hexagon and
make that text
like way smaller
stupid thing could just go away really
um
black
point two maybe no that's that's just
more
minus 2.4
okay uh that's better uh let me get into
my editor camera which is this okay so
wait why is the radius different
I must have done something wrong oh I
did zero I'm just not used to using C
Sharps then because um in Hazel when you
log things you don't like we use fmt
format and you don't need to specify the
index like you can just instead of like
being like
you know my parameter is at zero or one
you can just do that and so that way
it's just like depending on where it
appears it will get the right index but
here you have to actually specify an
index or at least in this version of C
sharp which is a bit annoying so 16 is
the radius that's correct that is half
of 32 and yet this doesn't reach 16.
ah is it because
it's at the origin and that's 16.
no but no because this is one meter this
is all one meter it's a bit more than
one meter
I mean that's the only thing I can
really think of right
is if um
is basically if it's
just not quite hitting
16.
but 12.9 that's three meters away from
16. isn't it
like that doesn't make any sense you
could definitely fit more tiles here
in fact doesn't this look is this this
has got to be the same amount of tiles
but that's super strange
I wish I could select this guy but I
can't like I don't know which one he is
okay well this guy will do maybe no if I
want to
uh
well this is my this is minus 32 minus
27.
so that's obviously yeah it gets to
minus but say even this minus 32 minus
27 on Zed right like minus 30 would be
here
it's supposed to generate all the way up
to here I'm pretty sure
like look this is exactly 32 32.
but it's like it stops short
and I don't really know why
or at least up until 31 maybe I guess
it's not inclusive
but 31's here this is like look how much
how bad is 27.
and it goes to -32 on x
so why is it not doing all of the Zed
stuff
maybe I've got a bug somewhere
but doesn't really look like it
like this follow Biz should be being run
32 times
why wait
ah is it
no well it should be 32 hexagons yeah
but wait I mean this looks like 32
hexagons this doesn't I guess because
it's skipping
which would which would actually make
sense so see this goes to exactly 16 and
this flattens out perfectly but I guess
I've just screwed up the width a bit
which is the Zed and I think that's
because you can see that they're not uh
they're a bit intertwined or whatever
that might be why
but that that's also weird because
I'm clearly trying to do the same amount
of hexagons but I guess because they're
staggered I think that's why because
they're staggered
it makes them like
they're almost overlapping so it is
still 32 hexagons but it's kind of like
this
I think
but I'm pretty sure I don't have any
overlapping hexagons do I
like I said would this be one row
or
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen Seventeen eighteen
nineteen twenty one two three
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
yeah so that's definitely 32. so they're
all 32 but then here I've got one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten and twelve so that's why I
guess because this counts as a row
not this
hmm
and I guess that makes sense because if
we look at the I guess the X Offset you
can see if it's an even row yeah it gets
a 0.5 okay I see
so that's why
that is why
um
now the real question is what do we do
about it well
uh I guess that probably means that
like so what was the value here was it
like -27 so I think the reason why it's
like that is because 27
sorry 32 times 0.86 is 27.52 Yeah so
basically we this is this just happens
to be our distance
this is like our Z distance
Z tile
offset we'll call it
and so because that's our Z tile offset
I think we should probably
multiply the radius by that
uh and that will create a smoother
Landing for the um
yeah there's some weird stuff during
yeah
can I just do this though no I can't I
don't know why it's reloading assemblies
during play is a bit broken in this
Branch as well
okay so now uh uh yeah so now so we've
limited it to 13.76 which means it's
smooth out perfectly
um
and then
okay so there you go
so that I think is uh correct
so now let's stop our weirdo
debugging
and then I can also go back to
uh
this
and then I can also go back to my orange
hexagon and remove the text component
from it hopefully I won't need that
again but there we go alright so you can
see now we smooth out which is kind of
cool so we have these kind of edges now
obviously like if we go back to our
graph
um we could make it smooth out a bit not
at the last minute as well if we
actually wanted to
uh so let's see
so this is what it does at the moment
um
what would we how would we facilitated
that
uh
uh guess
what we increase this
wait when I say not smooth at the last
minute yeah I guess I wanted some buffer
so I guess you would just have B
as like a buffer and then if you if you
increase that it's like it but it also
that also causes it to start sooner so
it's not quite as good as the seams
and then that just ruins everything as
usual
um but yeah you could do that I guess to
increase the slope
or we could do that that's on there
that's not oh
that's the same thing yeah well of
course
yeah I don't know
what if we multiply everything by B
then that just does yeah that's the same
as s obviously all right whatever
I don't know if we necessarily want that
um like we could just Chuck in B here
and that kind of works
at least a little bit
so that's just before the second test so
maybe I will do B
and just do that
like add a little bit and that will just
kind of flatten out so see you kind of
get a more flat area now there's two
tiles here that are flat rather than
just nothing
okay so let's expand this a bit
and I I would like to maybe take these
and bake them into
uh you know one kind of
um
mesh because at the moment they're I
mean they are instanced they're yeah
like this would be it would be great to
do a custom kind of you know situation
for this because at the moment they're
all entities and they don't need to be
and it's very bad performance and it
means we can't go too much but 64 by 64
is fine how many is that
know that 4096 so that's not too bad
like we can handle that
um it doesn't take long to generate or
anything either but you know and that
can be one chunk
technically uh and I guess we would
totally well no we'd make each chunk
smaller like 16 by 16 or whatever
um and then we would
and then we could um
what would we do yeah we'd make each
chunk 16 by 16 and then we would uh just
make a lot of them so that we could
unload them and load them and stuff like
that and then for the Horizon we'd have
some fog as well but I don't know I
don't think this performance is great
and it's probably the CPU that's just
having to process 4000 STS like this and
calculate like well transforms for them
because we're still doing a few things
that are silly uh where's my scene
render panel I can take a look there
well the GPU is fine it's like six
milliseconds per frame
um but I'm guessing that the frame times
yeah 30 milliseconds
and most of that's probably going to be
nice stuff seems to work but most that's
probably going to be going through all
the entities
so yeah
um all right
now I want to turn off capturing for
physics
that's what Peter said to do capture on
play yeah yeah go away
um
project just in case
all right yeah so that's pretty cool
um now um we're gonna I guess we can
play with I mean that's not pretty cool
it's not bad but I would like to
actually have it generate rivers and you
know do some cool things maybe
uh which is not at the moment so I think
that's what we'll move on to next and I
might actually look at some
tutorials or whatever something to get
some better
uh
structures but I guess maybe before we
do that even it might make sense to
generate
like the map
um
oh imagine could you imagine if every
time it unloaded a chunk it regenerated
it when it loaded it again so that way
when you return the terrain's different
that would be kind of cool
I'm tempted to do that but otherwise if
we didn't want to do that we would just
generate the actual noise value for the
huge map so if your map was like I don't
know a kilometer by a kilometer or
something so a thousand a thousand
um units of in-game units a thousand
meters uh you would generate a thousand
by a thousand floats which is your noise
value no but just one noise value but
and then all you have to do is basically
do you do this kind of not instantiate
but set the tile values to what they are
per chunk and we could do 16 by 16
chunks basically
so that's how we would do it um I think
we can do that next it's very very easy
to do that
um Zoom it is what I use to draw on the
screen
uh it's quite good let's Zoom it I
really like it
for streams and for videos and well just
for life really
uh okay so
that's what I think we'll do and then
obviously like we could do something
like at the moment we instantiate
whatever on Earth we want but
um we could uh obviously
kind of yeah I think okay we could
obviously change the like make the blue
ones like it's kind of like water so
have that be you know if there's a
certain um
we could make zero like the water level
for example I don't think we have to
have like multiple water levels but we
could make zero at the water level uh
and then that would mean that anything
that is below zero effectively gets kind
of clamped to zero
um and that way we don't really have
because I don't think I'm gonna make
underwater sections or anything
um
and I'm not going to do overhangs or
anything complex like that
but yeah so that's when I separate the
noise generation and I'm really just
need to go to the bathroom for like two
seconds and I'll be back nothing major
foreign
quickly explain what the plans are for
the game uh yes
um they are
uh
basically you are it's set in like a war
zone you're like some Soldier or
whatever and you need to deliver coffee
to the general
and it's kind of physics based a little
bit there's enemies trying to attack you
you can't fight very well and can't
treat very well if you're holding the
coffee but you can put the coffee down
which makes the enemies attack the
coffee
um but you can fight better and you need
to get to the
uh General and deliver the coffee but
also the coffee itself is kind of
physics based so if you like jump around
too much with like while holding the
coffee and Dodge and change direction
and you're a bit aggressive then you'll
like the coffee will spill will start to
spill out and if obviously you spill too
much of it you lose
that's the game basically and it's kind
of hexagonal
you know looks like this
at the moment uh you can kind of shoot
it's kind of third person-ish you can
tilt the camera a bit as well
um
and uh I'm working on map generation
Tim is working on Art if you go to
studio.com you can see all of them
all of the um
all of our streams at once and Peter is
currently working on sleeping I believe
actually is Peter sleeping yet
maybe it's not
uh no I think he's live
yeah so this is uh Studio channel.com I
just made this early in the Stream
actually like yesterday but you can see
you can see all all streams at once in
my chat
because I had to choose a chat
it's kind of cool to see everyone I
guess working
at the same time
all right
so let's see uh
yeah so we're gonna separate the purlin
noise from everything else
um
so let's do
generate noise values or something
so we'll do this first
and this will basically create uh well
the thing is I guess
yeah let's just make this a float array
I guess I can do that
I don't know is that good maybe I'll
just make a normal flat one actually I
think I'll do that that might be faster
I don't know I forget if this is
I think this is I think this is
contiguous in memory I'm pretty sure it
just means that you can address it kind
of by two values more easily maybe but
yeah
no this is all procedural
do some procedural stuff
um so let's just do noise values new
floats uh map with world of map with and
hide it probably going to be identical
but
and then this so what this will do is I
mean like literally let's just copy this
like it just does the noise so
if we look at what we need for the noise
it's kind of simple
this is the noise value so we'll see
everything after it we can immediately
discard
um and then for the noise value it needs
kind of this situation
um which now that that's like this we
can and we don't need those variables
anymore we can just simplify it to this
uh that I believe that yeah that does
matter
um although not really because we could
just generate a noise value for each
coordinate it doesn't need to be this
weird thing in fact that's probably
messing it up it's making it less
uniform
um but I guess this matters in a way so
let's maybe just put XP in here
and also the Zed tile offset like does
that matter that's probably making it
less uniform as well so let's just go
with zp as well
um and then yeah we can use our same
coordinate later okay so that's kind of
what we end up with
um and then that obviously goes into
our noise values uh x and z
um and that's all that does so now we're
basically done with noise and we
shouldn't use noise anymore so we can
get rid of it and generate chunk and
then based on where we are instead of
doing noise get this will just do noise
values and it will sample them at x and
z
so let's see if that works hopefully
that should work the same way as before
uh yep exactly the same
but the benefit now the benefit really
the huge benefit now is that we could be
like
um no we want way more noise
right so generate like you know this is
just doing map with by map height but
because we're going to introduce chunks
we can be like generate a map that's
like several kilometers large basically
with a noise value for each tile but
then not actually create all the tiles
at once basically because that's going
to be slow
um and that's going to be impossible
actually
depending on what scale you do it
um okay so that's cool
glad that's in there
um
next up then
oh and we have an amplitude for the
noise as well which
yeah we can
think about
uh if we want to actually keep three or
whatever
um so at the moment I'm working on
terrain generation uh I'm generating
like a bit of an island but I'm also
going to make it actually be chunks now
so
I guess we need to
um
uh private void
I don't it's not really a generate chunk
it's more like set chunk but uh let's do
this so we'll have we're basically gonna
make this be chunk width and height
and again let's make it 16 by 16.
and then we also need to have a private
hence
uh X chunk index y chunk index
oh is that actually a chunk index so
this is basically Where We Are
could just have it be one variable to be
completely honest but
we'll see how we go
um and so now kind of what I can do is
so this this dictates kind of what chunk
we're on and then we have this kind of
collection of tiles but we're going to
have that perch Arc now
we probably need four chunks I would say
like as a minimum obviously because if
you look like four chunks means that if
we're in any given spot as long as the
chunk is bigger than what we can see
which is not going to be but let's just
say it is then uh you know we need four
because we're if we're in a corner we
obviously need the corners of the chunks
to line up and like we need different
chunks here so that we can you know not
see empty space so four chunks is kind
of the minimum but we could also like if
we have the resources for it we could
also decide to you know do basically I
guess nine chunks because then that
would be kind of like having a chunk
you're in a central chunk and then you
have chunks all around you
um and that and then as you get as you
step off you that chunk gets you know
you you shift the chunks so I feel like
nine chunks is probably let's go with
nine chunks
[Music]
um
of 16 by 16 Maybe
uh so that's a three by three kind of
Chunk
situation
um
and
basically what we'll do
um is like so let's have a chunk here so
struct chunk or maybe this should be a
class let's make it a class I don't know
we'll see class chunk
um
maybe I should make this uh not part of
this but
the chunk itself is going to have the
tiles in it but this is a reusable chunk
and we'll create these up front so this
is kind of reusable
instantiated add in it like this is not
it's going to be reusable basically
um
I don't know if we want to make this a
property
really doesn't need to be but this small
I guess c-sharp style
um
so
yeah and then we're going to create I
guess we're gonna have a
list we just have a list of or this will
just be an array actually an array of
our chunks
and there's going to be nine of them
three by three we'll see
beautiful
um so
and then map width and height I mean
maybe this can be more like based on
chunks but no no I guess it should be
like this because this is tile based ish
so if I do want to basically say that I
want a certain amount of chunks so let's
go with like like we kind of said we
wanted
but at 64. well we can we can kind of
push this because this is four by four
chunks at the moment if we want
let's make it like six by six
so I want six chunks
let's just make this chunk size why do
we need width and height they're going
to be square
well actually they're not quite square
but because they're not Square in terms
of meters but they're Square in terms of
tiles
um
and yeah this will same okay so
that's good
um
but yeah but we have nine chunks okay so
the thing is
yeah so this is going to need an
external a z index basically and then
what it's going to have to do
is figure out where we are or in the
world so the X offset is going to be x
times chunk size
and then that should kind of that that
that that's going to give us the tile
index of where we are at which is good
because that's obviously going to give
us
um I don't know if we need to do that
it's gonna give us an offset yeah and
then we're gonna go through
the chunk size and basically set the
chunks up
but they're going to be at an offset
obviously
uh and that offset is exactly what we
have
uh our variables for so
so CX says chunks X chunk Zed and I
guess I'll refer to this as Zed
um and we'll do so yeah so we need to be
able to sample this now um immediately
like you know if we're
outside of the world like we should
really check that so if the chunk index
uh I guess times
well I mean we it'd be nice if we didn't
have to do this
um because at the moment the world is
not in terms of chunks
uh but also maybe if we're halfway
through a chunk it can just not generate
it yeah because that way we can have
partial chunks which might be cool I
don't know so
let's do this let's do
um so we need to we need to access two
things so first of all we need to know
which chunk it is that we want to
replace basically so we actually need
like a chunk index that's important and
that's going to be zero through nine
basically or zero through eight
so that's kind of what we're at
right
um
uh and then we need to yeah so we need
to sample the noise
for this tile so that's just going to be
that that's easy uh well no actually
it's not gonna be that it's going to be
this
I'll call this XT
because this is just in terms of
set of like tiles that's the indices
basically
um so that gives us a noise value now as
for where this should exist like in the
world
um
that is just going to be
uh x t plus x times
this size and the size is what we do
basically here
so I think that's going to be important
because it's hexagonal as well so
and yeah this whole situation I won't
worry about maybe for now because the
offset should take care of that actually
so we'll have we need even we need X
position
uh
hmm
and our Z offset we need as well which
is 0.86
that should probably just be a constant
up here or something
put this up here I don't really care
why is the scenario suddenly oh because
I moved that that's fine that's not
suddenly
um all right
yeah so what was my Zed at okay that's
just that
yeah okay so yeah so now we can actually
gather the translation
um
now the translation is going to be
this but now we need to calculate the
actual position
so
so basically yeah we need to uh
X tile offset I'll say
oh hex offset just to really indicate
that it's because of the hexagonal
nature of it and then the actual X world
that can just be here actually um but
basically this will be
uh it should be
oh no but we need we need this plus 0.5
that's important isn't it
uh this was the annoying thing in the
first iteration of this system actually
although maybe maybe not
um
because the thing is we can't just
multiply it uh and then this is the
regression of the chunk which that by
the chunk size
we're not even yeah so we're using that
for the sampling that's correct
but then this is fine as well that does
the placing but now we need a world
space offset for it
um but the thing is I think that's kind
of like
difficult Maybe
although maybe it doesn't have to be
maybe it's just
um like this is just
that
but that's not really quite right
maybe that also needs to be times that
times this
I think it is actually I think
I think that might be better that might
be okay
um but for this I'm a bit confused
because well it's because it's gonna be
because that's staggered
no but it's one isn't it or was that is
one one of these is one yeah so I I feel
like this is just going to be
that
but then you need to do plus X
I don't know man but then we're not
using this so that doesn't make sense or
plus this sorry because that's the same
thing okay maybe it's that I don't know
we can always just try basically and so
now what we can do is because we have
chunks and we have chunk index we know
which chunk this is so this is the chunk
we're working with
so now we can go in and basically do
what we did in generate chunk
which
ah but generate chunk
yeah why would we not have done this
immediately we I think we probably
should have Ryan
because why would we read redo it
we wouldn't okay that so that needs to
be fixed I think but um
long story short this is what we do
so to get the cha the
um it's just chunk dot tiles right to
get the tile we want
um and then yeah we I mean we have a
noise value but
and that also implies that we don't
uh we don't generate the whole map up
front which
I don't know maybe we should maybe we
can even multi-thread it
and have all these because it's just
math we can have all the noise
Generation stuff happening in the
background
potentially all for the for the rest of
the chunks anyway
um
but okay whatever it doesn't matter
though like for now let's just not care
about that let's just grab this so what
is this this is the translation that we
have already
so that's I guess this translation right
um this is yeah a little bit
white grenade initial tile set is that
what I'm trying to do no it's not
[Music]
uh this is oh but this is doing radius
okay we won't worry about the radius yet
oh we no we kind of have to but we'll
half worry about it
what could go wrong with that
um
yeah let's just not worry about it too
much for now
so what I'll do is
we'll grab
basically yeah we'll just set the
translation of this tile to be the
translation so we'll just try and do
this for now
whatever
um create initial tile set does that
need to happen probably not so this
expects it to be already created so
here's the thing
that's fine
uh
uh but not anymore actually because what
we're gonna do instead
I mean it's kind of simple it's kind of
similar isn't it uh so let me maybe not
delete all of that
we really just have to create them I
think
but the thing is we don't know which one
to create like because maybe it would
depend on the whatever we'll figure out
a way to change them I think later
because my point is at the moment like
we can't change the material we could
just change the individual material
surely
um to make a different you know colors
or whatever but yeah let's just not do
that for now um
so let's do
basically yeah it's gonna be this but we
have to do that for each chunk as well
so for chunk
chunk chunk in chunks
we have to basically be like chunk dot
tiles or ADD
and it doesn't really matter we just
instantiate it they're basically all on
top of each other but it doesn't matter
because we're going to go through them
again later
um
we're just creating the actual entities
first
although
yeah yeah
so that's gonna create nine sets of 16.
but the thing is nine times six so what
do we have before
like we had a map that was 64 by 64
which is four thousand NTS I'm just
worried I'll exceed that so if we have
16 times 16 times 9 no that's less okay
good so we have 256
and it sees basically 256 tiles per
chunk and we have nine chunks so that's
less that's good because 16 by 16
performed way better but that's yeah
that's 256 so yeah
bar but even 32 by 32 was fine so what's
that that's a thousand
I still it would be nice if we had less
but whatever it is what it is for now
you can always optimize it later
Famous Last Words
um all right so
oh yeah and the noise value here so I
think we just didn't know it's value
times three basically but that's
basically yeah that's how we did that
and that was for a given chunk so if we
do create initial tile set which I think
we're doing I don't know if I look right
little tile thing what does generate
chunk do that did the actual generation
which I'll just comment that off now uh
we won't do that anymore instead we'll
do basically we'll go through all of our
chunks
uh we'll have to do that by index though
um we'll do chunks I uh dot uh oh no no
chunks yeah we could have just taken in
the chunk actually instead of the trunk
index but whatever
um set chunk
I okay c x and c z is like the offset
um so let's I guess we can just probably
just do I divided by
I'm on 3i divided by three
so we're kind of doing a two-dimensional
thing here
uh that's gonna be but this isn't really
going to be around the origin anymore
is that fine
it doesn't matter does it like we can
make it around the origin maybe later
that would just mean we do minus one
basically
yeah I guess we can try negative because
that's like CX and sees it that's really
just used as a tile offset what's
important yeah so let's just try this I
guess so now we have the middle chunk
being here and then we have one chunk
either side of it right if I've done
that correctly
I should have
yeah because it's gonna be zero to two
zero two yeah
Mass one and since minus one to one
Maybe
okay I'm a bit scared but let's see if
this crashes or not yeah well it didn't
crash uh not reference accession all
right what's null
112.
this
um
yeah what is now
ah M chunks I don't think I actually
created the chunks did I
yeah I probably need to actually create
the chunks
115. are you still upset are you
okay I might just connect the debugger
let's see if this works
all right another exception so what's
null
chunk isn't all
how why they all know oh create initial
tile set happens
up there
you know what since you're the one doing
this why don't you actually set chunk to
something or does that need to be done
beforehand because it's not a reference
I don't know
but it makes sense that this function
should handle it
[Music]
yeah
Hazel just crashed
collects garbage tried to collect
garbage
hmm
that does not look promising there's a
lot of bodies
how much are we creating that's too much
why is that so much though
am I doing too much map sizing
probably
I think this will probably crash
um why though
create initial tile set oh that's strong
yeah that's why I Wrong surprise hasn't
crashed yet
um it's supposed to be whoops supposed
to be a chunk
size
because otherwise that's yeah that's way
too much stuff
[Music]
okay well there's all my hexagons um
so
index out of range though line 80.
this
uh X10 ZT out of range you say
oh
yes I mean I mean I don't know that
should be out of range but I definitely
should have added something because
that's obviously constant it should be
plus X but why is it already out of
range though where are my noise values
uh so there's noise values right they're
mapped with by map height
so that actually should be
oh it's because I went negative
yeah see the thing is
that's not negative
um
that's why I didn't want to do it that
way I think
um
yeah look I am just gonna do plus one
maybe
this is a bit dodgy but I'll write
something here
um
wait I does that make sense actually
because the thing is oh for chunks yes
no of course this won't because we're
gonna keep moving forward
so what this actually should be
is in this case if we start in the
origin
it'll be basically how like how much how
far are we away from the origin away so
like
uh if we have
um
because it's an index thing as well so
we have in this case we have six by six
chunks that's the size of the world
so constant map
with chunks is six right
so that's like the tile width
I'm getting a little confusing but
that's that's yeah so
since that's the case since we have six
one two three which we probably should
go with an odd number
then I guess you'd add
three right and then you subtract three
to get to the middle
and this would be map width chunks
so you have seven right two three four
five six seven you're in this one in the
middle
so you'd go one two three back
so you're subtracting half of that
rounded down
uh and then you'd uh yeah you'd add it
back so
minus that divided by two
minus I guess height divided by two
a little bit confusing but um whatever
uh and then you'll add that on so this
is fine
you add on half
uh but actually no that see that's wrong
that's just for the sampling oh but we
only use this for sampling no we don't
see that's the problem
oh that's that's really annoying so yeah
so we only want to do this
for the oops for the set
for this sampling
so sampling X is that plus
that
let's just do that maybe
oh but then no it's actually this that
needs to be changed
I hate everything this is getting too
complicated
rubbish
okay and that clearly didn't work either
dude oh it did crash
uh but that isn't that right a lot
roughly correct at least
no the syntax highlighting is not from
visual assist uh this is my own theme
foreign
we might want to run through this with
the debugger attached I think
probably be the best thing to do
so
this is zero correct
because wait this is our chunk is minus
three so now it looks like we have where
to sample from which is zero and we have
an actual World kind of position of the
tile
so in terms of tile coordinates we're at
-48 when it comes to the world now that
being said though
I don't know why we're creating those
tiles though so see that's oh that's why
they were away from the play it's fine
that we're making them I guess
that makes sense because we shouldn't be
creating these but we're just we've just
decided to do oh and we're only doing
three
ah okay
yeah yeah okay no let's not do that
um let's uh stop this
um
what we should have done is
um this is cool that it's doing this or
whatever but the thing is I don't care
about it because this is just an
arbitrary chunk index so let's not let's
actually still do minus one
right which that will result in a
different area of the noise generation
basically
um
and also this let's just make this mod 3
still because we're trying to do 9x9
chunks
uh mono
yeah number nine trucks no three by
three chunks
okay
so the positions are a bit worrying but
we should have uh and it's because it
also crashed
it's gonna take a while
uh 91 was bad
yeah I mean I I'm not surprised because
this is so Doge
yeah like you can't do that by map width
this is chunk width man what are you
doing
a chunk size
let's just quickly see if that okay
um that's not bad uh I mean it's very
bad but it's not bad you can clearly see
all my chunks
the chunks themselves are at different
levels and also they're massively
overlapping
um
let's have a look at why that might be
um so
I mean
I don't know if it's because of the
zero what it is but
because where does this yeah so we get
that offset
which already has X in it
and see the extra is X Plus 0.5 I feel
like we're correct on the x-axis so
let's actually for now just to simplify
this let's set translation Z to zero so
that we can just kind of
generate them along one axis well no
that's clearly not the right offset
which is strange because I believe the
correct offset
isn't the correct offset
um
oh that's wrong already
what this used to be right when I set it
up I thought
what
when did that when did this happen
now they have to be two meters apart oh
everything's doubled what
weird
I think that should be I mod three no
this is correct so I'm mod three to get
the x i divided by three to get the Y
what is that
um that's weird this is weird uh
this must be something different
um which I guess would mean that
everything has to be kind of multiplied
by two now
which is kind of annoying
I don't even know if this would work
properly
but also that's not the X offset is it
so the X no that is the X actually
so they have to be at a distance of two
from each other now that used to be one
I don't know what happened
but it looks like they have to be at a
distance of the of yeah and then
meanwhile
so that means this these have to be
one away instead of 0.5
and then the Z is
double yeah everything's been doubled
somehow
that's a little bit suspicious though
okay anyway we're focusing on the X so
uh XT if it's even we do the plus 0.5
um because we've decided to do that yeah
so this now is yeah and but it gets
doubled because this becomes one instead
of 0.5 but we do double it
but we're also doubling the 0.5 yeah
I guess that's correct
but this doesn't work so clearly it's
not correct
um
so why is that wrong
is that another one that's hiding yeah
it is oh well because they're all on top
of each other because I did Zed I made
they're the same
because it's all zero
but why is that wrong
yeah so the offset is now times two
that does kind of ruin a few things
though because now yeah so we have to
basically double that
and then sometimes we have 0.5
is that fine though so if that's one we
get I'll give us 1.5 which gets doubled
to three I guess that's correct
this does seem correct an XT is just
like ultimately
that's going to be the position of the
chunk that
yeah but see uh I guess maybe this needs
to be multiplied by two as well and
that's why
no
what's weird is it doesn't seem to be
actually moving it
like if I don't do this this is the only
thing that sets that right yeah
so then why when I double it even it
still doesn't like
and let's also set y to zero
it's weird because I clearly made it a
lot bigger I made it two right and it's
still close together so that's really
weird look at this
like how is that happening
or is this like just crazy let's just
put a breakpoint in and take a look I
think
like am I just very very wrong here so
minus 80.
is our first x value
even as true
X is zero X offset is zero x t is minus
sixteen times two so minus 32.
0 and we get minus 80.
wait why do we get minus eighty
why is that minus eighty
it's 2 times -16 plus
zero
is this just the debugger being weird
I think it might be
why is it minus 80
that doesn't make sense does it 2 times
x t 2 times minus sixteen that's minus
32 plus zero
minus 78 minus 76 but clearly two meters
apart
let's jump to the next like the zedro or
whatever
minus 79 minus
ah
I am a fool
I'm a Fool all right it's because we
need to offset it obviously ugh
okay
if we're truly doing it this way then it
would look very different because what
would happen is this basically stays the
same
which is double as well
which let me just do this for now and
I'll fix it later
um
X yeah the X offset can remain
but
it's because yeah they need to be
staggered
um so that's fine I think
and Zed will if I do that with zed
um does that work
but why am I doing Zed here
no I don't think you need that I have a
feeling it's just this
but I might be wrong
okay tomorrow I crashed again I don't
know why mono yeah the debugging the
debugger seems to crash mono sometimes
which I think we know about that bug I'm
pretty sure
okay that didn't quite work
um but my point is I think yeah these
are all just they just happen to be
staggered so one of these see it's
supposed to be up here but it's not
because it's not shifting on the z-axis
and this is the x-axis
that's what I think is happening
um
oh I don't know this doesn't make sense
actually
wait but neither does this because this
is just times x t so where's X coming
into play Oh X is in X hex offset that's
why so this should be Z Plus that maybe
but that also seems like yeah not enough
distance oh but it used to be because
now it's times two but because of the
nature of Zed it might just be also
times eight six
um yeah I think it is so that's times
0.86
because Z was always a bit yeah there
you go that's perfect
all right sick
uh and I think that looks like more than
16 by 16 tiles so that's got to be all
of our chunks now what we could do is we
could draw chunk boundaries
that would probably be good
um
I mean I could even I guess we should
generate that uh
let's do this let's do this this will be
good I think this will be nice uh we'll
create just a like a cube
we'll make it like super tall I guess
and
maybe I'll make it 0.5 by 0.5 so it's a
bit thinner we'll make it like
sure 30 meters tall and we'll make it
well let's make it kind of
kind of maybe 20 meters tall actually
that should be enough to see
um and let's make it let's give it a
material
let's give it the muzzle flash material
or is that too that's a bit annoying
let's give it
um
chunk marker
yeah I just want to do like a little
just like a bright kind of material it
just indicates like hey this is the
chunk
basically
um and then we'll make a prefab out of
it
actually let's delete that I'll make a
little folder called debug question it's
a folder we're used to not having few
features
um all right so there's our trunk marker
prefab and then the idea is this is zero
zero Ryan Yes zero zero zero so now the
idea is I can instantiate one of those
at each chunk marker so
um
private void debug create chunk markers
and then basically what I want to do is
for the size of the map right so we've
got map with chunks and stuff
for an I uh y equals zero Y is less than
I should really use that
wise up
uh we can just do instantiate
um
prefab
chunk marker
and the translation will be
new Vector three
let's see so x uh
uh wait
how does this work
0.86 is the uh it's because
uh it's not uniform
um
anyway
let's do
wait because the problem is like what's
interesting is that yeah I guess we'll
have to multiply it by that
so
let's do
um
I guess this should be high technically
but they're the same
so we'll subtract half of that
yeah
um and that I guess X stays the same
but then with this guy
we need to apply that 0.86 offset
because the Zed chunks on the Zed are
gonna be a bit smaller it's not a square
because it's not that yet so
I think that should maybe work
uh for our trunk markers
uh I have about a set
um
the chunk marker
of course
why did that not work man
oh no no no no no no I forgot to
multiply it by chunk size
that's the chunk index and then the
chunk size is this
and so let's do
I think that should work
I guess so but it's a bit
is that really 16 by 16 tiles though
one two three
four five six seven eight nine like what
weird
I should really yeah make chunks as
parent entities that would be nice as
well
yeah I'm gonna have a lunch break soon
um
this is the index correct correct
wait but yeah and then chunks oh no no
no it's because we have the stupid
um times two now for tiles because this
is the thing guys tiles used to be
exactly one meter across like as in if
you wanted to join two tiles on the
x-axis it was times one basically and if
it was on the z-axis it was times 0.86
they were a little bit closer together
0.87 or whatever
um
but now everything's doubled for some
reason and I still don't know why maybe
Peter did something
so I think this these are our chunks
I I
when
I I don't remember oh
um so what uh let me actually look at it
from above
so zero one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
good
um and then
this way one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen so
this is on a 17 yeah so I think
um I think that's correct because again
remember they're not uniform I mean if
we wanted to truly know and this is what
the entire map should look like but
we're just focusing on an area in
between and then we've got the chunks
around us
um the thing is though
uh if we really want to be good at this
which I think we should
every chunk should have like a root
entity
which I think we can just create or we
could instantiate a prefab Maybe
because I we can we still create
entities
yeah I think we can
we can just create an entity like we
don't have to create a prefab
so yeah so if I do this when I create
the chunk
um
you know let's just do no no here
no create initial yeah here it is new
chunk
Toyota Constructor I guess I will
um
chunk
we'll give it an index
so root entity equals new entity
basically uh name
no sorry it's not new messages create
entity
ah um great
this is an energy so I can't access that
API for some reason uh
no it's static yeah I thought so it's
scene.create entity
you stupid thing
um all right so
is that good probably
uh and the reason why I'm doing this is
because I want when I do instantiate
um for not this but for my initial
create initial thing instantiate I want
to instantiate child and uh it's going
to be
um from the root entity of
whatever chunk I'm on right
so that way they're nicely grouped and
organized and you'll see why I'm doing
this as well
[Music]
but actually this just isn't working
this is an interesting bug
so it can't find uh
one of the things here what happened
the zero argument Constructor for oh it
needs
yeah that's uh that's a bit dodgy we
should really not do that
but apparently we need a default
Constructor or it just will not
could go for a bun me
they open today it's Sunday
do you guys like Bon maze
I do
okay so now we have you can see all of
our chunks here
and then each chunk contains out
hexagons now one of the reasons why I
did this was you can see now I can
easily select the chunks and I can see
the chunks which is fantastic
um actually multi-selection is really
good for this because before it didn't
used to do that
um so it's nice that we can just easily
kind of go through you know all of our
chunks
uh but also what I can do for example is
like if I wanted to I could obviously
grab this and if I go to show gizmos in
play mode I can just move that chunk
away
and that's nice because I can
investigate what the heck my
trunk Market where my chunk markers are
because they look a bit
like they shouldn't maybe be there they
should probably be in between the tiles
or something
[Music]
um
because it's a bit weird isn't it but I
guess it doesn't really matter
well no actually does I need to be able
to know where the chunks are so that I
can generate new ones right
yeah
no I kind of want to walk there
I think it'd be good to get outside a
bit
um check this out though I got chunks
generating
so these are just the chunk boundaries
but what's really cool is multi
selection because it highlights the
whole chunk yeah
so I really like I quite like that
um
but yeah
now I can just yeah this is all kind of
generating
these are chunks now which is good
because yeah we can have an infinitely
sized World kind of that's cool
um at what point do we still get in
trouble
no uh not in this game not in this game
no it's not gonna be that big
uh go on 10 minutes
I just want to wrap up my I want to do
some more things like add some height
now
so instead of setting translation y zero
I can now actually set it to something
and watch it fail
uh okay so that's a bit weird it's like
it's not
but it is sampling uh because it's
sampling from this is why so
this is like the offset uh and then we
still need to do plus X Plus Z otherwise
we're looking at basically the first
value for each chunk so you can see now
we have a smooth terrain that doesn't
really look like it's made up of chunks
that are joined together but obviously
we know better than that we know that
they are just you know chunks that are
kind of joined together right
um which is pretty cool
but they transition smoothly is my point
so yeah
um
I don't really don't like these chunk
markers uh
they're annoying
um there should probably be a lot
thinner shouldn't they
point two
ah no
maybe even 0.1
okay they're thinner now
they're just a little guideline like I
don't really think we need them
sure
so let's not create the markers I want
to take a nice screenshot for the uh
thumbnail
of the of the YouTube thing
call right
although it's nice to see
a bit of a top-down view Maybe
the icons
because every day I've been showing like
every part has a different screenshot
of the live stream I'm in every
thumbnail
so this was like yesterday's
today's so it's changed quite a bit
we lost uh the outline effect
because you guys liked it more without
but also I liked it more without so
fine
now we have this and some generation and
a better character maybe I don't know if
better is the right word but a different
character
because it's still a box on my thing
okay
just going to update this stream
thumbnail
oh wait
no I did I did the wrong thing
I forgot the rest of it
[Music]
whatever that'll do
okay
cool
um all right
all right so yeah so got the trunks kind
of working I guess the next real step is
to
when you move to be like I need to
request a new chunk
um
how do we do that
I mean
it's pretty easy I guess you could just
be like all right if I'm like you know
it like first of all tell me where I am
tell me what my chunk index is like
where is the player yeah
um that's kind of easy like if I want to
know where the player is
I can just be like tell me the players
like translation the x and z translation
uh player chunk
go back to two
uh and then just
the thing is it's because it's centered
around the player I don't know if I like
this whole centering maybe I shouldn't
have centered it around the origin
because that just makes everything so
much harder but anyway
um if I do play a chunk
because otherwise I would just basically
be like
um the translation should just be kind
of divided by the chunk size but I guess
this is gonna be
um
like the X would be divided by basically
two
oh wait that's the tiles no no
could I just divide it by the chunk size
probably not because
yeah they're not exactly uniform they're
in terms of tiles and tiles of two so
this would be
maybe that and Zed would be that because
of that like whoops because of that Zed
offset
so I think this tells me
um
why are you not happy
huh
oh sorry it's a vector so that's my
that's maybe my my uh my yeah so let's
do um
player
uh I was gonna maybe get the text the
debug text component
I don't know if we have one
I thought we had a debug text we do
um
find MC5 tag this is for debugging debug
text get component text component dot
text equals
uh string dot format what is it again
it's zero zero
or XX it's so annoying yeah here it is
no it's not x axis
zero dot Hash Hash Hash oh my gosh I can
never remember that
um
and we'll have to do play a chunk.x
player chunk dot y and
this will be that comma
that
so this this should give us the chunky
note but again again we have to also
from that I think
subtract
half
of the
map with chunks basically
which is LOL
all right well that's giving us like oh
no no okay and then we floor it
obviously yeah
so let's do that and then
play a chunk.x equals you know math f.4
or whatever
and that gives us the and we can just
cost 20 inches later but this is just
for the debugging okay so uh let me go
back so this is my chunk apparently
minus four minus four does that sound
right no it should be minus three I
think
okay that looks good like you can see
when I move off the chunk it's like it
thinks I'm on a different chunk
um that might be a bit dodgy
um
maybe I don't need to oh no that is
correct
because the chunks start at zero so
actually where's zero
no no I think this is correct it's just
remember it's not rendering all of them
if I bring back my debug create chunks
create create chunk markers I think
you'll find that I am correct uh so if I
go
where's zero I'm trying to go towards
zero
which seems to be here yeah so you can
see this is zero right
and then this is going to be oh wait was
it negative oh it was negative
probably should be positive Ryan
that should be because it's a negative
chunk index but this is zero and it
looks a little bit off because you can
see it thinks that I'm outside for some
reason oh I am never mind I'm just dumb
I think it transitions to one around
here and what's my location
128 apparently huh
yeah so 127 is like the cutoff yeah I
think that I think I'm pretty sure
that's correct
um
but yeah why is it negative
like
oh cause the translation isn't it is
negative is
was not positive 120 did you guys don't
see that was that not
am I negative territory no I'm not what
are you talking about
what
the player's location here is positive
32 it's minus four
on Zed but it's positive X right now
oh but I'm subtracting half of the thing
because it's centered around the origin
that whole thing again
okay whatever I'm gonna take a break
have some lunch
um
and we'll get back into it
but yeah
it's definitely some work
um but basically the next step is like
once I figure out the trunk coordinates
properly and everything is tight and
like works well uh I can just start like
loading in chunks and unloading chunks
and it's not really loading in it's just
like
basically moving every single piece from
one side of the board to the other you
know that's kind of all it is to kind of
like you know if we if we if we if we're
always in the middle as soon as we step
on to this chunk it means unload this
chunk and instead like load in the new
chunk which would be you know here uh
whoops here right so you're kind of just
shifting it across
um and that's why it's nice to have kind
of a three by three grid because then
you can just say that you know like
if this is my my 3x3 grid nice aspect
ratio if this is my 3x3 grid
then as soon as I move from this tile to
this tile that means immediately cut
these off and make a new blob over here
right
[Music]
um
and the same for like you know whatever
if I move on if I move from here on to
here then it's kind of like drop all of
these and add all of these but you kind
of separated by axis so that's kind of
what's going to happen all right um I'll
leave this up hopefully it doesn't crash
um
actually you guys won't know if I write
stuff but yeah I'll just having a lunch
break and I'll be back soon
enjoy the music
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
okay
[Music]
foreign
wanna hear the ocean rock crash over me
hold me tight and don't let go watch
over me
[Music]
let me left behind
us
[Music]
and let me fall deep enough
one we are
on one we are all we are all one we are
we are we are all
right
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
City
what you will about love
[Music]
let me go
dance
more than we say or do
I don't wanna
say
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all forever
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
These Eyes you make me shiver Rock in my
mind nothing innocent
[Music]
I'm a queen of kids
foreign
[Music]
with me
foreign
[Music]
the world
foreign
[Music]
you know
what's going
on
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
baby
songs
[Music]
no one's telling it straight to you
I don't know how you feel it
no one knows
[Music]
never going to
do stuff
[Music]
Never Enough
all right I'm back
what's up guys did you miss me
oh
now the tasty lunch
how's it going stream
um okay so uh I guess this would be a
nice opportunity to do a bit of a
refresher on what we're doing
those of you who may be joined later or
I mean that's the good thing about
YouTube streams you can rewind them
but uh we're making a game and like I
don't know Tim and I were talking about
this over lunch like I don't
I don't know it feels a bit Bland at the
moment like I feel like I need some good
ideas and
I also feel like
you know when you're doing let them down
when you're doing game jams it's like
you want to find a good middle ground
between
enough content but not too much content
because when you try when you start
making it more com like complex
and more like complicated you wind up
uh well apart from it being more work it
almost reduces from the game like less
is more in a sense you know
you kind of want to be able to
um
find a good middle ground of like this
is a simple concept and it like I'm I'm
very much in favor I think of
like living or leaving like the a lot of
the game elements almost like the fun of
the game depends on the player you know
that's why I feel like it's so easy to
just make a multiplayer game put it on
Steam and then everyone loves it because
it's like it's almost like a multiplayer
game that you can play with your friends
it's kind of like BYO fun you know you
bring you bring your own fun to it
because it's just a place for you to
hang out with your friends and be on a
Discord call and just
have a good time and the game is like
the game is good like it needs to
facilitate that
but it's not the thing that causes it
right it's like
you know if you go in
I don't know
I was gonna say going out to a
restaurant but I guess eating is fun as
well but you know if you go out to a
restaurant it's a lot of times like the
people you're with
that's the important thing you know and
the eating is like secondary but like
for most people it's probably primary
but you know it's nice to kind of go to
a restaurant
um and that it gives you like a venue
for you to hang out with a friend and
spend some time socializing and so games
can be like that as well and so
that's in a way that's how I feel and I
feel like what we're doing here like is
a little maybe too complicated by the
way this didn't crash which was nice
because I left it running all the way
through lunch and I can hear my
my computer is my fans are wrong quite
loud
but
yeah I don't know
is it weird to make a game in your own
engine you don't have issue with getting
distracted thinking about improving the
engine instead of working again
nah well like of course there's features
here and there that I'm like yeah that'd
be nice that'd be nice but uh in general
not really like it's it's like I'm
especially today like I'm kind of
focusing on the game and I can do that I
think because
it really kind of feels like
the engine is just the engine's capable
enough where it's now like I can focus
on making an actual game
rather than having to like you know deal
with the engine itself all the time
because that sucks like I don't really
don't like doing that
um so it's nice to not really worry
about that
uh okay so anyway
um
yeah so we're generating chunks right
like these are all chunks
for those of you who missed we were
basically early in the Stream which you
can rewind or you can watch it later
they'll stay up on YouTube uh you know
we basically created these white lines
they're like chunk markers so these are
like boundaries of chunks and then we
have basically nine chunks right and I
can select them all so you can see them
uh but like you know that's a chunk
that's a chunk that's the chunk they're
being all kind of generated from Pearl
and Noise
or actually Simplex noise technically
um there are little gaps between them as
well which is
kind of interesting so you can see that
like
there's a gap
um but uh yeah we have these kind of
chunks being generated which is really
cool
um because it's gonna mean that we can
have basically an infinitely sized world
oh yeah Peter sorry I forgot that you
wanted to call let's jump on a call
totally forgot about that
all right what's up Peter
[Music]
foreign
thank you
okay yep never mind
I don't know how that managed to happen
but whatever yep can you hear me now
I thought it was a stream that couldn't
hear me because it looks like uh
it looked like I joined the Discord like
call and then
um I noticed that in OBS my volume
wasn't working for my mic but
um and I thought you were hearing me
because I was like talking and you seem
to be replying during the call
um which was funny
um yeah but what I guess I think what
happened was when I went to adjust the
main speaker volume I somehow without
noticing hit the 48 volt like phantom
power button on my interface and it just
cut out like obviously the mic turned
off basically so
um that's funny
um but yeah
unless you heard what I yeah I heard
everything you said yeah yeah
um I was gonna say that yeah like the
the replacing the same things fine my
level Generation stuff should basically
work anywhere like it's it'll take a
little bit to set up but I might make it
into a prefab to make it easier and like
it's basically mostly in a script so
like it'll be fine
um
but yeah like I have a I have noise
generating terrain with a chunk system
and I'm halfway through the trunk system
like we can get chunks generating I just
need to you know replace them as the
player moves basically I'm up to that
part so it's almost done um
and I'm going to keep working on that uh
Tim and I had a bit of a chat during
lunch
um and I guess like I mean Tim thinks
that it's like this game is just a bit
well a it's too much too much content
too much complexity like he like
dichotomy more because it was so simple
um which I guess I agree with a little
bit but also he said that um
uh
he said that like it feels like you know
the act the actual game itself running
around shooting enemies you know that's
like any game like that's been done a
million times and so it feels a little
bit like yes there's a little bit of a
coffee mechanic but other than that it
just feels like a
a clone of every other game you know
that just is skinned differently
ultimately and like I think I I I kind
of agree I just think that maybe we're
focusing a little bit too much on
fleshing it out with so many features
but at the end of the day like I feel
like
I feel like what's really really the
most important thing to this game is the
primary mechanic which is the fact that
you are carrying a cup of coffee which
can spill and so you have to be careful
because I feel like in every other game
like if you're running around in Call of
Duty or whatever you know you're not
thinking about like oh I better not move
too sporadically you know like that's
not that's not even a consideration like
you don't even think about the movement
you just make the player move the way
that you want to move but what could be
cool about this game is the fact that
you can't just rotate as quickly as
possible you can't just you know you
have to be a little bit more deliberate
with your movements and calculated with
your movements and also balance that
with maybe putting the coffee down if
you really think that there's going to
be a big engagement
um so I feel like that mechanic is
really important and showing that
somehow so again ideally I feel like we
would have this massive pot of like you
know a a few dozen cubes in it and then
if you moved his sporadically the
physics would naturally mean that they
fall out because that obviously would
mean that people could kind of
you know it would it would come with all
the benefits that a physics engine has
like in terms of like you know you can
you need to keep track of momentum you
need to you can maybe like do some cool
moves where because like you keep the
momentum going somehow you can avoid
spilling you know or whatever you might
have to slow down slowly like you know
it it naturally gets us a lot of
mechanics obviously
um by just using physics so I feel like
we need to figure out a way to do that
ultimately and then the other thing
really I think is the enemies like the
enemies need to
be better in terms of like you know they
need to be a little smarter I think so I
don't know like my plan kind of today is
I would like I'm gonna I would love to
spend the next eight hours or even nine
hours working on
terrain generation and make it basically
perfect and done because I don't I think
I'll be able to do that in nine hours
um because the main system's there and
it's going to be mostly about making it
look good and stuff and I might add like
some nice water effects and whatever if
I have time but that's going to
basically be today to rent and then
tomorrow uh I can take a look at Ai and
you know Make it try and make the
enemies actually
behave a little bit yeah in a cool way
because that might be cool
um
but you know aside from that it's kind
of like I think what what we're gonna do
maybe when Tim comes back or I can do
this myself or whatever is I feel like
we need to take take control of the
direction of this game and actually be
like all right
players toss intent what does that look
like uh where did where does the player
get the coffee from where is the general
that the players taking the coffee to
how does it how does he know where to
take the coffee to and what is that
Journey kind of like
um yeah
yeah yeah I think that sounds like a
good plan
um it's actually like part of the reason
why I kind of just
figured you know what I just have to
stop tweaking the character controller
yeah and just call it good and start
working on other things yeah they're
done and they can be polished you really
need to like have a breadth first kind
of approach when it comes to a game Jam
yeah
yeah because like it's it's a little
buggy but I'm like
bugs we can fix later
if we have time we can fix them before
we ship you are of course allowed to do
some yeah I'm fixing afterwards yes it
doesn't change the gameplay too much
yeah but it's also like it's it's at the
end of the day like it's not like we're
gonna be winning there or anything like
it's not it's not like we even care
about that it's like what we're doing
this because it's fun and because it
obviously is very useful from a learning
perspective like I've never really done
terrain generation like this before it's
really fun to explore that
um and so because of that it's kind of
like
um like character controllers on the
animation system well yeah so like it's
you know at the end of the day it's like
a fun game is obviously good uh and that
should drive what we're doing here but
at the end at the end of the day like it
should it should be about the journey
not the destination of like what is the
final product what is the final game
it's about it is about the journey
um
so yeah and and it's good as well in in
this sense because obviously during
dichotomy like I spent two days I think
out of three working on the engine and
the asset pack system and
multi-threading and all that stuff
um whereas I'm actually working on the
game this time so we have a little bit
more technically we have more resources
even though Tim is working more on the
art because there's more art than in
dichotomy and I think he
he doesn't think he's going to be able
to do any engine like as in any uh
editor stuff or scripting really but
that's okay because I think both of us
will be okay like yeah with that
all right yeah
um
okay so I'm gonna basically push my
character controller stuff
um it's obviously containers on scene so
it shouldn't be too much of a problem
uh I did have to do some engine fixes so
you'll have to pull that if you're gonna
try it out yep
okay uh I'm just trying to think what I
should work on
next
um so you said you're good you're
obviously going to finish up the um
the terrain generation yeah and you're
moving on to enemy AI yes
I I think you should you should do
either the coffee mechanic or like
um the actual like
uh the gameplay basically like meaning
like where do you get the coffee from
and where do you take the coffee to
because it would be really good to have
that kind of vertical slice completed
yeah so that we can at least play
through the game and then fill in the
gaps rather than you know figure that
out there figure that out at the end
prioritize you know getting like
kind of gameplay
done like with you know picking up the
coffee and then dropping it off yep just
so we have that and then work on like
actually losing coffee
uh like having it spill out and stuff
like that all through that
I mean like yeah no no I I agree
definitely do the gameplay stuff first
but I was gonna also ask like uh because
with Jolt like if I wanted to say add 50
little cubes and I mean like small cubes
to
a a pot or a cup
like how well do you think that would
work
because it's obviously optimized like
for meters I guess now or at least
centimeters probably
uh meters
yeah like I'm just wondering like is it
even worth trying I guess I could just
try it right now on stream c yeah but I
think because that would be the best
thing by far obviously to do it that way
yeah I think what my uh tried outstream
because of the way okay like in the
physics Branch
if this is empty Branch I imagine it
would be
pretty performant
um because we do proper broad face
layering
we don't do that in this version okay
um that could be problematic
yeah
so I'm almost
certain that it's gonna be quite a
performance hog
but I'm watching your stream so it'll be
interesting to see yeah
so if I just add a rigid body
to this guy dynamic
uh sure
so okay so that's a one by one meter
right
um so how big
0.01
is it
probably so point one is the minimum
yeah I guess it's not bad right minimum
safe so that's 10 centimeters
which is like big it's bigger than a cup
unless we blow up the units of the whole
game
um I mean I don't know that that problem
will work with uh with the character
controller considering it's animated
yeah all right so let's uh make okay
pots you can't you can't make it smaller
it's just you'll have to change the
convex radius for the box shape uh in
the engine code right it could be
smaller
I'm making a little container
okay
so
so here's my coffee
which I'm going to add a material to of
course
sure
okay
um
save that scene
uh so I guess like
container
I guess I'll just do this manually right
I'll just duplicate
so that's 12.
and then
24. let's do 48.
uh multi-select just makes this like
possible first of all because without it
so if I just simulate that I mean I
don't see why that would wouldn't work
right that's only like
um so in that case since Peter says it's
nothing
let's um
yeah but also
now one thing we are missing is
selection like as in being able to draw
a box selection that would be nice
but anyway
very tall cup of coffee here but there
there's your coffee right
done
and we could of course tighten them up
now okay here's something what if I
scale them down can I do that with
do I have to change something give it
give it uh so you would probably want to
see individual Origins
I don't know how well it works it might
be broken
pretty well
that's great I don't know what you're
talking about
um
I don't know I can make this probably a
lot smaller now
yeah
hang on but they're smaller than Point
why now
yeah of course
that's what I'm saying
they have .04
so I guess I fixed it
so what if we do point zero one
okay that doesn't work
okay so that does
yeah okay okay so yeah and that's
because the convex radius
of the Box shapes point zero two doesn't
work yeah
point zero three
0.03 works
it seems to be a
that's three centimeters
that's pretty good like yeah if I
tighten this a bit
like let's really oh well actually okay
so if I was pouring this let's just say
we're pouring this
so here's my full coffee
so I'm gonna make a
four of them right
so that's what uh four times three
twelve
so let's go with you about
we'll go with about 50. so this is 48
right
so and then obviously to reflect the
fact that this is now a lot smaller
uh let's select this is all of it no
um
let's make this a lot smaller now does
that thing actually yeah whatever
I was going to say does that thing
actually work because I I my translation
my scale Gizmo disappears if I don't
have it on
like the origin thing
uh yeah that's I that's
kind of intentional because it doesn't
work if you do
um like a common origin
right
because I wasn't able to get that
working and so me and Tim basically just
decided let's disable it that's fun
okay
main game mechanic basically done
this coffee cup is beautiful
definitely coming soon to my merch store
okay
so
make sure we don't have any leaks
wouldn't want to lose that coffee
okay
there's Lakes
actually this might be too thin now yeah
I think scale basically went to zero on
the y-axis well yeah
scale is way too thin for those
yeah you can see x x axis no that was
translation actually yeah
yeah okay so the bot well I guess it
needs to be thicker
but that's probably 0.03 or oh really as
big as the coffee
what if it's a mesh collider on a cup
that we make
I mean that would be fine because that's
just like check it out coffee
and I guess we could add more if we
wanted to right
yeah like
sure
hey
all right so that's our coffee setup
uh
uh let's put that into a cup
and I want to make a prefab out of it
coffee
setup
sure all right so now
back to the main scene
and we could
have a little coffee set up
nice origin
um but yeah
there's my coffee and like that's a good
size
I bumped into it and ruined everything
down they're on the plane
uh
because there's a big plane on the
ground
but yeah I did notice that there is
something left and then of course like
we could just make it so that when they
leak out or whatever
when they hit the floor or hit a trigger
or if they leave this trigger even then
yeah maybe we could be like it's gone
therefore you lose
oh one's all the way over there
oh no that's not that's my blood
particle
um but yeah that's pretty dope
I don't know what you're talking about
this is great this is great coffee look
at it
yeah that's fantastic
oh One's On The Edge and I think it
looks kind of nice
I would love to disable Shadows for it
but the AR looks great
um yeah
thank you no disabled there oh SSR
shiny coffee I'll disable AO for a bit
just to see what how garbage this will
look oh beautiful
air off air on oh God that's terrible
yeah that's pretty bad
um yeah wonderful
so that's like great now if we have a
have an actual so if the if we do
oh but that's coffee
um if we do have uh what's it called
um oh this has been simulated that's why
if we do have um
uh a mesh like if Tim makes a mug out of
this with thinner walls will that work
at all because that'll be there's a
different type of collider right as a
triangle Collider
well it might have both depending on it
might have a convex and a triangle but
we could just make it use only the
triangle as long as the Cup itself is
but like I mean it doesn't matter
because this cup like the thickness of
these walls is fine like yeah you know
what I mean like I feel like it would
almost be bad if it's any smaller from a
gameplay perspective like you're not
going to be able to
you know you're not going to be able to
see what on Earth is going on and stuff
but I guess like it would be really cool
to but how would that work like if I
like if I because obviously I want this
to be carried by the player
so therefore it how do I set how do I
set that up it's like I need a restraint
or something no oh God no actually yeah
the way we currently carry stuff is we
remove the rigid body and the Collider
because we do not have a like the way
you would do it
is with a fix
constraint
that's basically how you do parenting in
physics
we don't have that can't wait add that
easily
probably not
easily subjective
in theory I could add it
I mean this is the primary game mechanic
so this is as important as it gets
I'll take a quick look because I I
imagine joke probably just had an
example of how to use it
uh
because then we could just attach it to
like the player or even a bone the Tim
could make specific like a coffee bone
the Tim could make specifically
like in the Armature for this purpose
and then you'd have to kind of be
careful or even yo you know it would be
good he could still make a bone for this
but I feel like because you know how the
player has a very flat hat that's almost
perfect for a mug of coffee so that
would kind of be nice considering the
fact that when you're you know when
you're playing you're kind of you're in
this perspective so therefore like a
tiny cup here versus something sitting
on top of your head this might be a lot
easier to see how much coffee you have
left and all that stuff
I kind of like that idea
that's all I have to do
to get a fixed this right uh are you
showing me something
oh and Discord okay well that does seem
easy and it also looks like you've
already written it in our API
uh I didn't that's a jolt example huh
they also use ref that's simple right um
so
I guess that's what I'm doing first
thing when I get back
I could also I could also use this um
yeah that's not I think that's good um I
could also use this as an opportunity to
finally add some transparency to the
engine by making the mogby like
see-through
so that you can see the coffee inside it
that wouldn't be too difficult it would
just you know basically defer the
rendering until the very end
do we need to though
or the coffee well I don't know it might
just be a fun because because we don't
we we don't really have transparency at
all
and we've been wanting to add it forever
if we have time
yeah
I might do that
well it's just it's more so that like
this is just an excuse to finally get
into the engine properly you know but
yeah of course it will depend on time
but also like it might be nice to only
be able to look at the coffee like this
you know kind of like from above because
then it's kind of like
you don't really know how much is left
as uh
yeah I can say one I
think a big Arrow above the goal would
be good to indicate it
the goal um yeah well I mean gold being
like yeah
maybe it's just I'm planning to add fog
so
if because we kind of need to because at
the moment obviously the Horizon is
weird so fog would be kind of nice to
have
um but
yeah like I don't know
um
like my point is if the arrow is too far
away it's gonna be hard you could have
like a compass or like a hot element
that just says Hey the general is
somewhere that direction or you could
maybe like the c key could bring up a
compass temporarily just so you can kind
of see like instead of your gun you can
kind of see which way you're supposed to
do it's supposed to go and it's like a
Minecraft Compass it just kind of points
to the direction
yeah that could be cool
and and actually the compass is
something you could get like basically
the start of the game could be like
like you know private get here pour this
coffee take that Compass deliver it like
to the general go
um and that will all happen in that in
that kind of like coffee tent
yeah
um
yeah he will he will he's still out for
lunch but um because he wanted to hang
back but uh when he comes back he will
I think he'll he'll possibly start that
I think he's still kind of playing with
the the main character or something
something like that
yeah because he had to fix the animation
for it as well so you don't like
pause randomly yeah
uh also I I believe with xerox's
character controller like it can like if
you look on my screen I guess on the
stream or if it'll catch up but
um you can kind of see like the
uh
you know how high the um
terrain pieces are and I'm pretty sure
you can just automatically climb up on
that like as in it because it's about
that's just part of the character and
does that just work with normal
um mesh colliders like this
I mean the player isn't a mesh Collider
I'm talking about the terrain
well these are all individual entities
at the moment with their own mesh
colliders yes
that should be fine okay
um
I might want to look into
I've got to take a quick look at my
physics Mt Branch because I'm
almost certain that I had to fix some in
the Bible with star walking
in there although I actually maybe I
didn't because the fix was basically
updating jolt to 3.0 which we are on in
this Branch as well right
um
oh Xerox says it should just work
so that's good
that's great
and yeah jumping and stuff like that
like I don't know I might add that as
part of when I when I do the physics for
the terrain
yeah I might add some kind of stuff
basically
but like yeah I mean I also like I also
think that I'll and I as I said I'll
probably take a look at this tomorrow
but
um hey like the AI I guess like the I
don't know the enemies really need to
I feel like in order to make this game
good like enemies really have to be
this has to be something to them you
know
apparently they're pretty much just
re-skinned they're mindless yeah
which isn't great I tried to improve it
a bit by making them stop before they
crash into the player that didn't work
yeah
so yeah
um yeah it would be nice to have like
some slightly more intelligent AI
um
but I think
that's everything that I kind of wanted
to discuss cool and push my stuff now so
yeah I'll probably put a little bit
later
yeah but yeah go and get some rest
yeah
we'll see when I wake up
five six hours from now yeah
all right
all right well have a good stream and
I'll probably see you later yeah see you
later good night
good night
okay uh yeah
um
so we're gonna finish up
the kind of terrain stuff
uh
yeah so the chunk stuff is what I meant
uh we're gonna fish off the chunk stuff
so being able to actually load and
unload chunks that's what we're going to
do next
um but I'll I'm just gonna go grab some
more water I'll be back soon
[Music]
hear you and I
tonight
[Music]
foreign
thank you
all right I'm back
Okay so
dislike system that we have here with
the chunks
how do we know if it's time for us to
load on the chunk and is this like the
correct chunk coordinate um well it's
obviously not the gray trunk coordinate
because it's negative and it can't be
negative so what I would like to do is I
would like to find out basically
and I would like to have a way to find
out
um thank you Dom for the bless you
um I would like to have a way to find
out
like which actual chunk we're on right
because at the moment it's kind of like
this is what we're doing but that's
clearly not really correct because
uh
um the chunk so we have these chunks
oh but that's what this is supposed to
be
yeah so there's two types of chunks
there's a chunk within this
but then there's also a chunk
within the world
and actually you know I I believe that
might be correct
because we have this many chunks right
we start from here
this
uh
let's create Chuck markers
um
when do we we create them so set chunk
so this is like
let's just quickly put a breakpoint here
so we're asking for minus one minus one
that's the chunk
uh and the trunk index is yeah that's
irrelevant
so this is kind of oh but this is yeah
so two
two two
ah this I hate this world centered
around the origin thing man it's like
messing me up
we honestly don't even need it though
that's the thing like if we had a huge
world like Minecraft we would
because of like floating Point Precision
but
even then like I don't know
maybe I should just cut that out because
then we have to do all the all these
weird offsets you know
valid really
so where does this come from so it's
coming from us basically being like
let's we need to create nine chunks and
let's start around the middle
of the world so therefore
let's go from chunk index minus one two
one
so that's where that's where we
currently are
maybe this should just be plus equals
then
wait I don't think we need to do this
actually
I feel like that's already good we don't
have to do that because the chunk the
chunk is already basically centered I
think
so
no well that's not right because what
should happen guys is generally speaking
where we spawn at the moment
which we're only Sport and we're just
there like we are basically at the world
origin so this should say zero zero
so yeah so what it looks like is it's
almost like I have to add that back in
and then I'll get what I want
right
I need to stop that from happening as
well
but then that's three three
wait
oh and no well yeah zero zero why didn't
I get zero zero before when I commented
it out that's a bit weird isn't it
but this I think this is now correct
and so when I leave this boundary I go
from zero to
it was in this case negative but
you can see like I now know where I am
so let's make this uh
get player
chunk index
so we'll keep the debug text that for
now which is this yeah
so now we need to potentially trigger a
lard basically
so we I think we should basically do
this I don't know my I don't know if
this is a good idea but my idea is
basically like
uh we so we need to know what chunks we
currently have loaded right so I think
it probably makes sense for chunks to
have
like some kind of uh chunk to be aware
basically of
like their chunking decks in a way
right so
yeah
when we actually create the chunk
which I don't the initial chance that
that doesn't matter but when we do I
guess
it's not generate chunk it's like set
chunk I think
when we actually do like the set chunk
um
yeah so this is the chunk
I think we should basically be like all
right the chunks
chunk index
uh
is going to be
this right
I think
again
um let's just
uh
I don't attach the debugger
okay
two two
three there so that's not right
oh that's the sample X this is the
sample X
sorry this is actually the wrong one
um yeah
I should name it something else or at
least how to comment
s
it's a sample
um but I think
I don't know this is for sampling oh but
then it gets multiplied by chunk size
yeah but that's still for that
uh
so is it just this I think it's just
that I think it's just this
would make sense because c's for chunk
oh you stupid mono are always crashing
man
I want to just make sure that's correct
right
debugger is why it crashed before as
well
um so if we look at chunks
zero zero yep okay so that looks correct
so now they line up each chunk knows
where it's at so my plan now is uh
basically just two
um like as we move
uh
uh we'll do we'll write a function
called process chunks
and
we'll get the player chunk
and so we know that like the correct
chunks like we know we want to determine
whether or not we need to load or unload
any chunks that's what we do basically
so the way we do that is we have to go
through all the chunks we have
right
um or actually we could even just say
let's go through all of the chunks
that
are around the player chunk
said
right so we're gonna go through these
no there's a much easier way to do this
isn't there
um I think we can just do basically if
if chunks
um
zero
dot chunk index
doesn't equal
player chunk
dot x minus well I'll play a chunk minus
Maybe
can we do that
because they're back twos right yeah
so either either needs load unload or
out of bounds
yeah that crash happens every time you
use the debugger and then when you
reload the assembly
okay so we're at zero zero
yeah and we don't need to load anything
because you can see the log is empty
then if I move into a different chunk
you can see we need a load
and it stops and it needs a load
um and so the idea is
if it needs load then we uh let's make
another function
very lots of functions today
usually I like talking with everything
in one function but I'm actually making
functions for everything now because
it's so I need to be very careful here
um
load chunks around player and we might
as well
or even around the index we can say
and this basically will do this right
um except in this case it's obviously
uh
there needs to be an offset yeah so the
index is the offset so we can just do
that
I think
all right
no
oh that's a Polaris
probably shouldn't be yeah this we
really should be using do we have a
vector 2i and I don't think we do
yeah we probably shouldn't be using uh
floats here
well you know what always a first time
let's add a vector 2i
actually we can probably just copy all
of this just make a 2i
yeah can we just replace float with INT
in this file
and Vector 2 with vector 2i
yeah all the ants worked
yeah why did that not work can I do that
please there you go
realize it's just annoying
uh we won't make that we won't do those
things
clamp needs to be done with an ant
okay whatever good enough I don't know
if this is needed there's a normalizing
and
stuff this is mostly for just
storing two numbers really okay
so 2i 2i
chunk indexes annoying as well
okay nice
uh yeah it doesn't need flooring anymore
and
but we do need to actually process these
those floats
wait what
uh
In Their audience cool
so we're doing integer comparisons
rather than slow comparisons here which
is important
um but we do need load and then yes that
which that's already
an INT which is good
all right so yeah so load chunks around
index uh so we can just be like yeah you
know what let's do uh we need to check
the bat that we needed the bounce check
um but we can kind of just be like play
a chunk please
basically
um and that will load them around there
because it's doing the minus one
uh okay so that's great I think um the
one thing I'm concerned about is the
outer bounds so how do we know the
bounds first of all
um
I guess we have map width chunks
right so as far as the chunk index goes
I think it can't be less than
so
check bounds so if
uh
well actually shouldn't load chunks
around index do that
maybe we don't have to check the balance
like it should probably do that here
right
uh yeah and otherwise I guess it but it
will probably keep triggering it that's
the problem
yeah
I think Checker bounce
uh if
can load
if chunk
bound check
I think I'll do it this way
so basically what this will do
is it'll just check everything around it
so four ants Z equals minus one is that
is less than equal to one
uh Z Plus
actually
let's just do index dot y minus one how
about we do that because that way we
don't have to do any offsetting later
wait why am I doing this in a for Loop
like a clown
all I need to do is
all I have to do is check to see if this
guy
uh if I try and go that if that's less
than chunk
map width chunks
divided by
sure
minus that
I think that means it's invalid
uh and then we'll
we'll do the greater than check as well
I think that should be okay
I don't know there's probably a minus
one that needs to happen somewhere
because what's the minimum we can have
here yeah so it's minus three to three
because there is a thing
so that's going to be
minus seven divided two which is three
and
two minus three if that's less than
three oh no maybe that will work
greater than three yeah yeah no I think
that's fine actually I don't think we
needed an equals two I might be wrong
but I guess we'll find out
full loop
okay so let's try this out I'm kind of
interested to see what will happen
so
apparently nothing
oh no it's working let's just stop it
seems weird
and what's this
is that the Playa chunk index
because that's really weird
ah I forgot to do this
did you guys watch me ride that typo
change the condition
yeah zero zero
oh I'm still zero zero though that's
wrong
um zero zero anymore
okay well that worked so see how that
disappeared and that shifted
let me keep going
so that's good
that's obviously working uh
no no that's also working
was it not working before
look
this is weird
oh it's weird for negative
ah hold your horses
no way
you'll check your load of false not
intro what
I'm pretty sure this is correct
yeah and this also seems like it should
be correct
yeah but
that's weird that's not because look
it's like it crosses here but this is
wrong
because we should have a negative one
present
but we don't it's like it's working but
it's not
ah no it's because it thinks we're still
at zero but we're not C
so this boundary doesn't work for some
reason
uh and that that's actually uh oh yes no
no it's because I changed this to this
should be mouth floor
that's important because the negative
value
uh floor to end I think
because what will happen is uh if it's
0.1 then it becomes zero if you cast it
to an end so that's correct but if it's
negative 0.1 it also becomes zero but we
want negative 0.1 to become negative one
so we need to floor it
that's why
yeah so now we're going to negative one
and I think all the chunks are working
perfectly now
which is great
the colors are changing
um
uh oh and also it's resetting all of
them which is unnecessary but the colors
are changing because we don't store the
colors we actually regenerate the colors
um I think wait
do we we actually we shouldn't
regenerate the color should we
the height of the correct though
but the colors get instantiated once oh
no no it's because we move the tiles
around that's why yeah
I don't know if I'll Cape that system
this is a bit wasteful because it
actually reloads all of the tiles
but what's cool about this I believe is
that we should basically be able to make
this pretty much infinite for one I mean
we generate the level up front but if we
go to
like map width chunks
like we could probably make this like
70. that's what
and it'll take a while to generate the
world I guess but uh and I have a lot of
debug markers let's not do the debug
markers
we don't need them anymore
that's much faster uh and yeah I mean I
should be able to keep going like
forever this is like Minecraft now
yeah and you can see I'm good
it's just going to keep generating the
world
and it's not it looks like it's almost
changing it it's not actually changing
it
it's just that um
we don't have a way to set the color yet
we should probably set the color on the
material I guess
but that's also a bit weird at the
moment because the material is shared by
all of them they don't have their own
material
which is okay but it just kind of means
that it's tough yeah I don't know how
I'm gonna actually do that
because I'd like to
set the material but it's just that
yeah that is I'm not sure I'm gonna do
that
because I don't want to actually
instantiate the prefabs but if they're
different tiles they kind of need to be
that's the problem
I'd rather rather like you reuse them
kind of from a pool but again ideally
they wouldn't even be entities it's just
that
it's easier to make them entities
um yeah and then we just kind of add
some fog so that we don't see the end
uh and that's kind of it
and obviously like the terrain is kind
of
the same
so it'd be nice to change it up a little
because it's kind of boring but you know
we can also go into like level generator
and uh you know make it more ravenous or
whatever
a little bit steeper maybe so this is
kind of steeper I think
but we could also beef up the amplitude
if we wanted to and there's a lot of
stuff we could do obviously this is kind
of a good steepness I think 0.8 0.08
if I was really Pro I'd actually unload
chunks behind you
because you can't see them obviously
to kind of load them in
how long does it take to do that
let's see
um
load chunks around index
probably very fast well I don't actually
know it could be up to like a
millisecond Maybe
it says two is that two milliseconds
that is kind of slow isn't it
can I do two strings
no
but that's a that's a double
2.3 milliseconds
kind of slow
I guess because we're setting so many
transforms
the map is the noise values for the map
are generated once
at the very beginning
but the obviously like the positions are
reset
the positions of chunks and all these
hexagons are set as we need them
basically
okay now these are all physics things as
well I believe
so what that means is I should be able
to
now that I have this set up
like what do we need for this really
um we just need
the level generator script which is this
so it needs to play up the blood
particles normally used
and the chunk Mark is an irrelevant
underneath the hexagons obviously
and it needs these parameters right so
if we hop on into uh Peter's world
which is I think the root motion right
then yeah nice okay
uh well actually I need to pull Peter's
stuff I haven't pulled it yet
okay lots of stuff has changed
hopefully nothing too major
I need to do some merging
uh this should all be Peters
and asset registry
I understand why it doesn't just
autoimage this
and then also I need to pull engine
some character control issues were fixed
this is an app called Fork
which is uh my favorite git client
by far
okay I need to rebuild that
we're on primac
favorites
oh okay so
great I broke the asset registry uh
that's all right there I should be able
to fix it pretty easily
where is it
it's here
oh that's one of the problems anyway
no it's in a few it's all the scripts
basically typescript file is missing
from a few places
okay so let's say line
uh 21 needs that
line what was the other one that needed
it
one two four
is that it
meow
there's my sense to work yes
oh no it doesn't actually I need to
build the script or something I think I
did build the scripts uh and it broke
everything as usual
um
well actually that looks correct
why can't I move
weird but I don't care because we're
gonna we're abandoning that scene
basically that was just to test in and
we're moving on to this scene which
hopefully works yeah it does there's
just no uh the terrain generation ah
because that used to use my code Maybe
but I can kind of move here
and fall off somehow all right so this
actually uses the level generator which
is cool it has these uh player should be
where's the Real Player his name is
player so that's what should happen
he should be around the origin which he
basically is
uh chunk marker
we need that just in case it'll crash
uh sure I don't really care let's try
that
all right
um so we're inside the physics
which is not great
um
what if we just drag ourselves up
yeah well we're not falling those cubes
seem to work but this guy
why is that so weird it's like it's not
it's like it's offset or something
like what's going on man
the physics seems really weird
like it doesn't look like it's on the
level
uh now that being said though uh I
remember there is this weird there was
this weird
no but it's not here anymore the plane
and what's this this looks suspicious oh
that's the coffee cup
so why
is
those cubes seem to work properly I
guess
but the player doesn't
shooting at me
like this is really weird
it kind of looks like it's just like
offset somehow
I don't know how that's possible
but also this is weird like this isn't
rotating the player
camera I mean
um let's maybe delete player too I don't
trust player two
ah so weird man okay now I'm getting
another of his exceptions
uh we're from
level generator on update ah
really
253 because that's supposed to be
reading the player I think
ah the player needs a rigid body
wait this is rubbish what is this
I don't think this needs to this should
not exist anymore
and really this shouldn't either but
start with this
okay still errors
238 now
oh this rubbish yeah
okay no errors
but yeah same situation
but it does that kind of looks like he's
walking on the level you just can't get
back up
um and that should be because there
should be a character should be a slope
limit of zero
one is probably too much but
you can be able to get up now I can't
the buffoon can't get up
oh but it's a step limit on a slope of
all right
step offset is offset
the what that is basically
yeah it is okay beautiful so now we can
actually walk up the slope and yeah that
looks good
right don't worry about the colors
changing
I can't uh aim it I can't like walk
backwards to name that way though which
is
a little pit
challenging
it'd be cool if the completely useless
but it'd be cool if you had a flashlight
just for the sake of
hey look here's a point lad with Point
Light Shadows
this is the problem when game engine
Developers
make games they uh
they just make they drive
like
they make features just to show off
engine like engine they make gameplay
features to show off engine features
I have no idea which way this is a
spotlight's supposed to be
and for some reason
I can't select it anymore what
that's really really weird
let's reset the rotation
I thought it was just that way
doesn't it Point down by default
which way is it pointing
that way no
this way
okay so if we rotate it 90 degrees
then
but look at this this is so weird
yeah that's because it didn't rotate 90
degrees
okay
think I'm getting somewhere
so now if my gun
has this guy
I have some nice
so nice I have a nice spotlight
I can shoot this guy so I'm out of ammo
but I can pick up
this reminds me a forest
in a bad way
wait my flashlight's gone oh that's
because I picked up a gun
and this one doesn't have a flashlight
that's funny all right whatever I'll
leave that in for now
all right
um
well yeah I mean that's so let's go to
double generator and make this a bit
over the point zero eight or something
was a good value right
so let's see how this works because this
is pretty steep but I did make it so
that I can climb
on this steepness as well as you can see
so now I'm kind of like
this is kind of cold but this this is
definitely too steep I shouldn't be able
to climb
that's too steep to climb
um
so yeah you can see that's too much
but I can climb these like smallest
slopes but that's too much so I really
need like a jump I've still got that
blood effect that's funny
those blood particles
um
Whoa man
yep that's physics for you great
good work jolt
my flashlight's backwards why
[Laughter]
some garbage
yeah it's kind of nice maybe to not jump
because that way you have to be
strategic about where you go
no I'm kidding it's Scottish um all
right so
what I really want to be able to do now
is I need to be able to set materials
yeah
so I need to be able to
um
and I don't know if I can this might
require an engine feature maybe it
doesn't though
I have a feeling it might though
um
what I kind of need to do is I need to
have my materials right so
I have my hexagons I need to have my
materials
uh but I don't know if this will work
like I have a feeling it does
but it's okay I can get it to work
easily
ah
oh my gosh it might actually work
Color Me impressed if it works
which I'm not quite sure yet so I
basically here are my materials right I
have four of them they're here and the
idea is I can now it doesn't now doesn't
matter which hexagon I have I could just
have one hexagon prefab and I can apply
one of these to the material in that
chunk to that pre to that entity in that
chunk basically programmatically
hopefully
so let's save that
um let's try it so
let's try and make so set chunk
or not said chunk right oh no I just
said chunk right so if I do basically I
guess it would be tile.static tile.get
component static mesh component
dot material
ah see it no material what
there's no way to set the material
I thought I thought that was a thing
oh do you have to do it to the static
mesh
now you can always get the material
you don't seem to be able to set them
into set the material
which is fine that's um easy to add
I guess we'll have to add it though
but this like let me just make sure this
works though
and the way I'm going to make sure it
worked
I just wanted to say make sure that the
editor can actually set it up properly
so what I might do is I'll do four and I
equals zero eyes less than materials
uh
length I plus plus
and I might just print out the
materials I
Dot
sure let's print the color
and that Oaks yeah I mean those are
values that's red
uh that's orange that's green and that's
blue
so
that did in fact work
amazing
okay so let's add the material setting
situation let me just save Hazel so I
can close it
um so the way that's gonna work is let's
go to script glue this will be easy
because obviously the C plus supports
they're just not the C sharp so static
mesh component
uh we'll we have get material
um
so let's just copy that
call it set material
and this is going to get the material at
the index and it's just going to
uh if that's valid obviously it's going
to do
material set material uh to in handle
at the index
let's do that
make sure it's not zero maybe but
whatever
oh this is if it's out of range
uh yes
that's true
that
yeah that's it
so we obviously have to uh just add that
into here so that's easy as well done
um
but also I guess in the header
this can just be um
I don't know that can be that doesn't
have that shouldn't be a pointer
it needs to be here because we're
writing to it but here it's just a
64-bit hint so uh and now we're going to
this script which we can do here
the um
internal calls situation we find the one
that's like uh get material on the
static mesh component
there it is
we duplicate that set material void
I'm gonna make it match this uh this can
just be
so while we do pass it in here I don't
know why we do that
let's just make it a year long
so you long it'll be implicitly cast to
the right type
uh and that's done um so now we just
need to make sure that static mesh
components
which is in components
so we have get material and then we'll
have a public void
set material int index
I guess we can make sure that it has but
has material
does that just validate the index or
I don't know
but anyway either way let's just
basically do internal calls set material
and then this is going to be material
we need the actual uh
handle
uh well we'll get the material
and then material dot like handle
Dot
what is this
may have no way to get the actual handle
are you joking
why is this uh this should probably be
internal
yeah it doesn't look like that's funny
um that should be okay right
ah but it's an SM handle
right
no no oh hang on it's
material.handle.m handle
okay
done that's it I think that's it
um so what that means is basically back
in
our game
when I do this I can get a mesh
component and I can be like set material
which is not going to set on the match
it's going to set it on the mesh
component which is different uh index
zero let's set it to okay so let's just
try and set all of it to like materials
zero
so that'll make make it all blue
basically
see if that works
[Music]
exception probably the materials on set
because sometimes they break
that should be enough
that's the function I just added
I mean that's just a 64-bit hint so I
don't see why that wouldn't work
isn't that weird that should have worked
uh fine let's try let's do a debug build
because I don't know why that
[Music]
foreign
debug though but I'm guessing it will
still it's gonna crash now
but then I'll be able to debug it I
wonder what's wrong
I mean it was clearly able to get the
material so that clearly worked so why I
wouldn't be able to get the handle and
why is the handle not just
easily converted it should be
zerox dad
um the material table no no oh well the
material handle it's unable to repeat
memory
but why
so this isn't being passed correctly
that's so strange well whatever I don't
have time to deal with it now but
uh we'll just pass it I guess by um like
as a pointer but
like we obviously shouldn't have like I
don't know we should I don't think we
should have to
or maybe because it's reading it as this
is it's trying to it's not like a triple
type maybe it should be a uint
64t if I do that let's maybe try that
just because that's less code to change
um and it's the same thing
let's try that
am I sleepy a little bit I got up kind
of early today
um but
a little tired but I'll come alive later
what we're working on here
um terrain generation
we basically got it working I'm just
trying to set the materials up
so that we get prettier things
I'm running a debug build that's why
things are slow
because I'm trying to add
a function to the engine and
something wasn't working so this will
probably work there right
I think it's already whacked because
yeah I mean debug builds am I right
yeah that looks blue beautiful
all right so let's restart this in
release mode yeah I don't know I guess
if you set it to
an asset handle even though the memory
is identical it maybe mono is like oh
that's not a trivial type or whatever
so I'm gonna do some conversion well I'm
gonna do something weird with it like
take its memory address instead of it
maybe I don't know I'm guessing no this
is release mode
so much faster oh this is the wrong
scene as well um
that's why it was null at that point
that's funny uh where's
he has Peters is the actual Saiyan
uh
yeah I mean you can see that it's
they're all blue now
so that's clearly working now which is
good
um
so
let's look at
yeah so the idea is and the reason why I
did this is because now now
now we can be cool with it we can be
like um
uh what we can do we delete this no
that's my beautiful island code that I
need to keep for for real
um so yeah so now we can be cool with it
in the sense that we can uh get a
material based on like whatever we want
really so for starters I could just look
at like the Y translation and be like if
it's below zero that's water so let's
kind of either flatten it out into water
or you make it like
um
uh or or you we can still kind of I was
gonna flatten it and we'll talk about
that later because water's typically
flat but we'll uh yeah we'll talk about
that later
um so let's grab this
uh else
let's just set it randomly now so
uh
I don't know if that's all I don't know
if that's I don't think it was inclusive
and if it is I guess a little crash or
just a C sharp exception uh they all set
yes and blue is the first one
yeah cool so now you can see that all
the negative ones
all the all the negative people who
don't like live they're all blue now
um
which is cool
it's like my flashlight
um
but what we could have could have also
done is easily kind of creative water in
the sense that like we could have just
been like
uh not only do I want to set it to Blue
but let's actually set the translation
to zero and then that's just going to
make those areas flat yeah definitely
you can see how well that works
oh because I already said it
yeah so this is pretty cool now because
it looks like we have pools of water
hey Tim check this out
we got like
we've got a lot of stuff actually we've
got pools of water wow they're kind of
flat and then we also got
um like the animation and you can see
he's walking on the terrain and he can
actually there's a slope there's a limit
that's configurable to how big of a slow
pick and climb that's the character
controller yeah yeah
it's like it can climb little like
slopes like this
uh and oh and infinite terrain
generation basically so like we could
keep going forever the colors change
just because they're kind of randomly
generated yeah but
um
yeah we can I kind of like the team
I don't know it's just kind of a it's
like low poly but because of the little
like AO between them and you know all of
that kind of stuff and the cut and the
lighting oh and I added a little uh
Shadow costing spotlight
to just make it look kind of cool to the
gun yeah
and then obviously this still works I
think they bleed
what's it called I'd be just curious I
can bleed by pressing space space to
bleed oh that's cool you can almost
leave a little grenade behind you
because see I'm leaving these guys
laggy
nah it looks pretty cool no you can't
jump at the moment but I'll oh you
should jump and it should do a flip
procedurally
but yeah
but anyway that's pretty dope I mean I'm
in the water now
there's a lot of water
but also I mean the water at the moment
isn't shiny but I could make it like
reflective obviously what's it called
I'm gonna push the water texture because
I was done
you want to see what it looks like who
is doing this
where is that coming from
yeah
sorry
what do you guys think of the game
yeah well good thing is guys you can see
everything that I've done on stream and
it's even rewindable because it's on
YouTube so
if you missed it just look back
yes
yes I'm on low
so I should be 1440p unless I'm asked
something up
I'm just gonna make a predictable thing
quickly mostly for debugging uh as far
as um
[Music]
like tiles go just because at the moment
the colors are random and it kind of
it's hard to see if it's actually
working properly
uh because obviously every time you
every time you go through a different
chunk it changes the colors
so I'm just gonna make it a little bit
more predictable here
like like so
I don't know if those ranges are right
yeah I guess they're not bad
they're a little bit it's mostly red
though
so maybe let's make this point five and
one
so now they're kind of more height based
as you can see but also I feel like we
could play with it now that we kind of
are capping zero we could just make this
a bit
bigger
yeah then we'll get some more
yeah it's still it's kind of annoying
because it does fly it seems to like
flash for a frame when it changes the
chunk well that's really weird
I don't quite know why that's happening
it's not smooth like it's yeah it
flashes why
I need to like see what the heck's going
on there
because it's
oh but it's I'm actually almost
surprised that's working because it
literally shifts oh because but it's all
within a frame so I guess that's why
oh it's still printing something
a lot a lot let's login for
yeah I need to see what's up with that
I can just hide that
well we have features in this engine
so what's that warning there
where's that at it actually says the
stock trace for warnings uh load chunks
around the index I'm printing that oh
that's that's how long it took three
milliseconds yeah it's kind of long man
that's four milliseconds pretty much
look like to be completely honest like
this way of doing things is garbage
um like each one of these hexagons is an
entity with a with its own rigid body
and its own mesh collider like I'm
almost amazed this is actually working
this quickly
um but it's a game jam and for
prototyping this is really all you need
you know
but yes like it would be nicer to maybe
not have that now I I kind of want to
smooth it out a little bit because I
know I'm arbitrarily multiplying three
somewhere yeah here it is if I just do
one yeah that's gonna make it much
flatter I think maybe not ah or was that
not in uh that might have been the wrong
yeah there it is three
this should make it much flatter
yeah so see that's flat out but now I
can boost
this guy
by three
uh and that will just give me or is that
just gonna give me more variance like in
a bad way like what if I make it one
oh
ounce garbage
I'm just not reaching the like the
amplitude just looks way worse okay
let's go back to like point one maybe
what if I boost the gain does that do
anything no
um all right
so that times three was actually kind of
cool
maybe we should even boost it more
I mean that looks kind of cool right
and if I do that but then also because
that could be like I could multiply it
with different areas or whatever so it's
yeah
but
like if I make that smoother
whoa
now that is smooth
I called her it almost looks like the
shore
um that's way too smooth though
that's kind of cool and then you got
kind of like Islands
but like yeah I mean there's probably
too much water
now if we wanted less water by the way
especially because it's good it's an
island so it's going to be around there
we could
just
add a little bit to it
so it could be like translation.y plus
equals like I don't know 0.5 or
something
and that's going to obviously lift
everything and we should get less water
um
let's try like 1.5 that's probably too
much
I mean we're still getting a lot of
water
huh
yeah okay so we kind of have less water
now and obviously more height
I kind of want to love to know how tall
some of these things are
um
maybe that's too much
less than two times plus two
um and what else was I gonna do
oh yeah I wanted to well this isn't a
big deal but I kind of wanted to
make these colors a little bit more so
spread out
yeah
so this is a little bit of a smoother
terrain which I don't know if I love
that because it was kind of cool before
and let's quickly especially now for
debugging for the player let's just make
the uh
stamp offset at least 0.5 so that we can
actually climb up on these mountains a
bit better
yeah it's really bad that you can't aim
backwards
like and then when you're walking
backwards it actually killed someone
and this guy doesn't have a spotlight
it's kind of cool actually it's tough to
fight them off man this is kind of cool
I really like the synthetic as well
there's something cool about it
oh and we could this is actually like
there's no reason why
man why this can't be um
complete like a day night cycle
yeah I did want to add jumping
and I kind of wanted to have better
level Jen but
this is just you get what you get
but you need jumping because otherwise
like
what is that oh that's my little piece
kind of shoot them backwards
run away I used to be much faster than
them I feel like I'm slower than them
now
the mountain slow them down a little bit
but really not that much
oh they're kind of shooting themselves
oh that that's right they shoot me
that's what all those green arrows are
shots fired I'm definitely dead by now
nope and sometimes the physics glitches
out
hi friends
come and get me
yeah swap orange and green around yeah
the colors aren't then definitely not
temporary
um but sure
there you go there's your sand
it looks pretty cool like I don't know I
like this and especially like that's the
other thing right so the blue material
uh is uh I could make that shiny because
it's not at the moment
uh and I mean I don't know if that would
be necessarily correct but you can see
it's kind of reflecting the environment
map and I mean technically if I turn on
um I don't know how cool this will look
but if I turn on uh screen space
Reflections then wow
nah that's kind of dope though man
that actually looks kind of sick
oh and that's halfres
this is full res
that is pretty cool
and now if I just made them wave a
little bit man
Tim check check this out
this actually looks sick
so I've got water and I turned on screen
space Reflections and so now you can
actually see like
stuff reflected in it
so for me I have no roughness on a
texture well mint no you can have a bit
of roughness it depends it'll blow the
reflection a bit if it's rough
and uh specular or specularism
speculates just how much light is
actually affected well specular is not a
parameter what do you mean well
like this is specular word
this is specular reflection yeah but
that's because of the roughness and like
I guess then them if it's the metal or
not it'll react differently actually
what if we make the water metal because
I guess technically that might be a good
thing
because at the moment it's dielectric
but if we make it matter it'll be a lot
darker yeah
that's pretty cool look at that it's
like a full honest reflection now
kind of wish the uh chunks were a bit we
could make the chunks bigger or have
more of them but I'm afraid like for
performance sakes because they're all
entities that's not a good thing
um
but yeah that looks pretty dope
and
it'd be cool if you could
move a little bit like on uh like as in
the water was like kind of like water
you kind of lose your blue color but if
it's reflecting the sky I guess it
looked kind of cool uh here's what I
wanted to do I also was wondering if I
because we're using a uh like an actual
um
environment map but if I just use like
you know something like this
I guess I'd want to match the
directional light as well
you know like what would that look like
I guess garbage
but see now I guess it does that look
like water
I'd make it I would add like a custom
little vertex Shader that just based on
the the position like you could just add
a little sine wave
and that would be kind of it
but that does not look as good does it I
mean I could make it darker because the
other thing is right
I did kind of want this to be at night
um and so if you
basically grab
this let's make it a little bit more
like night
uh
well there's some detail though
um and then what else we're gonna do
yeah like
if it truly was really dark
like I wonder if we made it like super
dark right
um so this is like really dark now uh
but we also have a directional on it so
let's make the directional light really
dark let's make the skylight
a bit brighter
so this is like really dark right
but what if we then
just
like what if we just add some point
lines
I'm just this is almost like just me
visualizing what it could look like you
know
I can't even know where to add these
that looks a bit weird
you're like a little lights I mean it's
cool because of the um
the flashlight I guess
and the lights could be like you know
street lights or houses or like
something like that because I'm
obviously gonna add some structures to
this Terrain
and also I think we should make the uh
yeah so those rubbish let me delete
these stupid point lines
everything is a bit brighter
I don't know did you guys like the
environment the HDR more I guess it
looked nicer well in my opinion anyway
because this isn't really night night
sky
with stars like the other one um but
what I was going to say was I think like
the green
the prefab the green material
like we can make that rougher basically
and then there was also like the red
tones were pretty rough weren't they
whoops
oh no they were the ones that were
reflective so if we go red and orange
and just make them
actually rough
and get rid of these stupid things
then now
yeah
now
was that the directional light
because that kind of looked like a point
light
I guess it is
yeah it is huh
so now nothing's reflective except for
really the water
no I don't know I liked that
that uh environment map a lot more I
think
okay you want me to take a look
sure let me just fix my Skyline
yeah having it be a bit wavy would be
really cool
um all right water texture right
I guess I should probably close Hazel oh
actually first let me make the
words
all right
also what is that is visible stuff what
was that for
eign
yeah that just hides it from rendering
yeah we had that since Forest I think
what well because I had to add it
because we needed a way to hide
something I've yes I'm pretty sure it
wasn't in iconic like I'm pretty sure it
was since Forest but you can always
check exposed
to the it was because otherwise I
wouldn't have I'm pretty sure it was
well it recently got moved to the
properties panel because like oh yeah I
didn't no no no I didn't um yeah I'm
pretty sure that Peter probably did that
like yesterday with me I don't know why
though but I've been using it
programmatically for the muzzle flash
because the muzzle flash spawns a
emissive mesh right well it doesn't
spawn it it shows it just for like one
frame
uh right I've pulled right
so that's it all you did was out of
material
yeah
so a static Mash yeah
right same yeah
what is this stupid Peter loves to log
man Peter committed so so much logging
that I have been searching for
log.infoorn in videos here just to get
rid of it
um all right so uh it's a mess here yeah
uh water tile
all right
okay so I mean I guess
should I just put it on your prefab just
to see what it looks like yeah
uh
it's not it's called Blue
yeah I could see it it needs some
adjusting I think
yeah
um
yeah like I guess the origin oh but the
origins in the same spot
so it's kind of problematic
yeah it is because in a way yeah I mean
this is probably better but yeah I've
been using that though
um all right that's fine uh so let's
change I guess we'll change the prefab
to be your water tile
and yeah let's just see what that does
yeah
how can we we could have said that of
course but
and it's a mesh color right
yeah is that even yeah
but that's using your materials I
changed the material that's fine oh that
sucks
okay
um so I guess I need to then
set
this to what null
I don't know if I can remove materials
actually
well I guess if I just don't set it
they'll all be water
because the thing is at the yeah maybe I
don't know if this will work actually
because I need to set the material to
set the color
so what do you mean for the
Bridge tile so that I can have I can
decide which color it is
um I need to set the material on it so I
don't just have a bunch of different
prefabs yeah but how do I uh what if I
need 50 water ones and one desert one
for that chunk
I can't instantiate suddenly 52 and then
the next chunk needs the opposite you
know so you need to be able to set them
on the fly without actually changing the
entity because I don't want to insta I
own the instantiate prepares at the very
beginning just for all the chunks but
then they just get reused so what you're
saying you want to eat no no I think no
I don't think I need it
um I think what I can do is because it
it creates them initially
and I'm pretty sure uh but it I think it
actually does some overriding though
because I'm pretty sure this persists
past play
with the way that it currently works
which is which means I guess it wouldn't
work um yeah I guess I don't need a
Hazel material okay so then I'll just
where's the texture for this
well it's embed oh it's embedded okay
I'll just push the textures I guess so
yeah it's just the albuter Shameless
yeah
this
is
I guess sir
yeah this like Direction changing
situation I don't really like it
I don't think the player should change
direction
I think he should just strife and like
move backwards
there's a lot of common Stout code
motion player all right so
where's the movement stuff what am I
looking for
oh no I want rotation
what I don't want is this I think
right
[Music]
but this is just a rotation change isn't
it
but look it doesn't move at all
so basically this rotation changes also
that's not just the rotation that must
be also
it's possible for
um
moving which is kind of annoying
but it doesn't look like it should be
because that does look like it's just
the rotation
so set rotation yeah
so weird
a less than different
place
doesn't like it
it's getting dark isn't it
the thing is though it's like this is
using a character controller for the
situation
so
I it might not actually be that simple
but I just don't know why
this
ah whatever maybe I can just get Peter
to do that
but I don't know I don't think it should
uh I'd like to be able to strafe
my directional lights very dim
probably too right
I should really have a little bit of
roughness in that blue material
no I don't think so
or does that make the specular highlight
too big on
um I turned off the uh
well I didn't turn it off where I
started
which means that the screen space
Reflections are off
so they are and they're probably half
for us
looks nice for the reflections
but yeah this one's probably directional
lights too big
let's pause uh
I guess I will just keep it on zero
because this gets very big
and then that the home with that is it's
not yeah and also metalness or not like
this will just keep it Bluer
I'm not gonna make it look more blue uh
but this will make it more reflective
although it kind of looks like the
reflection looks the same it just looks
darker like it reflects more of the sky
box that's for sure could even go uh
yeah this bug
but um that's probably like that's what
halfway through metalness or whatever
uh
Sarah's off no
no that looks kind of nice that water
but yeah if it was wavy it'd be nice and
also right now we can just walk on it
which is a bit weird
and that Shadows too
because the directional light is
so 0.2 was probably not bad for it and
is the direction light in the right
direction I think so
because we are here
is the shadow going that way
Spotlight as well which caused Shadows
but
maybe it is because that's like the
location of it that's roughly right
um yeah I don't know
okay so Tim wanted me to take a look at
Keys textures
the desert
uh-huh
actually well that's nice because yeah
because I can just probably take your
water
and just set it and there is a roughness
texture as well yeah oh I can't because
of the UV
no yeah you can't because you this
wasn't a UV on yeah yeah
because that would have been really nice
and easy
um but anyway I guess I'll still have to
do that and the roughness
yeah that's probably not shiny enough
change to gray overall you think
I don't know well because you need if
it's reflective it needs to be basically
like
well no this is black oh black um but
like so these parts will be very
reflective and this will be like very
mild
um but it's okay because I can multiply
it yeah so I can't reduce it
um okay so if I do that
and then so that's the hexagon blue I've
actually updated the material now
um so if I just replace the Assad
whoops
um yeah the offset's a bit weird I think
and an update the prefab
okay well
some of them look right
why some of them bigger though like
that's weird isn't it there's some of
them are like using the old previews
yeah
that's what it looks like
um
but no shouldn't be
where's my little generator
yeah so that's that's actually correct
so why are some of them
like like this
and it looks like it almost changed when
I
like which ones were up and which ones
yeah when I oh
look
wait yeah that's not the same
very slightly though
right well it's completely completely
um it just happens to be great
wait that's a bug with a chunks wow yeah
I guess so but how because it's so it
almost looks the same
but it's not quiet like it's in the
water's in the same spot
must be a little bug with the offsets or
something
because look see the water's also in the
same spot here but the levels are
slightly different
that's really weird
but yeah it's also really weird how
these are
let's maybe pause this
pause you can't look at it
so why are some of these using the wrong
I want this metal chunk
ah
no I don't know why it's him
it's because I'm not actually
um setting it
is because I'm not actually setting it
or and by setting it I mean uh
they should all be using
one of the assets so level generator at
the moment takes in these guys
um
and it instantiates them as if they are
different but where since we're
overriding the material this can really
all be instantiate
hexagons zero
basically I think
yep I can't fix the Tim like not the
chunk weirdness but your water your
water is in
um let me see if I can turn on
screen space Reflections I guess it's
okay you got the
the reflection
doesn't
oh that's why the heights were different
no they aren't they're not different
anymore
yeah it's because so it was the same
it's just the height was changing and
the height was changing was because it
it was randomly upon creating the level
there was a one in four chance that it
would select your slightly different
mesh that's why
or what now it's only using your mesh
but setting a different material or or
the other one which was shorter
that's why when you went out of chunks
it was kind of like because it assumes
all the hexagons are the same shape but
yours was different and so because of
that it would interchange it but it
would not look right because it was in
fact different right
I might need to fix the colliders
because I don't think I'm on the ground
ah yeah are you still using Square close
no
it actually probably should have should
work
because I shouldn't be like so the
hexagon blue is the only profile yeah I
think it's still using the old one then
but so what do I do I just press book
Force cook Mash or what I think so
because that's using your water tile
that should yeah so it's not gonna work
now
no I'm still above
and I can't wait
material too it's probably using the
incorrect one and a similar material on
London no no all of these now
all of these tiles are all hexagon blue
now uh and that's all of that's the only
mesh it ever uses is your water cell
mesh okay so the material as you can see
is in fact different depending on which
one it is uh
but the it's the same geometry that's
strange
um and I can't unfortunately look at the
mesh colliders because the mesh ones
don't show up only the Box colliders do
see so I don't know what
what what the collider looks like for it
but you do have 80 gigabytes worth of
control the replays yeah you should
probably have you shot it off
because you know in application settings
yes
Peter sabotaged us all in Project
settings in under physics you need to
make sure that capture on plays turned
off
otherwise because we have quite a big
level and lots of colliders apparently
foreign
and you probably want it to be always
like that right so you'll always only
use one mesh
um
say that again
you have one management and that just
gets added
adjustments
yes I used to have I started the whole
thing like ages ago when I was first
just making the grid I just made four
different because we didn't really have
a way to set meshes on the fly like this
so I had yeah materials on the fly so I
had four different prefabs with the same
mesh just the hexagon mesh but four
different materials like in the prefab
and then I just instantiated which one I
needed but the problem with that is that
I can't since I do all of the
instantiation up front and only for the
chunks that are visible
I can't
uh go in and then suddenly decide how
many of each I get you know so but but
with this system what I can do is just
if I just have one piece of geometry I
can obviously if I have four materials I
can set any material to that specific
geometry in that on that chunk and then
next chunk when I need the same entity
but a different material I can
programmatically change that whereas
before I couldn't
and of course if it's the prefab you
can't because basically what I have to
do is destroy the entity and instantiate
a new prefab and that's what I'm
avoiding
yeah
I think so yeah
yeah this kind of yeah it looks I think
it looks good what do you guys think
stream
do we have the exercise on
maybe just not in this scene but control
case what the other times it's a bit
hard to see because it's also went on
the ground
you can just
wow that's the limit unless I go to edit
a camera
and see a little bit more
this could be the trailer for the game
that is nothing like the game because
you can't actually look at it from this
angle but and let's see this runs it
because then I'm not on the ground
but it's pretty cool
the reflection's nice I think yeah
and I guess I could make that move but
that's such a like that's a distress
goal
just to make it brighter
I mean kind of looks like nuclear waste
oh I'm tinting it by the way
I was tenting it by Blue so that's what
you did
but this is tinted
what engine is this Hazel
which is at my engine
you have to let go
and do it too much
oh really that's not weird too many
times there's some weird memory issue
with serializing about 2
I don't know what it is
I don't know I just feel like
a little bit that's too much but I don't
know it just looks like it's weird
because it looks like wait why do all of
these guys have Point lines
look
how is the performance by the way uh
it's okay it's just these shouldn't be
individual entities there's no reason
functionally for them it's just I've
done it that way because it's quick and
easy and not custom but yeah actually I
kind of like the blue tint on it
and uh
yeah
I just don't think it looks like water
though
um all right I'm gonna be right back
stream
[Music]
foreign
all right I'm back
sorry guys I wasn't talking to you
that's why I didn't unmute the
microphone it's not all about you stream
oh this super collider situation I
forgot about this is where I left it off
um
yeah I need to uh
yeah so there's still this weird
flashing that happens which I don't like
um it's weird that it happens is it
possible
that it's doing something twice
because it shouldn't you do it all
within like three milliseconds in one
swift motion
right
basically
uh Hazel's pretty good I think
compared to last Jam better because I
last time I was adding half the engine I
was adding like asset packs and like the
multi-threading for the runtime kind of
finishing that up like I was basically I
spent two days working on Hazel because
I wanted to ship the game with a mate
with like a major new feature but today
I base like this this time around I
basically haven't done any work on Hazel
itself just adding minor feature
features here and there like as you
would just expect from normal Hazel
usage so
uh yeah pretty good not like I'm pretty
happy
now
um I want to get rid of Peter's logging
ah but I can just do that by clearing
this right
so yeah so the thing is it's clearly
doing it once so then why is there like
a weird
flash right there
I'd love to just like
screen record I guess let me do that let
me just record in uh
obs
I'll just record
which way is it I went the wrong way
recording
it was recording at 60 FPS
so if we watch that video
stupid MKV file a piece of garbage
and I can't change the format because
I'm live
why can't I open the MKV video I should
be able to
pot player
hey it's me
um all right so
how do I
dnf that's right
I don't know if I'll see it on the video
no that's perfect
captured it
you guys might not even oh it was
definitely that okay good you guys
definitely uh would have seen that oh
man oh look
it's the materials that's what's the
weight the weird thing is
the materials don't get set instantly or
something look
so this is
before the before the me going back this
is the first frame of oh but look they
get set before the movement because
forward is that's forward
so I'm trying to unload this chunk
but what but hang on
why but why does that happen though
that's so strange
hmm
is that always the case do we have
another yeah here's another one
yeah
what the heck
I think I might know why though
I think it's because like because
they're physics bodies
and the physics update happens before
the c-sharp update maybe it only sets
the it sets the but that's not what
happens either
oh maybe it is because they all get
reset right yeah yeah my theory is it
does the materials it should do the
materials of the next frame
kind of
or it should do this because because I
think what's happening is it's not
actually doing the translation instantly
as changing the materials first and then
the next frame it changes the
translation
and I I mean I think again I think
but let's take a look at that doesn't I
don't know if that makes sense though
but let's take a look at this
um if we go into translation and we just
look at what set does so it does
transform components set translation
and if we go into here
into the C plus plus then what that does
is if it has a rigid body component
which it will it will get the actor and
do act asset translation which will
actually set the jolt thing
but also it will mark it for
synchronization
so body is scheduled for sync right so
that's important because it's just
adjust that so it hasn't actually said
the transform in the transform component
maybe we can get it to do that though
why not set both right
maybe that's why because otherwise you
can see it just does that
why don't we just also do it here
because I get that it's going to be
synchronized but that way we get it
instantly
it's just that it's just that we're kind
of overruling the authority of the
physics engine if we do this
but we might need that let's just kind
of uh tentatively kind of keep that
there because now that we've marked the
bodies for synchronization let's see
where that synchronization actually
happens
so here it is pre-simulate yeah that's
going to be the next frame but you've
changed the material instantly so it's
definitely that
it's just we need to basically go
through and re-synchronize the bodies we
need to flush them that's the other
thing we could do we could just
re-synchronize the body transforms
yeah that'd probably be a better idea
than than circumventing
certain events
like from Arrested Development I just
remember that one episode of job doing
that
that was so funny
um instead of circumventing the physics
engine here
um let's just make set translation
because it's already marked for
synchronization
but I think let's just do the let's
actually do the synchronization would
that be wild
like it would be
um
I think I think what we should do maybe
if that's the case because especially if
it's static right but if that's the case
yeah
um
I'm surprised that Peter didn't separate
this out but whatever
that this is these are the explicit
um
synchronize
pending body transforms
we'll call it that
uh
um and then we'll basically why don't we
just basically
ask the physics scene to do that right
before rendering because if there's
nothing there it's not going to do
anything anywhere right
so
um right before rendering
so what does it do like uh the physics
stuff
inside on update I guess there
on
uh
no that's like rendering
there's a C sharp One update that
happens
yeah I think it's this function on
update runtime yeah that's it run time
is it not the Hazel runtime but the fact
that it's in play mode um yeah so you
can see that we do the physics thing
first right physics scene simulate so
let's also after this basically so
before we render and I guess before the
post update queue let's do synchronize
pending body transforms so I think this
will fix
that problem
but I'm not sure
foreign
okay so we're looking for that flashing
and it's I think it's gone
I don't see a flash anymore so I did it
yeah it's perfect now
excellent
great
okay that's good
because that was really annoying that
little Flash
um
that might have even fixed the camera
being weird
uh something that I had earlier in this
in like a previous stream or something
okay
I feel like shooting each other
so what's next uh jump like lots of I
can do a lot lots of player stuff
Mike is in jumping like stashing like
whatever
oh I was gonna add fog
let's quickly add fog
I don't think that'll be too difficult
and I'm probably just gonna copy the
forests fog but tweak it a bit because
like
why would I not do that um
is this Forester let's see I don't
remember where I have Forest
the Hazel version
Forest the forest Hazel version yeah
this is it
okay so if I go into shaders I should
just have this in the same composite
Shader basically
so this is the same compository from
forest and it does it do yes it does
defog well it's quite a lot of stuff
um all right let's so we'll copy this
basically
we're going to copy that into
here so let me just like
I don't know look off into the horizon
or something
pause and then we can uh
check it out
okay so basically
it was done
like this
and where was it done before bloom
uh but after that yeah I guess we can do
it here
so if true
fog
uh okay so what do we have the depth
texture we do now we need to linearize
it probably a transparent step I don't
think we need that though
linearized depth so we need that
function which we should probably have
in a header but
apparently
in Forest it was just here and I don't
know if we have it yet so I'm just going
to paste it in
that should work hopefully
fog amount fog amount bloom
no I don't know man we could just try
and compile this see what happens if it
fails it shouldn't crash the engine
but it will it'll say it in the log yeah
it failed all right
um does it say why
Bloom Undeclared identifier
do you know who I am
I'm the blue boy
it's him new studio name
balloon boy Studios
or balloon Boy Productions
I kind of like that
uh I don't know change the seat to a b
or to a BB
so why is Bloom undefined
I uh was driving like yesterday and I
drove past like this big billboard that
said like it was like some art festival
or something it was called like the art
of Bloom
and I'm like that's funny
yeah
uh that's why because I need this first
that makes sense
D Undeclared identifier
all right
what's that used for
nothing nice
yeah that's used for nothing
it's for nothing
oh no an actual Vulcan era
uh we're using set two now where we
weren't before ah because we're using
the camera now that's why I'm
um that's because I added like a new
input
so scene come so what is what is this
the composite pass
a composite yeah it's this one so this
basically now needs the camera which is
what's different about about it
I think
and am I compositing it yeah I am well
yeah because I'm doing color mix and
there's even a fog color parameter that
was nice enough to add drink for us so
it's nice
oh well look there it is there's the fog
it's working that's nice all right now
let's tweak it
let's do it
too okay so first of all like the color
but also I think we could probably get
that to be a little bit further away
um
fog start distance so let's try like
three
um
and there's like some fall off or
whatever right
I don't want it to almost be
what is that though what is the stupid
falloff distance
because what if I make that more than
that yeah so
I mean I guess that is just like how
quickly it falls off maybe
now is that good in terms of like we
can't see the chunks loading in yeah I
think it is that's kind of cool
um it'd be nice if we could just fade it
out to the Sky Box
uh I don't we can't really do that
though I don't think
like that's difficult we'd have to
basically reject those pixels
Oh either we sample from the Skybox for
the fog area
or we reject those pixels I guess we
could sample to the Skybox
or we reject those pixels no but that
would be weird
because then we'd be seeing through the
ground sometimes I think
um
okay but also we have a fog color
um so maybe like we could do something
that's not black
you know
um
not us quite quickly
oh I just didn't change it I think
yeah so now we can't see the chunks
loading and they just kind of look
as we can
yeah the chunks are just not very uh far
are they at the very edge we can see it
I could make them a bit bigger
but on the other hand like yeah
I don't know man
what if we do make the hexagons bigger
or is this a good size I I like the size
though
it's just the problem is again the way
we're doing it now with the stupid thing
is it's not gonna be good for
performance
so
that's why
I can rewrite this game later and make
it better
but for now
yeah I mean even this is not we can
still see it
so this is gonna be like Minecraft's uh
alpha or like whatever it's called
Minecraft in Dev with nearest fog
setting
like
I'm talking like this
oh that's kind of cool though it kind of
looks foggy
like actually looks foggy
now what I was thinking though because
at the moment it's just a flat color we
could add a little bit
a little bit of spice to it by making
this like slightly tinted red
that's probably too much
spice
or we could tint it blue or whatever but
the point is to make it look a bit
you know
probably should have put this stuff on
the other side of the screen so you guys
could actually see but
but I'm not that considerate am I cannot
actually move this as well
do you guys like that more
so yeah that's the fog
again I don't know could make it darker
no I don't like that
I feel like I'd even make it brighter
although that's a bit annoying
what if I go really bright
and like a bit orangey or something
maybe
so if we do that
yeah
or is that not lamb
on the other hand we could make a cold
so this is us making it warm right but
we could make it
cold
I guess cold looks better doesn't it
I just thought warm might be cool
because it's kind of like but this light
just suits this almost looks like the
sky color you know
whereas if it was
warm so warm would be that it just looks
a bit weird but I don't know it almost
looks like there's a fire though which
is kind of the point
so I don't know haven't decided yet I
know you could have like a crimson-ish
this guy thing that looks a bit you know
look at that flash as well every now and
then just to simulate like as if there's
gunfire or something
orange Dusty look
it's more yellow
yeah purple-ish
could yeah add some blue
that's too purple probably
uh kept doing the wrong thing
that's kind of purpley
I don't know I feel like my favorite so
far if I really had to choose
is probably this
but that just looks Bland though in a
way right
sampler
but it's also too bright
it's dialed this down quite a bit
maybe a bit because that looks like a
thunderstorm and I kind of like that
but yeah here it is with fog now
oh and Screen space Reflections are off
but if I turn them back on then I'll get
the water reflection
wait
I fixed the colliders
when the collided do you guys remember
what I did to fix the player not being
on the ground when I changed Tim's model
because I don't remember how I fixed
that
Tim come take a look at the vibe
that's sick
so I got Focus
all right let's add a bit
okay guys I'm gonna do a poll now we're
gonna decide so
this is what the water looks like
without Bloom which personally I think I
prefer
but the cool thing is you can't see the
chunks loading now because that was the
really primary
reason so this is what the world looks
like without Bloom right uh Tim likes
the water with bloom
which what was it what would you want me
to set it to like one where's my uh I
don't know if it's the blue material
all right so tinted blue
and then like one
no that's that's too much
is that is that a good amount
good enough to cry yeah see what I mean
though that there's it's that bug I
don't know why because that's a looks
very strange
yeah I usually have this up anyway so
it's a way yes
yeah I think that's pretty good all
right so this is uh I guess I'll take a
screenshot
well I guess I should show the whole
thing though which would mean turning on
screen space reflections
I don't know why they're off by default
to make them on by defalcon string I
always use them
at the moment okay so
let me restart it so we can see maybe
we'll get lucky and get more water
that's pretty good
all right pause all right so
this is
a
or like all labeled
I'm gonna go to paint
um
and please don't crash
[Laughter]
it's funny because you clear waste water
yeah
it's it's funny because it's like
literally
um
yeah
all right so these are the two options
uh
stream watch watch and listen carefully
I'm not gonna repeat myself
this is a
stupid brush size this is a this one
here which one do you prefer this water
color and brightness or this
and they're both like specular and stuff
I'm gonna do a poll so you guys don't
need to spam chat
but if you want to I guess you can
doesn't hurt anyone
A or B water
how are people saying
okay I've just started the poll
this is B this is a uh I'll try and
never mind
okay can you guys see that or is that
I probably should have just been normal
and stacked them vertically
but it's difficult to be normal
yeah B hey
B hey damn I guess because this is just
too dark and murky but I kind of like
that vibe
but doesn't this like it almost looks
more reflective like this Maybe I'm
Wrong
because you know what I mean if it's
dark
I don't think so really wow I think so
it's never caused a crash it might just
be slower but you can turn it off in
graphic settings
um
outside in there yeah
because it's kind of dark you know
you've got a light on and it's kind of
like why is this water glowing so you
guys who vote for age feel bad for
yourselves
at the 27 of you I'm not ending this
poll until
it changes tides
Jan just announced a streamathon or
whatever it's called right oh yeah
sabathon but it's uh holathon
all right and in a swift move it turns
out that what's this this is a all along
what did you see that coming this is how
the government operates basically in
every single country
that's all right I got you
I just think I got you oh my God this
has definitely not been tampered with
guys
wants to shoot the game that looks worse
sabotage guys this has not been tampered
it looks like a has won now everyone
else joining is gonna be like I'm voting
for B now
wait
um all right so I guess we're keeping
your
nuclear water
this looks nuclear water this looks like
it's actually waste it doesn't look like
it it looks like a loser yard like
puddles I need to make the um
okay so what was it point
s six point five right
president crash and this color exactly
exactly yeah
all right guys well you know what else
though you know what else some of you
might not realize
is do you know the downside of this
water is if you don't have Bloom on
ah it's still the same yeah that's right
because it doesn't reach Bloom levels of
emission emission just is plus equals in
the for the color as well that's funny
but if you make the threshold for Bloom
less
which wouldn't do in which you can't do
oh maybe you should though maybe maybe
guys maybe this
is how you make it look dreamy
look that's actually kind of cool isn't
that kind of cool but I also kind of
like your depressing aesthetical my
depressing aesthetic
and then you can just dial the intensity
down so it's kind of like a point
three but intensity is also lower
and then if you turn Bloom off it's a
completely different game but also Bloom
illuminates stuff in the distance
in the fog well I can change that but
the fog does that
well I was playing with that I kind of I
think I kind of like I really like this
I think I like this better than Forest
black yeah
I guess I should make the orange be like
sand it almost looks green it's a bit
blue
oh really yeah well I don't know
it wasn't a perfect flag because
yeah all right I guess I'll end the poll
so you know water at all that's funny
um Okay so
yeah I mean like with the fog
because I don't know I do sometimes
think it's kind of too bright and I
would prefer something darker but then I
don't know that doesn't look
you like that
but I don't know like what you had
before
could make it a bit more
purpley
yeah this is what I had before
it looks like daytime no Terminus you
know there should be a day it's hard to
tell well that that's the thing like you
can there's no reason why we can't do
that because this is like fully
well like as in we're using obviously
this is all Dynamic lighting so we could
just come in to like the directional
light and just play with like you know
with this basically and make it a day
nine cycle yeah but the fog getting
darker oh we'll also have that and then
have zero for example for night
so this is basically what night could
look like
you know this this is night yeah
with the water yeah I don't know why
that happens it's a spotlight but yeah
um so that's kind of like night
um why are these still reflective
these should not be reflective
anymore huh that's strange but yeah
that's your knight
um and then
too many enemies and then the oh you and
you could even I mean you could even be
cool if you wanted to and uh make like
the fog start distance at night be like
one or something so it's like really
hard harder to see and actually the way
you also can ramp it up is this if you
make this like small
Mike I mean
I mean a little extreme Maybe
but like you know you could do this or
something like this is really dark
this is a better horror game than forest
was and when you can't see anything it's
like is it are the enemies chasing me I
don't know
am I going to die
possibly There Is No Death By the way
yeah right
and then and then it's fine because
you've managed to survive the night
ignore that Moon
um you've managed to survive the night
and that means that to enable night mode
you quickly all tab to the Shader do
some changes
we're gonna shoot the game as a
directional light wait I don't know if
that intensity is a zero
oh that's what maybe those were Shadows
though yeah there's a maybe oh maybe I
don't know anyway and now it's daytime
angiolite is more neutral possibly even
a bit blue
and your fog is better
which is still foggy I have black whoops
my mistake
hey it's daytime
so yeah
day night cycle done
uh okay so I would like to also this is
also tough but I like to make this
yellow I think so it's like sand
basically Orange
is the superior I think
gold
so that doesn't crashed yet any minute
now I'm at better stop wait while you're
ahead material at all yeah oh because it
writes it to disk and then it reloads it
and somehow that causes a memory
corruption error and I don't know how
and we don't talk about it
um
by the way you wanted like voxel death
ah that that Old Chestnut no I don't
think we need that yep well uh for the
enemies we have one of them
well no no because the player can't die
I think I think what we've just what
we've determined is that player is just
gonna spill coffee which is some say
it's worse than death
as we're saying this game yeah
all right you know what I should do
really I should probably try and build
this for the run time
do we need a sound bank because there's
no sounds
build asset pack
please don't crash
excellent you can crash all right uh
we're gonna try and run this in the
runtime everyone because I should really
test that so that when it comes time to
ship this game
I uh don't end up not being able to
um
so
I think we can do this I think if we do
this
it should work for for now as long as I
tell it
the right project path to load
which is going to be so working
directory
project directory
but the command line arguments shall be
ld53.h project maybe this will work
whoops
please work
will the game have audio Yeah
it's there red like normal there is a
diary I think it's dare but uh I just
said that I didn't build a Shader pack
I forgot something
we don't really have a one-click build
and deploy situation we like to
like pain apparently uh I was gonna add
it before but you just have to press a
few buttons in the editor randomly and
then eventually if you're lucky
if it's your lucky day
then you might just get a game
we're making the Sir with her message
oh it can't find the answer pack uh and
that's also um my bad I think that's
because
we're actually manually trying to load
it
which we shouldn't not be doing but we
are so see this is the answer pack um
I think it's actually just an assets
asset pack though isn't it
but is that going to try and
I did this differently it was like
project get asset directory
slash asset pack that's what it should
be
I don't know why uh it's not because I
remember writing that code a while ago
oh and the scene it's gonna load is
wrong
but that didn't work
nope
yeah this is strange we I had this head
to something else
yeah because it hasn't set the actual
project yet what the heck
where did I write that I remember
writing code and it's not here anymore
that's sad
because basically right now we don't
know what this is unfortunately like
it's really difficult to do it this way
you basically have to do an absolute
path or a relative path for the actual
shipped version but I'm not I'm avoiding
copying engine assets by setting a
working directory that isn't the game
um but this doesn't work because it only
works after race oh but can't I just do
I've deserialized it
so can't I just do I think I could
that's not a static function though
I think I can get the config I think
that's how I did it
asset directory but it's not quite that
simple because you have to combine it
with the project directory
oh cool
I'll be sure to check that out
maybe this will work
why does the movement look jittery from
like a
an hour ago
um I don't know I don't think it like it
doesn't for me so it might be the Stream
it does drop some frames when there's
like a like a lot of enemies
uh
and in general like the performance
definitely needs some attention
I don't know if there's much I can do
about the performance because just the
general strategy for how I'm generating
the level is not ideal
that didn't work why not
so these are both empty
but how
what the heck
wait that's still wrong
maybe that's why this doesn't actually
Destroyer probably
oh because I'm overriding it
yeah no it's better
okay the scene is not that's fine that's
because I needed to load the right scene
so now we look at the asset registry
and we find our root motion or whatever
it's called scene
and we load that
what happened here
we have a
huh
that's not good news
that's a weird bug
make sure I don't have any exceptions
and stuff in a minute
[Music]
well this definitely works so
the fact that it doesn't in the runtime
is a little bit concerning
uh but it also might mean that
I need to add stuff to my asset pack so
maybe it means that I'm asset packing
again
which is upsetting
well it doesn't work
um and I have a suspicion
that maybe 0x added some animation stuff
to Hazel but didn't add it to the
runtime serialization format
uh
which would be Bad News Bears
but I guess we'll see
piranha and debug and see what's up
oh no hang on
no that's calling it on create method I
was gonna say maybe I just forgot to add
something somewhere
um to the run time but no this is run
this is calling on create
and I guess there's like some exception
well no it's not even the exception it's
just that
the method itself
I don't know what's wrong with it but
it doesn't seem like it's working
so level generator on create
is there anything weird with that
I mean yeah I could access prefabs and
stuff I don't think there's anything to
do with animation though
I only Built This now but
it was working in the editor so it
should have been built
nazarex is here hi
[Music]
um
yeah I don't know
I hate these exceptions but something's
null it looks like
wait this might just be a fake one
though but this looks real
uh but this is why I could get motion
properties that sounds like something
something a root motion Maybe
but maybe not
no this is just set after set
translation
so body as the body real but the body
has no motion properties
so that's upsetting
yeah this a sharp ones might not have
been real exceptions I might just have
been in court
like not actually unhandled or whatever
but just the alarm was raised anyway but
this looks like this is now
and why is that bad
is that bad
get well at odds because I guess the
assert is what's happened
that's null yes but also the assert
checks to say is static and I guess
the motion type is static and that's
supposed to happen if it's not static so
that's a bit weird
like why would that be any different
so that's root motion player on update
and we're trying to set the translation
hmm
yeah so we're trying to update the
player trying to set the translation
but this is bad because well yeah there
are no motion properties but also the
player apparently is static but it's not
whereas in the body shouldn't be static
but it seems to be but is this even a
real body well the thing is like
it looks like it is like those look like
legit values
object layer motion type is static
though
like it's not like it looks like it's
you know
wrong
and the body ID is there I guess
sounds a bit suspicious
as to get uid I mean that looks legit
it's not like I didn't find it in the
scene as well it did
just didn't return at all
but
[Music]
hmm
game settings no
no
thanks Andre
Mr Terry
um red login console
really
oh well let's just do a set
wait is it even trying to set stuff on
the rigid body I thought it was a
character control I don't know like I
don't know what it's trying to do I mean
it's trying to set the translation on
the body
right but no but really that's coming
from just setting the translation
um
right
so
we're just calling transform components
at translation and that in that little
root motion Player thing
um
like that is doing oh it's obviously
setting the translation somewhere
right I mean we're doing it
well it's doing it for many different
things for the gun for the coffee for
and for the pickup trigger I guess I
don't know which one it is because it's
just an entity ID like it could be for
anything I just know it's being called
from up trying to update the rude motion
player I think
so like you know it's not necessarily to
do with root motion
or like it's not necessarily trying to
set the player's position
it's just trying to set someone's
position like I mean the ntid is this
like we could try and search the scene
for it might not be there though because
it depends but
maybe that will give us some idea oh it
is it's a child it's the pickup trigger
so it's trying to set the pickup
triggers transform
which is a rigid body of type zero that
looks kind of static doesn't it
like zero I would imagine a study is
static so that's actually correct and
look layer three that's what we had
there as well
like if we're going to the call stack we
can see that
the body is layer three so that looks
like it you know static which is zero so
it kind of looks legit
but then
like
if we try and set its translation
wait hold on I'm a buffoon
as usual
because like the thing is we're trying
to get them we're just trying to get the
motion properties and check to see if
it's not null and if so we do this
but otherwise I guess it's static but
the problem is that get motion
properties has an assert basically
saying you can't call this
and what is this isn't Peter's class
right this is actual jolt physics so
you're not supposed to call this unless
it is static so I don't understand I
guess why we're doing this we should
probably be doing something like if
static else or something I don't know
right so we do that if it's static and
if it's not we do we do activate body
but
because like because the thing is you
can't do this if it's not that and I'm
running a debug build
like that's why the assert's going off
so I think that has something to do with
it but also like
and it's happening again
oh in set rotation this time
but like again I don't know why are but
also I wasn't running the editor in
debug but I ran this in release and it
didn't work either so this isn't the
problem but it's
a problem
that almost looks like it works
did we get one frame no
looks like a net finished though
whoa that is that is that is a call
stack right there
oh my gosh although it's recursive
actually
um
aha jolt character controller simulate
so this is looks like character control
or something
um
update supporting contact
wait what was the bug I said
oh it's Nan's beautiful
nuns all day long
so what is Nan hmm
what could be Nan
I mean that's also an assert but I don't
think somehow I don't think Nan is a
valid value
after there are a lot of assets going
off in jolt but they seem to be somewhat
runtime only are we getting any frames
no
I mean that can't be right can it where
is this coming from iov
get closest
everything's man
get closest points
the NB is Nan that's why I think
that's an output parameter I think so in
b
so in be excluding convex radius
so it's probably this get convex radius
convex radius is zero
that looks fine though
what
in ours in B so it's this yeah this so
this is an an
yeah because these vertices are none
because the transform is Nan
and that's M transform of the
that's a that's a member
transform that takes a point in space of
the clotting
yeah okay
so the two to one I mean they're all
known all the trans both transforms and
so where does this get set then
I guess it gets
it's the inverse transform in the center
of mass oh and that's not all as well
that's weird as well so Collide convex
has triangles doesn't work but why is
this not working in the editor it has to
be the blood you didn't want it to
collide with the character so maybe
instead of dealing with completely
I mean I don't think so we could try
delete it though
but like I don't see why that would be
causing anything any problems
because again it works in the editor and
it flows through the same code the only
difference is the
the data might be slightly different but
here's the blood particle I'm going to
delete it it's right where the FaceCam
was
and then I'm going to rebuild the asset
pack
[Music]
uh and then we'll run it
I guess in debug
and yeah same issue
we could run it in release but I think
it crashed somewhere else
ah well we rendered a frame
because I think I saw the Sky Box
or whatever that is
and we even see the little text in the
bottom left so definitely rendered one
for him
but then it's upset because of some some
here
climb plenty of velocity but see this is
in motion properties now
and applied gravity to somebody but yeah
the fact that this doesn't work in the
runtime is super annoying anyway we
don't have to deal with this now because
again this is kind of physicsy so we
could probably get Peter to do it it
probably would be more effective at
dealing with this problem
considering he wrote the physics system
um
so yeah I don't know and the fact that
it works here means it's probably
something somewhat minor
It's gotta be right
so I have faith
but it is a little bit upsetting
because I would love to run it in the
run time and just see like what the
performance is like and
where the bottlenecks are I mean I'm
pretty sure I know but
can never be too sure
let's see if we can get to the edge of
the world
that's a good idea
because there is an actual Edge I didn't
actually make it infinite
I could have but I did not
we've got a lot
the enemies keep spawning which is going
to make this slower as well
foreign
how far away am I from the origin
so 400 meters on Z and 280 meters on x
let's see it over here
anyway this is dumb
I'm gonna stop now um yeah
yeah the enemy's spawning now is not
definitely not final
um
kind of hard to kill I lost my gun
my gun's out of ammo
I guess I'm dead
no they can't get to me no they just
stop and then they still shoot at me
all right
um
the random blood the blood's not random
the blood is when I shoot them
that and that little blob there yeah
there was that one little piece of blood
actually
but that's not
um
that might have been because I pressed
Space by maybe
because there shouldn't be any blood at
the moment right oh and they obviously
that them shooting I mean there are
yeah it's because it's hitting me
probably or they're hitting each other
so there's blood
but that doesn't happen on the first
frame is my point so it shouldn't that
wouldn't cause that problem I think and
the point is it works in the editor so
it's not you know
it's like that shouldn't work
is it possible to move your character
with the mouse well you you look with
the mouse
but the character you move with the wasd
hears
um
hmm
so I could make I could make the
the water wave a little
kind of wanted to do that
um
it's really not critical though
or maybe she should make sure that you
can't go into the water
or if you do something happens I don't
know
I was supposed to test let's make the
world a lot smaller
because I did want to test because we're
not probably we're probably not going to
make it infinite like that
or like infinite quote unquote infinite
um
so like if I go to the edge of the world
what happens
because I can just fall off right
this is the edge of the world
down I go
um oh my coffee thank you
now Tim also had other textures that he
made
did he not so maybe let's check her
check that out
uh where are they
materials no I guess no measures Texas
grass tile
okay so if we look at
uh I guess the green
right hexagon green material
let's try Dragon the grass a little
bitter
excuse me
why does that not work
that's really weird
okay well that worked
um
that is weird
don't really
see the texture on it
now am I sure that
I mean I think the only prefab by
spawning in and the first one so as long
as the same model
Tim the heck they're all there's only
one hexagon model right yeah there used
to be more because I can't see your
texture on this and I'm wondering if
it's properly UV unwrapped or whatever
if it's the same hexagon it should be as
long no that's before then
so I changed the thing
oh okay I was also gonna say you're
wasting a lot of space here yeah
I realized yeah
okay so I need to pull
Okay so
let's see
oh there we go that just worked nice
the the sand actually as well yeah I
know
my orange material I believe
what's it called
cool
I mean yeah it'd be nice to have I mean
it doesn't make sense I guess but
it'd be nice to have a normal map or
something on these because a little
lighting would look cool
and maybe you could make the sides
something considering you can see the
sides yeah back when it was top down it
wasn't really but the reason why I kind
of like no I don't want to do that is
because you have to make them terrible
otherwise
uh and like it's kind of a bit of work
right
I mean this doesn't look bad though
because I kind of like the non-texture
look a little bit
so that's why I think if we can get away
with that I'd rather not to work because
that's going to take a lot of time yeah
yeah
what would you want the red one
well because the thing is like this
level generator like I can
spice it up like if I want it to be like
Cliffs or something kind of tall see I
can do that so maybe like a rockfish
um yeah
but uh maybe a rock's actually yeah I
mean
yeah
I don't know if that's good though
I need to play with this a bit more I
mean that's that's a bit this is a bit
more extreme now
I don't know like obviously like you
know level generation
spend weeks on it
which point we pivot to the extra format
I'll let them there
three weeks
but once you can jump this might
actually be nicer Hills because then
you're gonna
you know speaking of game Loop
yeah
you wanted to have it done by the end of
today right uh yeah but I think I had a
chat to Peter while you were away yeah I
kind of decided that he would do it like
when he comes back and I would just
focus on Lower generation and then if
it's still not done by tomorrow morning
I'll do it but he should have it sorted
because that's what he's kind of gonna
work on now Germans oh but also Yeah
Tuesday 11 A.M I have the whole day
tomorrow as well yeah
um possibly 24 hours if we just go up
from 11 to 11. uh
what else
um Peter also is going to
make it so that because currently it's
actually impossible to do what we want
uh in terms of the main cam mechanic
which is oh did I show you the coffee no
ah
we have a coffee
because Peter just thought this wouldn't
work but it worked really well
like wouldn't work on a technical level
so check this out this is the coffee
uh
and then
you know that's the coffee
and that's what we're trying not to
spill
um so yeah it works actually well yes
maybe yeah with a little I mean you
could just make it an Hazel but there I
think the walls have to be
.03 is the minimum so I guess
ltf
that would be cool because in this case
that would be useful you don't need to
explain Dimensions you just says yeah
Maybe
but um
so thickness has to be 0.03 you can't
have it yeah the walls can't be thinner
I think than three centimeters
because then
because then it's physics engine's gonna
yeah
but it looks like that's fine because if
you actually contrast this with the size
of the player
like it's actually this is almost too
small I think and we were thinking with
Peter that it might be nice to put the
coffee on the top of her head because
it's such a nice flat surface and that
way you'd actually see it
yeah and so like pick up you know
there's your coffee and see that's kind
of small I don't almost want that bigger
maybe that's maybe that's not a bad size
actually
and like you said it's like a platform
you know
but unfortunately at the moment this is
the problem well yeah and you can't make
it Fuller yep so because you need to add
a constraint and so Peter's gonna
basically do some Hazel work yeah and
make that happen
cool
my plan for today because I've finished
the towels basically I gotta make
um finish your guns yeah
I think you might be able to shoot the
coffee no you can yeah
no I meant my coffee
look at that yeah
but you have to be at the right height
no
it's what I thought that you added like
aim lock on or something like that
because no no you had a Raider felt
exactly on the coffee I'm like wait what
no I don't think so I also don't like
the fact that it like I'd like to kind
of be able to strafe you know what I
mean so I can shoot them while but I
can't because as soon as I press s he
does a 180.
I want him always to Face Forward
basically I think
I don't think he should no you can you
can still move around see maybe if you
want and then when you hit WC he just
goes straight towards where you're going
so if you want you can do that you can
admire yourself
and the coffee maybe we can even zoom in
and out
yourself with this yeah no there might
be there might be some
sharing these two
um or help me sell lots of them anyway
and I like how my flashlight's facing
backwards for some reason now
um but
uh my point is that
um yeah it'd be nice so that you know a
actually kept facing forward so you
could you know like whoa did you see
that guy float off yeah where did he go
there he is
low gravity I don't know man jolt is
like look at jolt like what's happening
bro
geralt is a bit like a bit of a clown at
the moment like I'm seeing some I've
seen weird behaviors I've basically just
been walking like a normal person and
then suddenly I'll Zoom fly in the air
like we're talking like 2004 physics but
it's better Integrity than physics yeah
maybe and it's also a lot faster but
that's you know is that a good thing I
guess so
anyway
well at the end it's about to use it
yeah
yeah all right guys we're gonna go for
dinner
um
I guess I'll leave a nice
let's take a nice screenshot for the
Stream
now that we have like
you know
kind of want
that looks kind of cool
I guess I should face oh but the
lighting looks cool
okay I like that but this guy raw into
everything for me so I'm gonna delete
him oh I can't delete him I can move him
away though
um
I don't know which one he is and it's
not
my lighting for some reason
that's a bit weird
crafting the perfect screenshot
it's probably the last one
where do we put him here
oh the get this is wrong because I'm not
in the editor camera I'm in the player
camera that's why
okay there's the game
pretty nice
uh all right
um
let's copy it
pop it in Photoshop
is this in metallics
what is going on with my Photoshop as
well here we go
yeah why is that in italics
that does not not kind of
kind of looks weird
I don't know what's going on why is that
an attacks
what the heck
hopefully this doesn't become a problem
later when I actually try and do
something
okay
see you guys soon
all right let's hop on back
um
let's see
how does this thing work
um all right
Koto plays thanks for the 20 sec
it's like Peter currency
and nice spotting on Tim's stream
saw me walk past
oh yeah dinner was great had some
dumplings
some Chinese dumplings this time
um all right
so I'm only gonna do like a couple hours
maybe uh
because it's gonna be time for me to
sleep after that
you know it's a tight schedule from
dinner to sleep
not a lot of time but um
in all Sarah since though I do want to
get some sleeps like a good amount of
sleep tonight like a while because
tomorrow I might like I'm probably gonna
do a 24-hour stream
uh because tomorrow's obviously going to
be like the last kind of day the last
full day
so I wanna
get some rest
um so let's jump in
uh
oh still running it's still running
that's funny my screenshot remember my
screenshot
uh okay so what are we doing
um I don't actually know
I don't remember what I wanted to do oh
I wanted to turn some music on
that's what I wanted to do
how many hours left like a day and a
half
so that's what like 36 hours yeah we're
about halfway through
and uh I mean we'll be halfway through
in like a couple hours
I think
unless I'm delirious
no I'm right
all right
and where's my music out
huh
okay music should be back
Okay so
um
I mean I guess the biggest issue at the
moment is probably the fact that
or
the fact that we just crashed
oh did we no we didn't crash what the
heck happened there
some kind of phrase
why does it keep adding 10 bodies in
bulk destroying body
oh they're shooting themselves
and that's funny particles
oh okay so yeah we want a jumping to be
a thing for so much work to do
let's see what what do you think like we
could do in two hours really because
that's like the time that we've got so
let's think about what we can maybe get
done in that amount of time
is Hazel available for Mac not yet
uh it does work on Linux though and Mac
I think it has been has been run on Mac
and it has worked well at least
partially
but um
we haven't done a release on
ah the whole coffee mechanic
one as well
it keeps freezing which is weird I think
that's uh
I don't know why that is but I will say
that I did leave Hazel running
when we went to dinner so let me just
restart it
because it's been running non-stop for
like three hours on that one frame
and who knows what it's done
[Music]
thanks learning opengl
I guess jumping is kind of important
well let's just get jumping to work
still don't really like the movement and
I might get Peter to redo it a bit
but I guess I could probably do
jumping
uh I thought I was spawning
the key code.space
oh that's in level General that's funny
so let's get rid of this because this
was rubbish this was just for testing
so we can actually get rid of this
[Music]
um
so update
update move state
there isn't is grounded so maybe we
could basically
uh
so I mean
let me just try
body
[Music]
oh there's actually a jump
with a towel thing
sorry that does simplify things
[Music]
just like that I can jump
I don't know why it's like jumping more
than once so
power
[Music]
that was the quickest
that was the quickest implementation of
jumping I think I've ever done
because it's just dot jump
ah well actually also that only happens
if I'm
grounded let me see if this works
yeah it's where did it about it jumps
twice though
I should have done pressed Maybe
that does seem to work
no well I can still jump more than once
without actually pressing
jump which is weird
oh yeah I made the world super small
forgot about that
yeah there's a lot of weirdness going on
with the jumping
but I don't really mind it
foreign
[Music]
so here's what I wanted to do I
basically wanted much bigger mountains
and stuff and I wanted to add snow
potentially so
uh let's do this let's go to level
generator I know it's a bit off screen
but I figured you guys would benefit or
would want to see the screen more
just clicking on all my entities here if
you really want to see what they look
like this is them
but um
uh if we go down to
so frequency let's just make that like
one for now
So that obviously gives us more kind of
diversity
what if I just make it like a lot though
I could add a bunch though but let's
just say like 10 right
no see that so that is kind of it's
almost like it's capped
um Microsoft I could have a multiplier
for it
um but basically if we just make this
frequency sure let's keep it at one
that's a start
um
the problem now obviously is that it's
too up and down so we want to smooth it
out
um and to do that all we really need to
do
is think about how we sample
the noise
because the cool thing about the noise
sampling
when we generate the noise values
is that we passed in a float so at the
moment we're just doing
this right and this is very arbitrary
but we could have a scale for it
basically that's what I'm trying to say
so if I have a scaled it's like say 0.1
uh and we do this
then it's gonna like basically
just spread it out over a much larger
area
so I can kind of literally increase the
scale while by decreasing I guess this
scale
so you can see now for example I have
it's a lot more kind of static like this
is way too much obviously
but the Peaks will go to the Peaks right
I've just enlarged like the size of the
map basically to make it so that it's
much more gradual which is kind of cool
it's a lot more flat but it's not really
flat like because if I keep going I'll
keep going higher and higher
um so that's kind of nice as well that's
obviously too much but
but what I can also do is obviously like
with that information
um
I can like say that that is in fact flat
but I can still increase it here if that
makes sense so if I multiply by 10 here
but multiply by 10 less
um that's probably true extreme
maybe let's do
a five
then you can see that I get my mountain
peaks but they're a lot more like it's
not flat anymore
so it's like I've just accelerated the
the change but this is still way too
smooth clearly it's not it's still not
giving me what I want
and that was just to prove a point but
that's because this is way too low so
let's go to like 0.5 for maybe
multiplied by something like four and so
now I'll have but you know there's also
like what I'm doing right now is pretty
basic because I'm just generating the
one noise kind of texture well the one
noise
it's not like a texture I'm just
sampling at the the function but I could
obviously do like a few and multiply
them together with certain rules and
that would make it be a lot better but
I'm not doing that
I'm keeping it simple because this is a
game jam and I have a other more
important things to do
but this kind of looks cool
um
so this is good uh I would just say I'd
say that's a good level maybe but I kind
of want
it to be a little bit more spread out
too
that's probably a bit better right
[Music]
I am tempted to add some Peaks though
because the thing is this is this is not
bad for a base landscape
but like it would be nice to have some
like Peaks you know
and that's not that hard to do
uh let me go back to having a bigger map
70 by 70. chunks
so
I'm out of that
also with that though if we do in fact
stick with that
um
this should change as well the colors
so that it's been more spread out
so sand I mean Sans really just around
the
jawline so we probably don't need too
much of that
like that's probably a good amount
then the rest really can be brass and
then it doesn't really make sense to
have that weird red one
we have rocks or something but
I guess that can be that and then
I guess that that red hexagon
material should really probably be like
white snow or something
that doesn't look Wild
yeah especially the white
yeah it is
crash
I guess that looks White
feels kind of yellow
because the lighting I think is a bit
yellow
ah they were using um
like yeah the enemies were using that as
well
okay let's keep it down like that then
just go into the materials
maybe you can actually emit a bit now
we'll just make it be a bit brighter
like a bit very low
because there's snow after all it's
clear it is quite reflective
on it
yeah that looks kind of cool and you can
actually see that a bit through the fog
um
like that's obviously too much but
yeah maybe 0.7
I mean that's probably too much
maybe like point five actually was good
which is a little something to make it
like a little bit more kind of special
and bright to be like on snow
now clearly the snow is not uh too like
it should be like a peak thing
so I think I think what I'm gonna do now
is I'm actually going to break my rule
and I am going to generate another noise
texture or another noise thing
so what I want what I want to do is this
is like the primary noise
um but then I kind of want to do
so this is like the base Terrain
and then I kind of want to do one that's
like just Peaks
more like mountains we'll call it
and I think what we'll do is we'll
probably generate the same amount
um but let's see uh I guess what do I
want to do the problem is it's very hard
to test this
um
because
what I should probably do is generate
some like
I don't know if that API still works
but I actually think I can create a
texture out of it
and the reason why that might be useful
is just for visualizing it
I don't know if I want to test that out
now though
um
but my idea is basically to create
something that's like really quite
sporadic
and will be just like a lot higher
and then if it's above a certain
threshold on an area that where a
mountain could work
we could replace those with that I think
so that's kind of my point my uh
my thing
but I guess we could still make the
mountain go from zero
yeah I guess we would ultimately
um but like I just don't know if I said
just plant like you know
do something like this
hmm
I don't know
on the other hand
the problem is that I want it to be for
an entire area so I'd have to
like
no I mean the thing is so if I multiply
it by the noise value right
um well this is gonna look rubbish but I
just want to see what it looks like
yeah that runs everything else but I'll
basically like what I kind of want to do
is so I think I still want like a
fairly decent scale
um
so that was a bit too extreme but
I can maybe boost this but
I guess the idea is I'd only do this
I'd basically uh
foreign
would be
Max would be one
so the minimum I'm setting the minimum
here to one so it doesn't go below one
so it's only capable of making it higher
but then I also kind of want to
um
because see that's not I mean I guess
the scale is just bad though
but I'm it's because I played with the
frequency and stuff but I don't know how
that works really
and so that just kind of sucks
it's hard to do it's really hard to do
without visualizing this properly
all right I don't know if I should
bother
with that
okay now I think I want to give up on
this
um but the annoying thing is like I
can't easily I don't know why it's like
it doesn't let me
oh no that's not bad actually
like it doesn't seem to I was gonna say
it doesn't seem to let me
bump this up but I think it does no but
look it doesn't there's still a cap to
it
I think the frequency yeah that's that's
the frequency of of the wave so I I
really do have to just play with this I
think
but I can also play with the frequency
somewhat still
and then I can just lower the scale
and so that will get me higher Peaks but
a bit spread out and if it's too like
too much like this then you fix it by
lowering the scale
to smooth it out
um but I guess it's still not
like necessarily that great
because even though this gets me higher
low
and I need to start doing some
actual like
let's just let's write some code
to the player maybe gets pushed up
um
so when this these initial chunks get
done
now how do we get the player
get player chunk index
I should be able to get the play a tile
to check it's basically it's transformed
it's translation and push the player
above that that's what I want to do I
think
so um
it's not used
don't want the answer though
Maybe
um all right so
no but that's not the actual chunk
though that's the chunk index globally
I Wanna Know
I want to know something else I want to
know which actual chunk we're in
I mean I guess I can get the chunk index
of the player and then
I want to do this without like I want to
do this properly like without
cheating basically and using like the
physics the physics right casters will
need to get me the entity because that's
um
if I get the chunk index
uh
uh um and then I can
so that can get me something like minus
three minus three
but then I need to know where that lies
within my current
thing
no I can't quite sample the noise map at
that position and use that height
because there's a lot of modification
that happens to that to land to wind up
with a final translation so what I
really just need is the stupid like I
just need to know which chunk I'm in and
then which tile I'm in
within that thing
I mean oh but the chunk has a chunk
index so actually I could just search
for it
yeah I forgot about that
so let's just go through uh
chunk chunk
in
chunks
this is a bit lazy but
gets the job done so now I need to know
where I am within that chunk
uh and I think I can do that by
basically doing like
do I obviously I should know what the
offset of this is right
yeah I think if I do
oh this is tough but
um if I do
because the chunk has
an entity the root entity
and that has a
that has a translation basically the
local translation is the World
Translation so if I so that's kind of
like the offset
and actually if I do XZ
no that kind of gets me the offset as
well
um because I don't care about the Y
that's just the lateral that's just like
the yeah the kind of
horizontal I guess
um
and then
I can I think I can just take the player
actual player translation
right
and subtract this offset from it
and that gets me a normalized kind of
this is like a chunk space
uh position
and if I then take the X and divide it
by I think two
and then divide the Z by
2 times 0.86 or actually it's called a z
tile offset
um
sorry The Wire
so that's two that is a zed
um then that I believe
gets me
the I think the coordinate which if I
then floor it
and now I have
[Music]
what
happened ah
I'm about to do the card
lots of mistakes kind of getting tired
um
so are you serious
so what now I can use this chord in that
chunk
are you joking this looks like I don't
know man but if I use that within the
tiles
y
times
chunk size
I think I get my entity
oh my gosh
what an interesting thing
surprised to be really honest
um
[Music]
foreign
player dot translation
uh
I'm just going to set it to be like the
player tile.translation
oh y plus like two so oh one two so it's
two meters above the thing apparently
I'm always setting the wire to be every
frame
two meters above the current tile that
we're on okay well that seems to work
for that
and that and uh why am I always on water
yeah
I mean seems legit
I mean like yeah that seems to work
somehow all right so that's good because
now I can just do that you know one
second one person
here
and so basically what this does is it
spawns the player
actually above the terrain
probably even do one meter
drop dramatically
I kind of like the dramatic drop though
well that doesn't work
I think two meters is nicer
this could be like a little rounding
error I don't really know I don't really
care
that's cool we've got kind of like
almost like biomes here we've got some
Snowy Mountains
but the the snowy mountains I guess they
start kind of too soon
um
I kind of feel like there should be more
grass
there's a lot of water
it's quite a bit of grass
but I feel like we've kind of lost just
normal planes
like because now it's very mountainous
I guess it'd be nice like why not set a
level like
what's interesting is that like
what we should do we can generate
different Terrain
types you know like because then
um
you know
like height modifier
you know water level
so water level I don't know what that is
by default
let's take a look but the high modifier
for example
you know that can be this
um and then High modifier can be a
random.florid so we had five so let's do
like two plus random uh hazel.random dot
float like times
well three would make it up to five
let's make it like I don't know seven
and then the water level what's the
water level
we basically add an offset
somewhere
to translation y there it is two so two
is kind of the default water level but
maybe we can make it anywhere from
zero
to like 10 or something I don't know
like you know we can play with these
things
um so that it's a little bit more random
like as in you know so this can be like
this would be a lot of water this might
be too much water there's like an ocean
and then it's like kind of a flat
landscape I guess
it's kind of boring
but then there also might be something a
little bit more fun
or like this like that's really steep
it's steep but like I guess wasn't
guess maybe you'd want to also play with
this frequency though
so frequency modifier
could also be something that you do
and I and the last thing I think would
be scale
modifier
but also why is it doing all of this
every time we set the chunk that's just
a waste of
processing we should have done this
when we do the noise values
that way everything's set oh well
there's a scale well our scale's pretty
small there
I guess we can multiply it
by that and make it naturally a bit
bigger
I don't know if that's a good idea yeah
so we can get something that's a little
bit more
kind of like this
and it might be this is very tall this
is like unplayably tall
so that means that
this probably shouldn't go
that high
oh wow
but what I guess what I don't like is
you're kind of stuck with that
that's like the whole map you know
I can see the chocolate
you're kind of stuck with this like it's
not going to change because the chunks
don't change like it doesn't change
which kind of sucks like
because you know I mean I could
obviously
it's dangerous because this could be
zero so like if I add like at least
a little bit to it that'd probably be
better
but it might be able to go too high like
this or whatever but I don't know it's a
combination of all of these things
though
that's fun like this is just probably
too smooth see
so that means the scale is too low
this is like a very mountainous Terrain
it's quite a smooth one
but yeah the bad thing is there's like a
variation I guess it's just like this is
good for a base terrain these are all
good for bass terrains
but it's just nice to be able to be like
but here is in the middle of this
there's a mountain
but I'm not really sure how to do that
easily
I don't want to waste too much time
because I've already spent quite a bit
of time
but you know what happens if you get a
map like this I mean it's fine I guess
you can still survive obviously
it's funny how it basically ended up
making like almost hexagonal Minecraft
I definitely did not think we'd be
making this
[Music]
I'm out of ammo
whoa look at this world
no that's crazy
especially if you supposedly can't walk
on water
but the you can still kind of climb this
because the
character controller
makes you kind of pop up to the edge
I mean I guess these are all playable
technically I mean this one's just like
it's so boring though
foreign
[Music]
now that's unplayable there right
there are gaps in the level
because of how steep that is
oh here's another Mega tape one
so that means the top end is probably
too much
is that the scales problem
or the frequencies
or the hot knob it's probably the high
modifier
and this is kind of tall
but still playable
looks kind of uniform now
I'm just going through this to see if I
can find anything that's
ridiculous but
do you guys like the speed of this uh
start stop by the way
fast from the unity okay
oh this is tall this is tall but not
unplayable
[Music]
because I'm pretty sure I could probably
even get to the top
[Music]
yeah challenge accepted I mean challenge
completed
[Music]
foreign
you guys can't see this but this is
coffee
um
here it is
see there's kind of like coffee on you
it's it's like here
and you have to not spill it but work
kind of haven't made that exactly work
yet
but
that's the plan of the game you have to
deliver the coffee without spilling it
yeah you wouldn't tell from this game
would you that's what it's about but it
is and this doesn't really look like a
war zone which is what it's supposed to
be
turning out to be a bit of a disaster
foreign
have a look at the let them dead
page
see if
there's any ideas we can steal
I like weapons
10 weird weapons didn't we
cool what do you think of these
[Music]
that was a battle
check it out I got um
different types of terrain so you can
get kind of flat terrain you can get
mountains terrain wow you can get
anything in between really can I play
just walking orders yeah at the moment
yes but is that what we're gonna be
doing I don't know
I feel like this is I feel like we're a
bit in over our heads
but you know this is nice and simple if
you had some buildings here or something
so you can deliver the coffee
because it looks Bland but like you
don't want this terrain to be
can I need some kind of indication it'd
be good if there was some variants as
well like meaning that like if each of
these was a slightly different color
although maybe that's fine
yeah
what are they expecting here like three
different bearings or ten different
birds
the main thing is
and also technically if the different
materials that can't be batched together
so I mean they can't be instance
it's so weird
this like massive ocean
quickly had a boat like in Minecraft
because this is like I'm telling you
this is awesome this arsonist endless oh
where's my asses are
bro why are you floating after me
Tim look at this this enemy chasing me
he's just like I bumped him a bit and
he's just like floating
look at him
how's how is this a horror game
atmosphere
this stupid ammo counter that Peter
added is reminding me of forests a
little too much
day five still no land
I'm beginning to lose hope
I think that's Ryan is practically
infamous
which is great for a delivery game
[Laughter]
I found land I knew it was there I knew
my algorithm wouldn't fail me
my algorithm
oh and looked I made the snare kind of I
used your trick of making it a bit of
mess
and it looks kind of cool because it
almost looks like yeah see how it's kind
of reflective a bit it's like a bit
bright yeah
I mean to be honest that is our snow
type
White
did you make a snow tile
that is yeah yeah
I don't need a snow tile you're white
it's nice it looks like snow yeah
do you want it but I'm still making
Rockdale though
I guess yeah I guess so
yeah
cool
you really need a debug camera I have a
debug camera here it is
so I can say this is me moving and the
camera as you can see is independent I
can play it from this view if I want
I love the dude it's just built into
Hazel
alt C
gets you into debug camera
yeah
assuming I come in
um
I'm gonna have um I'm gonna try and have
some of this
trees
[Music]
I guess there
and uh I guess tomorrow
[Music]
it almost looks like the camera stops
right like
yeah but it's not it's just that I just
chose a very successful angle
but if you went a little bit that way
you'd end up in Natalia
okay good thing you didn't make it
two-sided
I don't
think it does yeah because you have to
that's a pipeline thing
[Music]
the fog is too much the fog is because I
need to hide the tile loading
um
it's not really I wouldn't really have
it like that
it's just if I don't that's because the
tile like the way that the tiles are set
up are not it's not ideal
uh it's going through the
like each tile is an entity
you know that old thing so
Jade is still here somewhere
so like if I don't how if I just hide
the fog for a bit
then like
you can say the distance is kind of
short
I could make it longer at the expense of
performance maybe the fog thing can be a
performance setting
um
well let's try it would that even work
though
I mean I did write the code somewhat
responsibly
like who's in
by that I mean
Tim's laughing in the background
um by that I mean if I change one value
it shouldn't break the algorithm like I
should be able to customize it a little
bit
or did I
like if I make this five by five
that's not gonna work is it
okay I think it is yeah
yeah there we go right
that's further right
[Music]
seven
that's probably gonna be too much
that's a lot of tiles I really should
make the tiles behind you not visible
but I didn't
it's gonna crash that's two of those two
taking too long
[Music]
too long hey we crashed why did we crash
because we're beyond the end of the
vertex buffer
that's probably because we're out of
transforms that's the transform buffer
so three by three and five by five
with higher in the middle
505 should work it's
but it's still not very long
[Music]
again this is just because it's because
this approach sucks
um and I'm well aware of that
that almost doesn't look like it's
actually any bigger though
I guess it is though yeah
nothing to do with calling uh it's just
you actually don't really need culling
for this finally enough like this will
be this is fine from a rendering point
of view like from the GPU point of view
everything's beautiful it's not GPU
bound whatsoever because this is all
instanced
um it's
the CPU is the problem
because each one of these is its own
entity over here in the hierarchy
uh with
um a rigid body and a mesh collider on
it each individual piece and that's just
way too
slow
like I mean I guess if you were
really good you could maybe but I
probably wouldn't even bother bashing
them all into one piece of geometry
because you can just instance them
and that's that's honestly fast enough
and you could you know if you put the
noise if you put the you do need to
generate a collider for them
and occlusion calling like Hazel kind of
has that
but the thing is they're all they're all
one you none of these would be occluded
though you know it'd be difficult to get
something occluded it would just be on
the other side of the mountain you know
what I mean like nothing here would be
included just this stuff would kind of
be occluded but what happens is Hazel um
does like uh
does per pixel like
uh what is it called like depth
rejection or whatever so the point is
like there's no overdraw anywhere in any
of this
like literally if this pixel of this guy
is behind that
it will never get drawn on a on a per
pixel level because we have a special
compute Shader that runs before we
render anything
that basically determine yeah for a
second
I think I'm back now internet scratch
for a bit you guys hear me
I was just saying that notice like that
there's a computer that runs in Hazel
um before you render anything that
determines which pixels are going to
make it to the final buffer
um and that way we don't waste time
calculating anything that doesn't need
to be there
of course it's still like you know have
to process all the vertices and do all
this other stuff
but
it's it's reasonably fast from the GB
side of things
but the downside really is
[Music]
the uh
the CPU in this case
um all right anyway let's do this
foreign
let's put the fog back on
it's probably too tall as well now
kind of reminds me Mario
I almost kind of like how it was before
I started adding this
which I don't think it's too difficult
I think I basically just had Heights the
original values were like
were height on two
oh actually water level wasn't too I
don't remember what height was height
was like five wasn't it frequency
modifier was just one probably in scale
modifier
maybe it was one
like this was more or less the original
was it maybe not
because that doesn't quite look right
that just looks
I thought this was more or less
I guess I can go back on stream and see
what I did
but
don't really remember
thank you
oh I still have a Time score here
shouldn't that be linked to the height
modifier
but also why do we do that if we already
multiply it a bit in a different place
then you could just increase this you
know
so I don't know
foreign
[Music]
like you'd want some more Hills
maybe this is a bit better
but also I feel like um
like this scale modifier right
oh it gets multiplied by that let's not
do that this one's gonna be way too much
yeah
but that's kind of cool like
I feel like we just
you know reduce it
and then you can do times point five or
something or even point two because it
should be quite low
so we can get something pretty flat
but that's probably too far that's why I
wanted the plus length
zero one
let's see if that's a bit too extreme
makes me think this should be lower
[Music]
yeah like I feel like it's better when
the world is a bit smaller you know
it was kind of fun
and then yeah this just looks better
when it's more miniature I think like
this
all right what do you guys think
isn't this kind of more fun
I mean you can originally get I mean you
can sometimes get this world
but it should be rarer to get that
you should get something a little bit
more
you know
like this basically
so it's cool yeah good people like that
not doing biomes um
super flat world would suck yeah it
would suck but also it might be you know
there might be less cover so it might be
harder in a way
I don't know
um all right
that's good I'll try and Commit This try
um I will commit this uh so Peter
gets it
sure
I don't know if we need this
why not
[Music]
so there's a yeah all the engine changes
oh
wow
[Music]
thank you
that's all my coffee
foreign
[Music]